WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN URGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SHOULD HEAR TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL- WITH SOME- ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
THE- MEMBERS. OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MINUS SENDER STERN
WILL BE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
HEARING- THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY
AIDED DEAL ELIMINATING THE
ACOUSTIC. FEEDBACK PASS IT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE TO RESTRICT THAT
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU WILL BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK THE POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO FIND ME PLEASE
SELECT ME BEFORE YOU START
SPEAKING ARE I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON IT WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKESURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. ONE OF
THE ASSET BACKED ACCESS WE'RE
MEETING. OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THIS HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THE SOUL FOR THIS THING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW ONE. WILL
ALSO BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WITH WHICH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
PARTICIPATE TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. YOU WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
THIRTY ONE. THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE THE ACCESS
CODE AGAIN IS THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
COMMITTEE WEBSITES WE WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
AGENDA. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
THE MODERATOR TO ONE TEN ZERO
PRESS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LIE NUMBER. THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE THE LINE NUMBER. YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME HE WILL BE A
NEEDED. ME TO BE READY TO TRUST
THIS COMMIT. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR- YOU
CLEARLY INTERVAL WITH ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU TO MISS ME YOUR
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON ON PRIOR TO TESTIMONY
OF THE PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING BECAUSE HIS CUSTOMER IN
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE ROAD
MEETING SERVICE. OUR HELP THEIR
CONNECTIONS MADE. PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD. AFTER ALL
DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN PRESENT-
LASTLY FOR WROTE EVERYONE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE TODAY-
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON
COVERING. YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES. THROUGH NO NEED.
HAVING HEALTH WOULD SEE CERTAIN
. MEMBERS CALL THEM- ITEMS
BEFORE THEY CAN ARE A WHOLE OPEN
BUT WE- BUT WE STILL WANT TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON THEM. SO
WE'LL BE. BEGINNING WITH- AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION NET
METERING. EFFORTS AND THE- FIVE
P. U. C. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT. GOOD MORNING. QUESTION
ONE YOU SAID GOOD MORNING NICE
TO SEE YOU. YES HELLO GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS SIMON BAKER
I AM THAT INTERIM DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ENERGY
AND CLIMATE POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. IT'S A PLEASURE
BEING HERE JEREMIH COSTLY AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. HOW TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE CDC'S ROLE MAKING
ON NET ENERGY METERING AND JUST
AS A POINT OF PROCESS- I DO HAVE
A SLIDE IN MY AM I THE ONE TO BE
SHARING A SLIDER SO I JUST I GO
THROUGH THIS VERBALLY. I THINK
IT'S YOU. OKAY GO AHEAD.
THAT'S
LIKE SHOWING UP. VERY GOOD
PERFECT AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
TODAY. OKAY. WHAT IS THAT ENERGY
METERING OR NAM NAM AS AN
ELECTRIC RATE CHARACTER THAT
ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO GENERATE
THEIR OWN RENEWABLE ENERGY SO
CALLED CUSTOMER GENERATORS TO
SERVE THEIR ENERGY NEEDS
DIRECTLY ON SITE AND TO RECEIVE
A FINANCIAL CREDIT ON THEIR
ELECTRIC BILLS FOR ANY SURPLUS
ENERGY FED BACK TO THEIR
ELECTRIC INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
. AS DIRECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN BY EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN. THE TURF WAS
LAST UPDATED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO ALIGN WITH MARKET CONDITIONS
AND CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS. S. DECISION ADOPTING THE
CURRENT NANOSTRUCTURE THE
COMMISSION STATED ITS INTENTION
TO REVISIT THE POLICY. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN MAJOR CHANGES TO THE
TERROR OR DEFERRED DUE TO THE
LACK OF INFORMATION ON THE
BENEFITS AND COSTS OF THE
CHANGES TO ALL CUSTOMERS AND THE
ELECTRIC SYSTEM AT THE TIME. AND
ALSO BECAUSE RESIDENTIAL
RATEPAYERS WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF TRANSITIONING TO TIME OF USE
RATES. SO ON THE SIDE I HAVE- A
TIMELINE OF SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS IN THE PRECEDING. IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY THE RULE
MAKING WAS OPENED. AND THEN IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE OR ALJ
PRESIDED OVER A PRE HEARING
CONFERENCE WITH THE PARTIES AND
THE ASSIGNED COMMISSIONER ISSUED
A SCOPING MEMO OF THE ISSUES TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THE PRECEDING.
FROM JANUARY TO FEBRUARY OF LAST
YEAR. THE ALJ ISSUED A RULING.
WITH A STUDY THAT WE CALLED THE
LOOK BACK STUDY WHICH WAS
ESSENTIALLY A VALUE AND
EVALUATION OF THE CURRENT
MEDICARE. AND ALSO A WHITE PAPER
PROPOSING A SUCCESSOR TARIFF
FRAMEWORK. STAKEHOLDERS ARE
PARTY'S BEEN SUBMITTED COMMENTS
AND REPLY COMMENTS. WORKSHOPS
WERE HELD AND THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED A DECISION REGARDING
GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR A
SUCCESSOR CARE. BAN IN MARCH
THROUGH AUGUST OF LAST YEAR
PARTY SUBMITTED NINETEEN
DIFFERENT SUCCESSOR CARE
PROPOSALS. THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST IN THIS PROCEEDING AND
WE HAD BROAD PARTICIPATION FROM
MANY PARTIES. WE THEN HELP MORE
PUBLIC WORKSHOPS AND THE PARTIES
PROVIDED THEIR OPENING TESTIMONY
AND REBUTTAL TESTIMONY. AND THEN
THE A. L. J. POSTED AT TWELVE
DAY EVIDENTIARY HEARING PROCESS
AND THE PARTIES PROVIDED THEIR
OPENING BRIEFS AND REPLY BRIEFS
. FROM SEPTEMBER TO DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR AT THAT POINT THE
EVIDENTIARY RECORD WAS COMPLETED
AND THE ALJ DEVELOPED THE
PROPOSED DECISION OR P. D. AND
E. D. WAS RELEASED FOR COMMENT
ON DECEMBER THE THIRTEENTH. SO
MOST RECENTLY- PARTIES HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTING THEIR COMMENTS TO THE
PD. AND THE CQC HAS YET TO TAKE
UP THE PD ADDY BOATING MEETING.
MANY TAKEHOLDERS ON ALL SIDES
OF THE ISSUE HAVE MADE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIRTY MEETINGS. AND
THE COMMISSION CONTINUES
INTERNAL DELIBERATIONS ON THE
MATTER. COMMISSIONERS ADVISERS
HAVE TAKEN DOZENS OF SO CALLED
EX PARTE MEETINGS WITH PARTIES
AND STAFF HAS MET FREQUENTLY
WITH PARTIES TO INFORM THESE
DELIBERATIONS. NOW GOING FORWARD
TO SEE IF YOU SEE PLANS TO HEAR
PARTIES ORAL ARGUMENTS. IN AN
ORAL ARGUMENT DATE THAT HAS YET
TO BE ESTABLISHED. AND ALSO TO
CONSIDER POTENTIAL REVISIONS TO
THE PROPOSED DECISION. IF I
COMMISSIONER HAS YET TO ANNOUNCE
A SPECIFIC TIMELINE FOR A
DECISION BUT THE MATTER IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE COMMISSION.
THAT WAS THE UPDATE THAT I HAD.
FOR TODAY AND BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY ANY QUESTIONS. DOLLAR YOU
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- THE INFORMATION SO I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- SO.
WHAT I READ IN THE IN THE-
INFORMATION THAT WAS AVAILABLE
TO ME WAS THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THIS THESE RESOURCES AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO. ALL PEOPLE-
ACTUALLY LOW INCOME PEOPLE GET.
THEY'RE GONNA CHANGE OVER FROM
GAS TO ELECTRIC OR IS. HELLO
FIVE ON THE WRONG I'M ON THE
WRONG ONE SORRY ABOUT THAT. SO
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SOLAR- ON THEIR
ROOFTOP AREN'T PAYING FOR THE
GRID- AT THE SAME RATE TO PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE SOLAR- AND HOW
DO YOU PROPOSE THAT THAT'S FAIR
TO THE PEOPLE THAT THAT. DON'T
HAVE SOLAR. RIGHT. SO THIS IS
THE BALANCING ACT THAT- THE
COMMISSION IS IN THE PROCESS OF
WORKING THROUGH IN THE PRECEDING
B. TWENTY THIRTEEN STATUTES-
THAT- WE ARE OPERATING WITHIN
THE BOUNDS OF- PROVIDES THAT THE
- DEAD DEAD MAN TERRORISTS- MUST
ENSURE THAT THE SOLAR MARKET
CONTINUES TO GROW SUSTAINABLY.
AND ALSO THAT THE- THE COSTS TO
NON SOLAR CUSTOMERS IS MINIMIZED
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S REALLY DAY-
BUT THE CHALLENGE IN THIS
PROCEEDING AND- AS I NOTED
EARLIER AGAIN JUST AS ROBUST
DEBATE ON ALL SIDES OF THE ISSUE
ABOUT HOW BEST TO. HOW BEST TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE- THE ALJS
PROPOSED DECISION. PROPOSES TO-
ESTABLISH OUT WHAT'S CALLED A
NET BILLING TERRORIST. THAT HAS
FOUR KEY COMPONENTS THE FIRST
COMPONENT WHICH HEY MATT BILLING
CUSTOMERS OR NEW SOLAR CUSTOMERS
FOR THE ELECTRICITY THAT THEY
EXPORT TO THE GRAD BASED ON ITS
VALUE TO THE GRAD- CURRENTLY-
BAD ENERGY METERING CUSTOMERS
ARE ARE PAID ESSENTIALLY THE-
RETAIL RATE- FOR- ELECTRICITY
AND SO- THE PROPOSED DECISION. I
PROPOSES TO PAY BASED ON THE
VALUE TO THE GRID AS MEASURED BY
THE AVOIDED COST THE UTILITY
WOULD OTHERWISE PAY FOR CLEAN
ENERGY ELSEWHERE. THE SECOND
COMPONENT IS THAT- THE NET
BILLING TARIFF WOULD CHARGE- SO
NEW SOLAR CUSTOMERS FOR THE
ELECTRICITY THEY RECEIVED FROM
THE GRAD BASED ON- AT A TIME OF
USE TARIFF THAT HAS A HIGH
DIFFERENTIAL. WHAT THIS WOULD DO
IS IT WOULD INCENTIVIZE THOSE
CUSTOMERS TO INSTALL MORE
STORAGE- AND DISTORT THE SOLAR
ENERGY AND SHIFT THEIR EXPORTS
TO LATER IN THE DAY WHEN IT HAS. MORE VALUE TO ALL RATEPAYERS.
TEN THIRTY IS THAT IT WILL
CREATE A- JUST CHARGE- WHICH HAS
BEEN- CALLED OUT THERE IN THE
PUBLIC DISCOURSE BY SOME AS A
SOLAR TAX- AND THAT WOULD BE
BASED ON THE SIZE OF THE SOLAR
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT NET
BILLING CUSTOMERS ARE PAYING THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FIXED COSTS OF
THE ELECTRIC RED- AS AS NON.
SOLAR CUSTOMERS AND THEN OUT
FORCEFULLY I'M THAT BILLING
TERRACE THAT IS WHAT'S PROPOSED
WHAT ARE PROVIDING A MARKET
TRANSITION CREDIT OR OR A
SUBSIDY THAT THE CUSTOMER
RECEIVES FOR TEN YEARS SO THAT
THE CUSTOMER CAN PAY BACK THE
COST OF THEIR OF THEIR- SOLAR-
PLUS STORAGE ENERGY SYSTEM IN
LESS THAN TEN YEARS. AND THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO GROW- AND THAT
ROOFTOP SOLAR REMAINS ECONOMIC
BUT THAT CREDIT WOULD STEP DOWN
OVER TIME SO. AS A NEW CUSTOMER-
TODAY WOULD GET- WILL GET HIGHER
SUBSIDIES AND I KNEW CUSTOMER
NEW SOLAR CUSTOMER- NEXT YEAR
AND FOLLOWING IT STEPPED DOWN
OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD. SO THIS
IS- HOW THE ALJ HAS PROPOSED TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF COURSE
THERE ARE MANY PROPOSALS THAT
ARE ON THE RECORD AND
PROCEEDING- BETTER- BEING
CONSIDERED. AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS. SO WHAT ABOUT THE EGGS
. SOLAR ALL. ROUTE OR EVEN
COMMERCIAL I GUESS SOLAR IT'S SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO BEAT THEIR
THEIR EXCLUDED FROM THIS PROCESS
EVEN THOUGH- THERE. GETTING A
SUBSIDIZED BASICALLY THEY'RE
SUBSIDIZED BY THE LOW INCOME
RATEPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
CAN'T AFFORD TO PUT SOLAR ON
THEIR HOME. RIGHT SO AND IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE
COMMISSION REVISED ITS NOT
ENERGY METERING POLICY- THE
APPROACH THAT WAS TAKEN WAS TO-
TO ESSENTIALLY LOCK IN THE- THEN
THAT ENERGY METERING ARRANGEMENT
FOR A PERIOD OF TWENTY YEARS.
AND THE INTENTION BEHIND THIS
WAS THE PART WAS TO PROVIDE SOME
STABILITY TO THE MARKET PLACE
AND ENSURE THAT CUSTOMERS WHEN
MAKING AN INVESTMENT THEY- ARE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE A REASONABLE PAY
BACK PERIOD. THE PROPOSED
DECISION OF THAT MINISTRY OF LAW
JUDGE I WOULD PROPOSE TO CHANGE
THAT- FROM A TWENTY YEAR- A LOCK
IN OF THAT ARRANGEMENT TO A
FIFTEEN YEAR AND SO AFTER
FIFTEEN YEARS- ON THE EXISTING
SOLAR CUSTOMERS WOULD- WOULD. GO
ON TO THE- THE NEW MAPS BILLING
STRUCTURE. OKAY SERVER MY LAST
QUESTION IS I'M VERY FRUSTRATED
BY THE FACT THAT. THAT PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T AFFORD SOLAR ARE
PAYING FOR PEOPLE THAT CAN'T
CAN'T AFFORD IT AND THEN THERE
GET THEIR RATES ARE ACTUALLY
GOING OUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THE GRID. AND THAT
FOLKS HAVE SOLAR DON'T SO WHAT
IT WHAT IS THE- I GUESS. THE
FRUSTRATION COMES FROM THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A P. YOU SEE JUST
HOW THE AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY- THE ACTING ON
THIS ON THESE ISSUES OR IS THIS
JUST GOING TO HAPPEN THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION. RIGHT SO THE CQC
IT. DOES HAVE THE AUTHORITY THAT
WAS GIVEN IT GIVEN TO IT. UNDER
THE TWENTY THIRTEEN STATUTE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH PROVIDES THE- THE
GOVERNANCE FOR THAT NET ENERGY
METERING PROGRAM. AND WITHIN
THAT STATUTE- THE COMMISSION
WAS- WAS DIRECTED. TO ACCESS
THAT THE COMMISSION MAY REVISE
THE- THE TERRACE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE TO ACHIEVE A NUMBER
OF A JACK OBJECTIVES THAT WERE
STALLED OUT IN THE IN THIS- THAT
SECTION OF STATUTE WHICH
INCLUDED ENSURING THAT THE THAT
TERRORISTS- ENSURES THAT THEIR
CUSTOMERS CITED RENEWABLE
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION MARKET
CONTINUES TO GROW SUSTAINABLY
AND INCLUDE SPECIFIC
ALTERNATIVES. DESIGNED FOR
GROWTH AMONG RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- IT ALSO REQUIRES
THAT- ENSURED THAT THE TERROR
YOU MADE AVAILABLE TO ELIGIBLE
CUSTOMER GENERATORS THAT'S BASED
ON THE COST AND THE BENEFITS. OF
THE RENEWABLE ELECTRICAL
GENERATION FACILITY AND THAT
THAT TOTAL BENEFITS OF THE
TERRORISTS TO ALL CUSTOMERS AND
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM OUR PROXIMITY
EQUAL TO THE COSTS- IT ALSO AS
REGARDS THE POSSIBILITY OF A OF
A FIXED CHARGE- FOR SOLAR
CUSTOMERS SWITCH AND IT HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL
ELEMENTS OF THE- DECISION. THE
STATUTE PROVIDES THAT- BAD AT
ANY SIX CHARGE FOR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS GENERATORS I SHALL BE
AUTHORIZED ONLY IN A RULE MAKING
PROCEEDING- AND THAT- THE
COMMISSION SHALL ENSURE THAT
THOSE I'VE GOT THE CUSTOMER
GENERATORS ARE PROVIDE ELECTRIC
SERVICE AT RATES THAT ARE JUST
AND REASONABLE. SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE PARAMETERS THAT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS- PROVIDED TO
THE COMMISSION. TO GUIDE OUR
PROCESS- ESTABLISHING. A I JUST
AND REASONABLE CARE. BUT EVEN
THAT THE- COMMENT I WANT TO
MAYBE PUT IT IN THE TERMS IT IT.
JUST FROM A FROM MY SIDE OF. THE
SITUATION IS THAT WE BASICALLY
THIS LEGISLATURE GAVE THE POWER
TO. THE PC WHICH IS UP
APPOINTED. BY THE BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
APPOINTS THOSE FOLKS AND WE GIVE
THEM FREE REIGN TO BE ABLE TO GO
AND CREATE THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
PUT A SYSTEM RIGHT NOW THAT WE
HAVE. IS IF YOU HAVE ROFTOP
SOLAR OR YOU HAVE SOLAR AND YOU
CAN AFFORD IT. THAT YOU'RE
GETTING A BENEFIT AND THE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THAT CAN'T AFFORD
SOLAR OR HAVE THE MEANS TO HAVE
SOLAR ARE PAYING FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT. A SOLAR
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY- THE
WRONG AND THAT'S OUR TWENTY YEAR
CONTRACTS THAT AS WE KNOW-
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE
SKYROCKETING IN CALIFORNIA DUE
TO MANY THINGS A GRID IT'S
HASN'T BEEN MAINTAINED. A
WILDFIRE AND- JUST QUITE FRANKLY
THE COST OF GENERATION AND THE
ABILITY TO BILL TO GET WHAT WE-
ARE- GET THE AMOUNT THAT WE
NEED. AND SO I THINK IT'S-
BEHOOVES THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS AND NOT JUST
HANDED OVER TO. APPOINTED
BODIES- THAT CAN CAN MANIPULATE
THIS SO WHY ARE WE EVEN HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION IF THIS IF
THIS IS IT YOUR- AT THE PUC'S
LEVEL. SO WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
A PROCESS RIGHT NOW- OF REACHING
A DECISION ON THESE ISSUES AND
WE HAVE A ROBUST RECORD THAT HAS
BEEN. COLLECTED OVER THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR SO AS I WAS-
OUTLINING EARLIER ONE OF THE KEY
FACTORS THAT I THINK THAT. THE
COMMISSION- I TOOK INTO
CONSIDERATION AS IT FIRST-
ESTABLISHED REFORMS TO THE NET
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND NOW AGAIN AS
WE ARE REVIEWING THE MATTER IS
TO REALLY HAVE GOOD DATA. TO BE
ABLE TO- MAKE THESE DECISIONS
AND THAT- AND INFORMED FASHION.
AND SO- THE LOOK BACK STUDY THAT
WAS CONDUCTED. AND ENTERED INTO
THE RECORD OF THE OF THE
PRECEDING THAT WE'RE NOW
UNDERTAKING WAS REALLY A KEY
PIECE OF THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. OUT TO THE DEGREE
THAT WE HAVE- AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN WE FIRST REVIEWED THE
TARIFFS AND SO- WE BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST RECORD.
OUT TODAY TO BE ABLE TO- TO.
MAKE FURTHER CHANGES TO THAT-
THE PROGRAM- BASED ON SOLID
INFORMATION. WELL I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IN FUTURE THAT YOU
PUT ON. HAVE THE ABILITY. TO AS
INFLATION GOES UP WHICH WE'RE
SEEING. INFLATION WENT UP SEVEN
POINT 7% IN THE LAST YEAR YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THAT OVER THE NEXT
OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS. YOU
NEED TO HAVE. THE ABILITY FOR
INFLATION TO BE CALCULATED INTO
THE PROGRAM SO THAT. THE
DISADVANTAGED FOLKS THAT YOU.
THAT I HEAR ALL DAY LONG ARE YOU
SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING HELP IN
CALIFORNIA AREN'T PAYING FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
PUT SOLAR ON THEIR HOMES THIS IS
REALLY. A TRAGEDY THAT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ARE PAYING. A
HIGHER RATE. FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SOMEBODY WHO
HAS SOLAR SO WE NEED TO PUT IN
THE BILL YOU HAVE INFLATION SO
THAT THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING. SOLAR ARE
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT. AND THEY'RE
BALANCING THE BOOKS ON THE BACKS
OF. HARD WORKING POOR PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S WRONG. ALL RIGHT WHEN
YOU CLICK ON THAT SIR. LET'S
FOLLOW UP ON THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING THAT THE CENTER HAVE
A LEG TO BRING IN THE ALLEY-
BECAUSE- I VOTED FOR. AB THREE
TWO SEVEN BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND WE CERTAINLY
IMPLEMENTED THAT METERING AND
ALLOWED FOR A SUBSEQUENT
REVISIONS IN IT BUT HOW MUCH
LATITUDE DOES THE P. YOU SEE
HAVE TO CONTINUE MODIFYING THE
NET. ENERGY METERING
IDEA OF DIFFERENT CRITERIA THAT
THE PC I SHOULD BE USING WHEN
THE TERM INTERNET ENERGY
METERING STRUCTURE AND SO I
THINK THERE'S- OTHER THE
EXISTING KIND OF STATUTE
INSTRUCTOR DOES GIVE THEM THE
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT CONTINUED
TO MAKE CHANGES TO TRY TO COMPLY
WITH- KIND OF THE CRITERIA- AND
THE STRUCTURE AS OUTLINED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. OF COURSE THE
LEGISLATURE ALWAYS HAS SORT OF
THE OPTION TO- CHANGE OR MODIFY
THAT. I'M NOT AUTHORITY GOING
FORWARD IF IT FEELS LIKE SHE
NEEDS TO UPDATE THAT IN ORDER TO
KIND OF ACHIEVED A DIFFERENT MIX
OF BALANCE OF POLICY GOALS AND
SO- THAT'S CERTAINLY SORT OF AN
OPTION THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO
CHANGE BUT WE THINK THAT- ORDER
STATUS OF THE CURRENT. STRUCTURE
SORT OF YOU KNOW PROVIDES
DIFFERENT CRITERIA FOR EACH OF
THE COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH THE
STRUCTURE AND AS MISTER BAKER
MENTIONS REALLY DOES KIND OF
INVOLVED THIS SORT OF BALANCING
OF DIFFERENCE- GOALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS LAID OUT FOR THE
PC. WHEN ESTABLISHING A
TERRORIST. I GUESS THE- IS DOES
THIS DEBATE ON THEM REALLY TO BE
A ZERO SUM GAME. DOES IT DOES IT
DOES DO WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW
THERE ARE BENEFITS OF HAVING
ROOFTOP SOLAR. FOR A CLEANER
ENERGY MIX THAT WE HAPPENED
INFORMATION BEFORE THE P. YOU
SEE OF THE- ADVANTAGES THAT
WE'VE HAD- BUT IS IT POSSIBLE.
TO DO MORE FOR LOW INCOME- THE
COMMUNITIES IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IS. MY COLLEAGUE-
AND MOVE THE INDUSTRY IN A IN A
REGIMEN OF MATTER TO- AVOID THIS
AVOID THE COSTS. THAT WE THAT WE
HAVE THAT DOESN'T REALLY. AT
LEAST WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
GONNA BE THEDEATH KNELL TO THE-
TO THE INDUSTRY. YES SIR IS IT
POSSIBLE TO HAVE. THE BEST OF
BOTH WORLDS AND MOVE GRADUALLY.
I MEAN I THINK- I THINK IT ALL
KIND OF COMES DOWN TO BALANCING
I MEAN THERE MAY BE A DIFFERENT
WAYS- TO KIND OF STRUCTURE
PROGRAMS IN A WAY THAT YOU TRY
TO AVOID SOME OF THE- KIND OF
SHIFTING COSTS TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND KIND OF ESTABLISH
A STRUCTURE FOR THAT AND THEN
THERE'S THERE COULD BE SORT OF
ROOM FOR A NOTHER DISCUSSION
THAT'S RELATED ALSO ON KIND OF
HOW TO PROMOTE SOLAR ON LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR EXAMPLE
AND SO ANY KIND OF A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION COMES DOWN TO. YOU
KNOW WHAT SH FINANCING STRUCTURE
YOU WANT TO USE TO TRY TO
PROMOTE- AN INCREASE IN SOLAR
ADOPTION AND THE SOLAR INDUSTRY-
ANY KIND OF ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
WHETHER YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW
MUCH YOU WANT TO RELY ON KIND OF
THE HISTORIC IN EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF USING- KIND OF THE
NAME TERRORISTS TO DO THAT WHICH
DOES HAVE- SOME. POTENTIAL
REGRESSIVE EFFECTS VERSUS
RELYING ON OTHER KIND OF
FINANCING STRUCTURES TO ACHIEVE
THOSE TYPES OF- GOALS OF
PROMOTING SOLAR. YOU SEE ON THIS
AVOIDED COST VALUE DO YOU SEE A
GLIDE PATH THAT WE COULD PROCEED
OR IS IT JUST. FOR CHANGING
UNDER I GUESS UNDER THE
AUTHORITY WITH A. B. THREE TWO
SEVEN. RIGHT SO- ONE OF THE- THE
KEY ASPECTS THAT THAT THAT WE
ARE- EXAMINING IS HOW TO BRING
THE- I'LL MOUNT THAT IS PAID TO
THE- BEST SOLAR CUSTOMERS ARE
CLOSER TO WHAT THE VALUE IS FOR
ALL ALL RATE PAYERS AND THAT'S
WHY YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT'S BEING EXAMINED IS TO PAY
OUT BASED ON OF WHAT IT COSTS-
BUT TO- TO GET THAT RIGHT OFF
THE BAT IT COULD BE TOO ABRUPT
FOR THE FOR THE INDUSTRY TO BEAR
FROM THE- ECONOMICS PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE- FOR THE- IS THAT-
DISTRIBUTED. ROOFTOP SOLAR IS
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN- THE- YOU
KNOW UTILITY SCALE ALTERNATIVE.
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WITH- WITH EMPLOYEE COSTS AND SO
ON TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS A
COST DIFFERENTIAL THERE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A SPOT TO GET THERE. AND
SO THEN HOW DO WE HOW DO WE WHY
NOT DOWN. I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
WHY DIFFERENT STRUCTURES ARE
BEING EXAMINED IN THE PRECEDING
. ABOUT HOW TO PROVIDE SOME KIND
OF A SUBSIDY AND THEN- WIND THAT
SUBSIDY DOWN OVER TIME YOU YOU
MIGHT LOOK AT THIS SIMILARLY AS-
THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE- A
SUBSIDY PROGRAM FOR ROOFTOP
SOLAR AT ONE ONE TIME. AND AND
THAT WAS STRUCTURED TO BASICALLY
HAVE THE ASSETS TO BE HIGHER- IN
THE BEGINNING AND THEN WIND GOES
DOWN OVER TIME WITH THE- GOAL OF
HAVING THE HISTORY- SEEK. COST
EFFICIENCIES AND BRING THE COST
OF THE TECHNOLOGY DOWN OVER TIME
SO THAT THE SUBSIDIES TO BE
REDUCED I MEAN WE DON'T WANT TO
EXPERIENCE THAT THE GERMAN-
EXPERIMENT RIGHT TO SHUT DOWN
ALL THEIR NUCLEAR ENERGY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A FOR POLITICAL
DECISION AND THEN MOVED TO COLE
WE'D LIKE TO YOU KNOW I WHETHER
IT'S- REAL OR NOT. WE'RE SAYING
THAT WE SHUT DOWN YOU KNOW THE
ROOFTOP SOLAR INDUSTRY AND
PEOPLE MOVE TO BIO MASS
ELECTRICITY THERE'S A THERE
THERE THERE I CAN I AM. I LIKE
THAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE HAVE
A WE'RE GOING TO BE DELIVERED
CHIP AND WE'RE GOING TO DO A
BALANCING ACT BUT THERE'S
GREATER BENEFITS TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE- I GUESS SO
WHAT'S UP. NEXT I SAW THE GUY
WHO SAW THE GRAPH. STAKEHOLDER
IN. IT THIS. THIS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH BEFORE WE GET TO A FINAL
DECISION- HOW HOW IS THAT
PROCESS WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THE PROCESS GOING FORWARD NOW IN
MARCH. I GUESS THE TIME LINE.
RIGHT SO- THAT THE COMMISSION
MAKES ITS ITS FORMAL DECISIONS
BASED ON- THE RECORD THAT'S
DEVELOPED IN THAT IN A FORMAL
PROCEEDING AND SO AS I WAS
NOTING PREVIOUSLY- BUT NOT GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF OPENING A
RULE MAKING AND DEVELOPING A
ROBUST RECORD IN IN NOT
PROCEEDING AT AND THE RECORD IS
NOW- IN ESSENCE- CLOSED- AND SO
THE MATTER IS NOW BEFORE THE
COMMISSION- AND- PROPOSED
DECISION THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE HAS-
AND THEN BACK TO THE COMMISSION
ALSO HAS. HAS OPTIONS OUR
COMMISSIONERS HAVE OPTIONS TO
PROPOSE ALTERNATE PROPOSED
DECISIONS AND- HORTON OPERATIVE-
THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES MAY ALSO. MAKE REVISIONS
TO HER PROPOSED DECISION AND SO
THOSE ARE ALL THE OPTIONS THAT
ARE ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW AND
THAT'S ALL PART OF THE INTERNAL
DELIVERY PROCESS THAT. WE'RE
UNDERTAKING RIGHT NOW- AS FAR
AS- ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER AND
BUT IT'S REALLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING AT PUBLIC MEETINGS.
WHERE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN
COMING TO OUR PUBLIC MEETINGS
AND- AND MAKING THEIR OPINIONS
KNOWN BUT AS FAR AS WHAT THAT
THE PARTIES HAVE TO STAY ON IN
THE PROCEEDING- THAT THAT RECORD
HAS NOT BEEN DEVELOPED. IN ANY
IN ANY ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OUR
CLIMATE IN TEXAS ALL IT'S BEEN
RECEIVED INTO THE RECORD.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT IS
ADDED. IT'S TIME THE FEDERAL
PROCEEDING IT WHATEVER YOU'VE
RECEIVED TO RECEIVE. THAT'S
CORRECT AND IT IS A VERY ROBUST
RECORD. OKAY TRUMP I KNOW THAT
SENATOR STERN HAS WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN THIS TOPIC HE IS
CONTACTED ME HE'S BEEN UNABLE TO
APPEAR BECAUSE OF A FAMILY-
CIRCUMSTANCE SO HE'S- WE MAY
SUBMIT SOME QUESTIONS TO FOLLOW
UP ON ON THIS- BUT THOSE ARE THE
PICTURES OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
HAVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING. WE WILL- THIS IS
INFORMATIONAL WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. PACKAGE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE. SOMEBODY FROM THE AIRPORT
MR SIKONG HEN MR BORN FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING- CHURN REMEMBERS IS
SERGIO AG O. R. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL
ACTUALLY TAKE IT OFF AND THEN
I'LL GET OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AT
THE AIRPORT AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO BROTHER LIBRARY
OUT THE CAMPUS. HELLO IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT- WE
COMMITTED ABOUT THREE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THREE YEARS
OR THEIR MISSION VIEJO
COLORATION AND I THINK WE DID-
YOU KNOW MARKET CHANGING OF
RESTAURANTS RANGING FROM ANY
UPGRADE SHRUGGED PRESIDENT WILL
BUT THERE IS. TO IT HELLO
RATING- AND EQUITABLE
ELECTRIFICATION OF PASSENGER
VEHICLES AND RAIL ALL COUPLED
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INCENTIVES FOR IN STATE
MANUFACTURING- NOW WOULD BE
GOVERNORS BUDGET BROTHER TURNED
BACK ADDITIONAL SIX POINT ONE
BILLION ONE TIME OVER FIVE YEARS
WITH A. BOOK BY COMEDIANS ARE
MOST IMPACTED. BRINGING THE
TOTAL AND THAT YOU ABOUT AND
BILL. OVER SIX YEARS WELL EVEN
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE HELLO CLAIM
AND CUT. COOL THEY HELP INCREASE
PRIVATE SECTOR CONFIDENCE- AND
ALSO ENABLE PARTICIPATION IN THE
MARKET ALLOWING THAT THEIR
MISSION INDUSTRY CAPITAL
CAPITALIZED ON SCALE ALL WHILE-
HAVING A. A OKAY- ON A DRIVING.
OUR DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT EACH. OF
CALLUM. MOST POLLUTING SECTOR
ALBUM GROUP PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALSO HELP REDUCE THE AGE
DEPENDENT ON ALL HOPE YOU. ARE
NOW THE BUDGET PROPOSES- TARGET
INVESTMENT IN ADVANTAGE AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES INCLUDING. I
TO INCREASE ACCESS THE BENEFITS
IN TRANSPORTATION AND ALSO MORE
THAN DOUBLED THE TARGET OR HEAVY
DUTY MARKET COLORATION. AND ALL
THE MANAGEMENT DO TIE IT BACK
DIRECTLY TOWARD COLLECTIVE THEIR
OWN MISSION- VEHICLE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY WHICH
ORGANIZED THE- EFFORTS AROUND
THE FOUR KEY PILLARS I WISH OUR
VEHICLES INFRASTRUCTURE END
USERS AND ALL THE WORK FORCE- SO
WHAT THAT WOULD TURN OVER- DO
YOU LIKE HOLLY- REGAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA. BOARD TO FURTHER
ELABORATE ON SOME. OF THEM THAT
WENT WITH WITHIN THE HOUR. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD MORNING SHOW
MEMBER AND THANK YOU TO MR ARGUE
ARE FOR THAT INTRODUCTION I'M
CRACKLED SINGLE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FROM ALL SOURCES AND
INCENTIVES A CART. I'M REALLY
PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY MY
INTERAGENCY COLLEAGUES TODAY.
BUILDING ON THE LEGISLATURE'S
LEADERSHIP WITH THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR THIS YEAR IS A PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO TRANSFORM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND
PRIORITIZED ACTIONABLE
TRANSITION ENSURING THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS SUPPORT ACCESS TO
CLEANER TECHNOLOGY FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS BEYOND VEHICLE
OWNERSHIP. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES TO DRIVE
SYSTEM CHANGE BY SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY BASED MOBILITY
PROJECTS TO LIFT UP PRIORITY
POPULATIONS EXPAND THE
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES THAT WE
NEED INCLUDING BICYCLING WALKING
AND TRANSIT. HELP TO TAKE CARS
OFF THE ROAD AND MAKE FOR BETTER
PLACES. AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR THEIR
OWN PUBLIC PROCESS THE CARD.
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE OUR JOURNEY TO
UNDERSTAND OR GROW AND GROW OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
TRIBAL NATIONS WORLD COMMUNITIES
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. RECOGNIZING
THAT IN ORDER TO REALIZE JUST
TRANSITION FOR ALL. H. AND
DIFFICULT UNLESS COUNTER. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALONE CARD HELD OVER
TWENTY PUBLIC MEETINGS AND
DOZENS OF INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS
SEEK INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
OUR ANNUAL FUNDING PLAN. WE HELP
COMMUNITY LISTENING SESSIONS AND
HEARD FROM RESIDENTS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN UNDERSERVED.
WE RECOGNIZE THE OVER COMING
YEARS OF NOT HAVING THEIR VOICES
HEARD X. INTENTIONAL EFFORT ON
OUR PART TO DO BETTER. AND WE'RE
BUILDING PROGRAMS THAT
SPECIFICALLY MEET THE NEEDS
IDENTIFIED BY COMMUNITIES AND
COMMITTED TO DOING MORE
IMMEASURABLE CLEARLY DESCRIBED
WAYS. CARB STANDS READY TO
IMPLEMENT THE FUNNY HOST IN THIS
BUDGET. WE'VE ALREADY MADE GREAT
PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING THE
FUNDING APPROPRIATED IN. THE
BUDGET WAS OVER TWELVE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
ALLOCATED TO EXISTING PROJECTS
BENEFITING CALIFORNIANS AND MOST
OF THE REMAINING FUNDING TO
SPEED THE FULLY ALLOCATED. TO
PROJECTS THAT OF THIS YEAR'S
BATTLE QUICKLY RUN THROUGH JUST
ELEMENTS OF THIS PACKAGE. AT
LEAST THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE CARD. FROM MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE FUNDING TARGETED FOR
HIGHLY POLLUTING HEAVY DUTY.
VEHICLES TRANSFORMING THEM TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY WILL
EXPAND INVESTMENTS FOCUSED ON
PASSENGER VEHICLE INCENTIVES FOR
LOW INCOME LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
AND LIFT UP OUR MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THEIR COMMUNITY
BASED MOBILITY PROJECTS
ULTIMATELY STRENGTHENING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTNERSHIP
AND APPLE FIND THE KEY
PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED. IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
DELIVERING ON BOTH EQUITY AND
SCALE. ON THE RUN THROUGH A FEW
SPECIFICS FIRST WE HAVE THIS
PROPOSAL. COMMENT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INCENTIVES INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
LOW INCOME CONSUMER PURCHASES
INCLUDING CLEAN CARS FOR ALL.
FINANCING ASSISTANCE BRAND NEW
VEHICLE PURCHASES FOR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS ANOTHER EQUITY
PROJECTS FOCUSED ON LOW INCOME
YOUR CORNER SHIP WHERE WE KNOW
WE NEED TO FOCUS. INCLUDES ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY PROJECTS FOUR
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND. OVER FOUR YEARS.
TO SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE.
ATTENTION EQUITY PRICE. THANKS
CLEAN TRANSPORT OPTION. AND
THEREBY REDUCE VEHICLE MY
TRAVELED INCREASE ACTS TO ZERO
EMISSION WILL. AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IS LOCALLY DRIVEN
PROJECTS RESPOND DIRECTLY TO
CRITICAL MOBILITY NEEDS
IDENTIFIED BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RESIDENTS WORK IN
THE FRONT LINES LOOKED AT
PRAIRIE POPULATIONS AND FOR
CALLING FOR SYSTEM CHANGE. THESE
PROJECTS ALSO CONTINUED TO
IMPLEMENT THE ACTIONS INCLUDED
IN THE LOW INCOME BARRIER STUDY.
FOR OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS AND BUILD ON
THE VISION ADVANCED AND CLEAN
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS. THIS
INCLUDES LEGACY PROJECTS LIKE
CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS THIS IS
DANIEL TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECT CLEAN THE BUILDING
SCHOOLS. AND PROJECTS TO
FACILITATE COMMUNITY BASED
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS ASSESSMENTS
CAPACITY BUILDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OUTREACH WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT. WITH
THIS FOR A PROPOSAL AND IN
PUBLIC PROCESS I WAS ALSO
CONSIDERING BUILDING A PILOT
PROGRAM. IN CONSULTATION WITH
CAL STAR INCENTIVIZE AND REWARD
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES. TO RE
PRIORITIZING. THAT WAS SENT
EXPANDING TRANCE TO. THAT REDUCE
VMT. MINOT STATE CRIME AN GOALS
INSTEAD OF ROADWAY EXPANSION
PROJECTS THAT INCREASE THE ANTI.
BELLS WILL PROJECTS COULD
INCLUDE TRANSIT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION SPECTRUM MOBILITY
SERVICES CARSHARING VANPOOLING
NEW BIKES OR BIKE SHARING AND
OTHER INNOVATIVE INVESTMENTS
THAT REDUCE DEPENDENCE ON
DRIVING. ULTIMATELY THIS PART OF
THE PACKAGE FOCUSES ON
TRANSFORMING THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM WHAT IS THE BENEFIT
EVERYONE. THE NEXT PART OF THE
PACKAGE IS A MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY
DUTY AND OFF ROAD ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND OVER FOUR YEARS TO
DEPLOY APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
DRAYAGE TRUCKS THE PROXIMATE LI
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED TRANSIT BUSES.
PRODUCING HAVY DUTY VEHICLE
POLLUTION ACCELERATING
ELECTRIFICATION. FOCUSING ON
SOURCES THAT POST PARTICULARLY
HIGH EXPOSURE RISKS TO
COMMUNITIES. THAT INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME I'M GIGI R. F.
SUPPORT. ONE THREE ZERO EMISSION
CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT PRESS ARRANGE A
VEHICLE CLASSES INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTION AND AGRICULTURE.
THAT INCLUDES TWENTY FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
OVER FOUR YEARS TO BE ABLE PORT
ELECTRIFICATION. ALL LEVERAGING
BOTH BATTERIES AND FUEL CELLS
BUILT IN CLOSE. COLLABORATION
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION. I
THE PACKAGE INCLUDE INVEST IN
EMERGING UPPER. FOR CALIFORNIA
CITIES THIS IS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND TO
INVEST IN DEMONSTRATION AND
PILOT PROJECTS AND HIGH CARBON
SECTORS SUCH AS MARITIME
AVIATION LOCOMOTIVES OFFERED
APPLICATIONS. NUCLEAR IN
PROGRESS. THESE INVESTMENTS
COORDINATING CLOSELY WITH THE CC
HELP MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
AS THE HUB OF STAFF MARK
CREATION INNOVATION. AND
WORKFORCE TRAINING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES BOOK
CELEBRATING ZERO EMISSION
SOLUTIONS IN THE TOUGHEST
RESTATEMENTS THE TRANSPORTATION
ECONOMY. OVERALL THIS PACKAGE
THAT ADDRESSES EACH ASPECT OF
THIS CRITICAL SECTOR LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES. TO
SUPPORT SYSTEM CHANGE TO ADDRESS
HIGH POLLUTION SOURCES AND TO
FIND INNOVATION THE FUTURE. WITH
THAT I'LL TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM. HEAD AND WRESTLE WITH THE
EDUCATION THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HANNAH
RUSSELL AND I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FUEL
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
AUTHENTIC EXPRESSION. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PROPOSAL
WOULD YOU SAY THAT. I WILL FOCUS
ON THE PROPOSED ENERGY
COMMISSION DOCUMENT ANOTHER
COMPLIMENT THE CARBON BOUT THAT
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT. AGAIN I
WANT TO MENTION THAT WE FOCUS ON
EQUITY IN PARTY COMMUNITIES BUT
PURPLE CALIFORNIA MUST ABOUT AN
EQUITABLE TRANSITION TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE. CAN BENEFIT FROM
CLEANER AIR IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
NOT LIVE WITH LUCIEN OR THE
THOUGHT OF QUOTE. CALIFORNIA
ALSO. BENEFIT THE LOWER
OPERATING COSTS. HE I WANT TO
MENTION ROLE OF THE AND YOU CAN
MY CAR AND HOW WE HAVE TO BE
VERY COMPLIMENTARY ALL EVERY
CONNECTION FOCUSES ON THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT BOTH
ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RIGOROUS
ANALYSIS WITH PUBLIC FOLDER AND
BUT WE ALSO ENABLE BEITBRIDGE
INTEGRATION TO ENSURE THAT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE GOOD FOR
THE PEOPLE. OF THE GREAT. YEAH
MAKE KILLED INVESTMENT
TRANSPORTATION. OUT RECENTLY
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE AWARDED
THREE NEW AWARD FOR RENEWABLE
AND GREEN HYDROGEN PRODUCTION.
AND THEN HAVE YOU KNOW CAR FOCUS
ON THE VEHICLE IN FRONT OF THE
VEHICLE REGULATIONS. AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO CONTINUE THAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND ALSO HELP
THE CALTRANS BUILDERS AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES. AS WELL AS THE
PRIVATE MARKET. NATURAL GIVEN
OVERVIEW OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. OF THE PROPOSAL AND
AGAIN I REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE STRONG EQUITY FOCUS HERE AND
CREATING ACCESS TO HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS. YOU WILL BUILD ON
SUCCESSFUL INVESTMENT PROGRAMS
AND ALSO PROPOSED NEW WANTS TO
TARGET CAT. WE CONTINUE TO
LEVERAGE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
THROUGH MATCH FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS AND WILL INVEST IN
THE PRIVATE MARKET MAY NOT
OTHERWISE BE ABOUT. THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IS STILL ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIER TO THE RAPID
SCALE UP. OF THEIR MISSION
CRITICAL. PART I OFTEN FIND THAT
WE NEED A MASSIVE SCALE UP AND
CHARGING REVEALING A BROKER CAN
YOU TAKE OFF FOR TWENTY THIRTY.
WHAT WE WANT TWO MILLION.
REPORTER LIKE UNIFIED BY TWENTY
THIRTY APPROXIMATELY ANOTHER
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND THE TRUCK
WE BOUGHT THIS. WHAT GOOD
PLANNING YOU CAN'T WILL BE GOOD
FOR THE BIG RED AND ADD
BENEFICIAL NEW LOW TO MAKE THE
GRID MORE EFFICIENT. THERE BY
REDUCING ELECTRICITY COSTS FOR
ALL RATEPAYERS. CAN ALSO HELP
INTEGRATE NEW RENEWABLE AND
PROVIDE ONE PARTNER W. THREE TO
BUY DIRECT FUNCTIONALITY THAT.
CAN NEVER BE MASKED BY GOT A
GOAL. THE END OF THE CALL THE
ENERGY COMMISSION OF THE-
PROPOSAL FOR TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. TO BUILD OUT
TARGETS FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND
ALSO FEEL IMPATIENT FOR HYBRID
VEHICLES. ON THE LIGHT SIDE WE
FOCUS ON INCREASING ACCESS FOR
LOW INCOME DRIVERS AND PARTY
CANDIDATE. WE ARE REQUESTING A
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
NOT. AT ALL EQUITABLE AT HOME
KERR DURING WHICH A COMPETENT
BOTH MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS LIKE
APARTMENTS. AND ALSO LOW INCOME
SINGLE FAMILY HOME. WE KNOW THAT
AT HOME CHARGING IS A CHEAPER
FUEL COPPER DRIVER. IT'S VERY
GREAT FRIENDLY. MORE CONVENIENT
YOU ENTER. AND IT IS TO THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
DEPLOY IT A WIDE NETWORK OF
PUBLIC CHARTER. WE KNOW THAT NOT
EVERYONE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
CHARGING AT HOME. THEREFORE
WE'RE PROPOSING A BROAD NETWORK
OF HIGH POWERED BACK ORDER TO
CREATE ACCESS FOR EVERYONE. I'M
A FOCUS OF THAT PORTION IS ON
HIGH POWERED FAST CHARGERS. BUT
WE ALSO INCLUDE PUBLIC LEVEL
TWO. DEPENDING ON THE U. K. WE
WILL INCORPORATE GREAT
MEDICATION AFTER. SUCH A COLD
BLOODED FISHER ARE DIFFERENT. I
WANT TO NOTE THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE NEW VEHICLE FAIL. 12%
OF THOSE WERE THEIR MISSION
CRITICAL THIS IS THE HIGHEST
UPTAKE SO FAR WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE RISE UP TAKE IT BY THOSE WHO
LIVE IN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
ONLY TO BROADEN ACCESS FOR
EVERYONE. ON THE MEDIUM DUTY
HEAVY DUTY FIVE BITS OF TRUCKS
AND BUSES AND OTHER VEHICLES.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PORTION. AGAIN
BOTH FOR LIKE BRICK AND
HYDROGEN. AND THIS IS ANOTHER
EQUITY INVESTMENT KNOW MEDIUM TO
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE AND OUR
MISSION AND- DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
WE WANT TO CUT HARMFUL DIESEL
POLLUTION. OUT OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
WOULD YOU START A PENDANT AND
POPLITEAL. PROPHETICALLY THE
BUDGET FOR WORK- IT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR GREAT
. HUNDRED FORTY MILLION FOR
TRANSIT. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR A BROAD ARRAY OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROCUREMENT
VEHICLE AND EQUIPMENT NCLUDING
CLEANING CONSTRUCTION AND
AGRICULTURE. CREDITED A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TRANSACTION THE STATE COURT'S
DETERMINATION. YOU NEED TO MAKE
ME AN INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
HAD ONE VEHICLE TO DELIVER
INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS ARE GOOD
PAYING JOBS THAT CANNOT BE
OUTSOURCED WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
PART DOES. AND A FINAL BUCKET.
IS EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES BUCKET
FOR A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WILL AGAIN COMPLIMENT
CARBON DIOXIDE. AND AVIATION
MARINE LOCOMOTIVE AND ALSO AN
INVESTMENT VEHICLE GRID
INTEGRATION. DEVELOPMENT
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAINING THE
INNOVATION PIPELINE AND BRINGING
THOSE JOBS. AND INVESTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA. NO NEED ROCK MATURE
WE'VE ALREADY INTERNATIONAL DOT
NET AND THEIR ADDICTION WHAT'S
YOUR CARD I DON'T BE A GOAL AND
ALSO HYDROGEN. INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE MARINES THAT SPECIAL.
CONTINUE TO USE A ROBUST PUBLIC
PRODUCT THAT. WHAT A GREAT NIGHT
TO FORMER INVESTMENT THAT
NOTHING OUT THERE YET. BETTER
TECHNICIAN CARBOPLATIN EXCELLENT
COLLABORATION PLAN LOCKER ON- TO
CONTINUE BRINGING OUR UNIQUE
EXPERTISE TO TACKLE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS EVEN BY TRUCK BUT
THE DRUG MARKET DOT WAS RUNNING
VERY LED BY GO BIZ WHICH
ORGANIZES OUR EFFORTS WHILE THE
PRIVATE ACTORS PUBLIC. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND WILL PORT YOUR
QUESTION. WE WILL GET TO THOSE
QUESTIONS SHORTLY. A LOT OF
SHINY PENNIES HERE MISTER REID
MR BROWN HAD THE- ALEJO.
GOVERNORS AND- A FINANCE
DEPARTMENT SAYS HERE'S ALL OUR
SHINY PENNIES ON THE NEW PROGRAM
SO WE WANT TO HAVE GIVE US FIVE
YEARS HAVE NO OVERSIGHT DO YOU
HAVE YOUR CAN YOU PROVIDE US
WITH SOME INPUT ON YOUR VIEWS.
OF THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US-
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS START AGAIN
ROSS BROWN WITH THE L. A. O. WE
SO WE RELEASED OUR ANALYSIS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF PACKAGE
LAST WEEKEND SO YOU CAN FIND
THAT- COUNCIL AND ALSO SOME-
WEBSITE LA O. DOT CA DOT GOV.
YOUR GENDER ALSO HIGHLIGHTS KIND
OF A LOT OF OUR- COMMENTS AND
ANALYSES AS WELL SO I'M NOT
TRYING TO JUST TOUCH ON. WHAT I
THINK ARE SOME OF THE MAIN
POINTS AND CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS A BODY WHICH
THIS- YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSAL AND PACKAGED SO FIRST.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. WHETHER
THE BANK OPPOSES MIX OF SPENDING
OR A DIFFERENT MIX OF SPENDING
KIND OF BEST ACHIEVES
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND
ULTIMATELY. ABOUT JALEN CATIONS
FOR MOBILE SOURCE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE PROGRAM'S. GONNA
DEPEND ON HOW THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZES DIFFERENT POLICY
GOALS- SO FOR EXAMPLE. FOR MANY
OF THESE PROGRAMS. ALL THREE
GOALS ONE OR MORE OF THOSE KIND
OF THE FALL. YOUR NEAR TERM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS. NEAR
TERM AIR POLLUTING. OR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS. TAKEALOT TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENT WHICH IS YOU HAVE
SORT OF A GOAL OF KIND OF LONGER
TERM GHG AND AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS. AND ENSURING THAT
OUR QUALITY BENEFITS ACCRUING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO
THERE'S KIND OF A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT POLICY GOALS SO SCARED
WITH. WITH DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AND SO- I WANNA JUST MAYBE TRY
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS FIGURE ON
PAGE ELEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA SO
THIS IS ALL FROM OUR ANALYSIS-
AND REALLY THE GOAL IS TO KIND
OF TRY TO OUTLINE AGREED TO
WHICH DIFFERENT- AT LEAST KIND
OF CAR PROGRAMS- HEVS DIFFERENT
GOALS AND SOME OF THE INHERENT
TRADE OFFS- AND SO INCLUDE SOME
OF THE- PROGRAMS THAT ARE PART
OF THIS PROPOSED PACKAGE AS WELL
AS SOME OTHER. PROGRAMS THAT ARE
IN THAT PACKAGE THAT ARE THAT
ARE FUNDED ELSEWHERE IN THE
BUDGET AND SO. IT REALLY MEANT
TO KIND OF LAY OUT SORT OF YOU
KNOW WHICH PROGRAMS THAT SHEEP
WHICH OF THESE GOALS MOST
EFFECTIVELY AND SO. FOR EXAMPLE
TO THE EXTENT NEAR TERM
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS ARE
PRIORITY. AND THAT KIND OF I
KNOW. YOU JUST THAT. IT IS ONE
OF THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE.
PROGRAMS A THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS TIME- OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
MORE THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
TON AND SO THESE ARE. ALL THESE
ARE RELATIVELY HIGH COMPARED TO
SOME OF THE OTHER REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE HAS FOR
EXAMPLE SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND BUT- I GET. A COST
EFFECTIVENESS ON THE NEAR TERM
GREENHOUSE. GAS REDUCTIONS- YOU
KNOW MURDOCH IN LOK AIR. ARE PRO
. AND HEAVY DUTY WERE TO. OR PRO
SUCH AS FAR AWAY. AND THE
FORMER. APPEAR TO BE. A MUCH
MORE COST EFFECTIVE THAN OTHER
PRO- ON THAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENTS SIDE THIS IS MORE
OF A KIND OF A QUALITATIVE
ASSESSMENT BUT- YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT THAT SUCH. A PRIORITY ON
KIND OF ADVANCING TECHNOLOGIES
TO MEET SOME OF THE MORE LONG
TERM. GHG AND AIR QUALITY GOALS
THEN- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR KIND OF
HEAVY DUTY PILOTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS AND DOCTORS FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES WHETHER. THE
TECHNOLOGY IS MORE ON HOW THE
EARLIER STAGE. FINALLY IF A
PRIORITY IS REALLY ENSURING THAT
THOSE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS
ACCRUE MOSTLY TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT HOW
TARGETING FUNDS TO PROGRAMS THAT
REDUCE. POLLUTANTS COST
EFFECTIVE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
WAY AND WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
THE BENEFITS ARE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE.
PROGRAMS RELATIVELY OF ON THEIR
- SO. AND UNDER VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT MONEY IS SPENT SOME KIND OF
PRIORITY POPULATIONS SO. I THINK
THAT'S OUR ATTEMPT TO KIND OF
JUST MAYBE SORT OF FRAME SOME OF
THE TRADE OFFS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. FACES DEPENDING ON
ITS PRIORITIES AND HOW IT WANTS
TO ALLOCATE FUNDING. SO I'M NOT
TRY TO RUN THROUGH I'M CONSCIOUS
OF TIME HERE JUST A FEW OTHER
POINTS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
THINK ABOUT. ONE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WRECKED IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RECORD- AT BUDGET HEARING TODAY
ON JUST SOME OF THE DETAILS OF
SOME OF THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT
ARE PROPOSED A LOT OF THE
FUNDING GOES TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS. A COUPLE NEW PROGRAM
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE- NEW
EQUITABLE AT HOME CHARGING
PROGRAM- FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. GRAHAM TARGET
PRINTERS- YOU KNOW HOW OLD
BENEFICIARIES BE NOTIFIED OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE FUNDS. AND
HOW IS THE PROGRAM DIFFERENT
FROM OTHER STATE PROGRAMS THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT. INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS-
ANOTHER ISSUE WE WANTED TO FIGHT
IS- AVAILABILITY OF FEDERAL
FUNDING SO- THE PACKAGE INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION FOR EASY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE- FEDERAL
FORMULA. PROGRAM GRANT FORMULA
PROGRAMS FROM THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE BILLION
NATIONWIDE THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR YOU CHARGING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS. THE
DETAILS OF THAT HAVEN'T- BEEN
SPECIFIED IT'S NOT CLEAR IT'S A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR. HOW MUCH CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE BUT WE- WE DO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT THIS
SPRING ON ITS PLAN FOR ENSURING.
THAT STATE FUNDING FOR CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL COMPLEMENT
THIS NEW FEDERAL FUNDING. SO
COULD INCLUDE A DESCRIPTION OF
HOWSTATE FUNDING CAN BE USED TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
EXAMPLE. OR A FILLING MAJOR GAPS
IN IN FEDERAL FUNDING. AND AS
SUCH IS THERE STILL SORT OF IN
SUFFICIENT DETAIL AT THE TIME
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO ADOPT
THE BUDGET COULD CONSIDER.
DELAYING FUNDING UNTIL IT HAS A-
CLEAR PICTURE OF HOW STATE.
FUNDING COMBUSTIBLE NATURAL
SIGNING. AND THE FOURTH IN FIVE
THING- WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS-
JUST A BEING OF MULTI YEAR
ASPECT OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
THERE REALLY ARE TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING MULTI
YEAR OUT YOUR FUNDING WHICH THIS
PACKAGE DOES IT PROVIDES OVER
THREE BILLION AND- ABOUT YOUR
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENTS- SO ON
THE ONE HAND. COMMITMENTS CAN
PROVIDE. SOME BENEFITS IN
PROVIDING MARKET CERTAINTY AND
MAKING IT EASIER. FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO DESIGN PROGRAMS
AND ADMINISTER PROGRAMS SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE CAN PROVIDE MARKET
CERTAINTY TO BUSINESSES. ARE
CONSIDERING LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS
TRANSITIONING THEIR FLEETS TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
KNOWING THAT THERE'S- GOING TO
BE FUNDING AVAILABLE IN THE
FUTURE- AND ALSO GREATER
CERTAINTY EACH- CARD FOR EXAMPLE
AN INVESTOR IN THE FUND IN AND
DESIGNING PROGRAMS IN A WAY
THAT. ANOTHER BOY DESTRUCTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE. DESIGNED IN A WAY
THAT HELPS AVOIDING A WEIGHTLESS
GOING FORWARD. ON THE OTHER HAND
YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BECOME A MULTI YEAR
FUNDING PROPOSALS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION. DOESN'T HAVETO
COME BACK OUT WITH A KIND OF A
NEW BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL NEXT
YEAR- AND SO THAT YOU HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE OVERSIGHT
THERE ARE SOME WAYS AROUND THAT
BY. INCLUDING SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS- BUT ONE THING I
THINK THAT'S JUST KIND OF A
TRADE OFF OF THAT MULTI YEAR
APPROACH THE OTHER OF COURSE IS
IT DOES CREATE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL GENERAL FUND PRESSURES.
IN THE FUTURE YOUR SENSE OF
POLITICAL POINT STATUES JUST
THINK. ABOUT- ABOUT THAT TRADE
OFF. SO BUT TO THE EXTENT THE
ONE. DOES PROVIDE KIND OF MULTI
YEAR FUNDING PART OF THE PACKAGE
WE DO. THAT PRIORITIZE. THAT FOR
PROGRAMS WHERE IT KIND OF CAN
PROVIDE SOME OF THOSE MARKETS
SIGNAL BENEFITS TO BUSINESSES
MAKING US LONG TERM INVESTMENT
DECISIONS SUCH AS HEAVY DUTY.
AND OFFER A DOCTRINES. SO I WILL
IN MY COMMENTS THERE ARE OF
COURSE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF ANY HOUSE. YEAH I'M
YOU KNOW I WILL GET TO THE- THE
AIRPORT ENDED AND ENERGY
COMMISSION. WE JUST FOUND OUT
THAT ON FEBRUARY. TWENTY SECOND
THE AIRPORT. ISSUED SOME
REGULATIONS TO CHANGE THE
QUALIFICATIONS ON THE DAY. A C.
V. R. P. PROGRAM YOU KNOW WE-
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE. WORKED
REALLY. HARD TO GET FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE- MILLION DOLLAR IN
THE CV R. P. WHICH IS VERY
POPULAR AND- MR RUSSO. MADE A
COMMENT ABOUT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES GETTING ENCOURAGING THEM
TO BUY. A SOLAR ENERGY IN THE-
WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF ARE PUTTING
MONEY INTO IT- THE GOVERNOR
AGREED TO IT THEY'VE CHANGED THE
ELIGIBILITY TO REDUCE. THE ROUTE
TO REDUCE IT FROM THREE HUNDRED.
THOUSAND FOR A COUPLE TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND BASICALLY
ELIMINATING A WHOLE GROUP OF
MIDDLE CLASS FOLKS WITH VERY
LITTLE FANFARE. IN SOMEWHAT OF A
BETRAYAL IN MY MIND TO WHAT
WHAT. WHAT WE HAD AGREED TO LAST
YEAR IN THE THREE POINT NINE AND
SOMEHOW. I'M HEARING THAT THAT
WAS. LEGISLATIVE INTENT WHICH
IS. ANYBODY WHO'S CASUALLY
LISTEN TO ME UP HERE ANDTALK
ABOUT THE DESIRABILITY OF
HAVING. NO REBATES AND HAVING
CASH ON THE HOOD MUSTA MISSED
THAT- BUT- GOOD TO TRADE OFF
THAT WE HAVE I GUESS MY QUESTION
TO YOU. IS DO YOU WANT JUST CAME
UP WITH A REPORT AND SAID WE'RE
NOT GOING TO MAKE. OUR OUR THE
PARIS PROMISE OF KEEPING HEAT-
THE TEMPERATURE RISE TO BELOW
ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES. THE CELL
. AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
PACKAGE IN A LOT OF THIS IS A
LONG TERM VERSUS SHORT TERM. AND
LONG DISTANCE AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES IT DOES AS A
REFERENCE AND I SHINY PENNY MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL GOOD ABOUT STUFF BUT
DOESN'T DO THE WORK. IF I HAD
THE FIFTH YOU'VE SET UP FOR.
CRITERIA IF I HAD TO CHOOSE ONE
. FOR THIS FOR DRUG DRIVING
FORCE FOR LEGISLATORS LOOK AT
WOULDN'T IT BE THE SHORT TERM-
THE BENEFITS THAT WE CAN GET TO
THE TABLE THE WORLD DOESN'T HEAT
UP RATHER THAN HAVING THIS NET
ZERO IN TWENTY FORTY FIVE IF I
HAD TO JUST CHOOSE ONE I KNOW
ONE BALANCING AND I KNOW I'M
SACRIFICING THEIR QUALITY I'M
I'M I'M ACTUALLY SAYING IT OUT
LOUD. SO THAT THE AIR BOARD IN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION CAN HEAR
IT DON'T WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO REDUCE THE HEATING OF
THE GLOBE TO WITHIN ONE POINT
FIVE DEGREES AND THIS AND THAT
YOUR FIRST CRITERIA MISTER.
BROWN BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
JUST A POLICY CALLED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO- I THINK
DIFFERENT PEOPLE CAN KIND OF SEE
YOU KNOW PRIORITIZE. THINGS
DIFFERENTLY I MEAN I THINK IT'S-
CERTAINLY REASONABLE TO KIND OF
HAVE A NEAR TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS AS A- AS A KIND OF
CORE AND KIND OF TOP PRIORITY-
BUT I THINK THAT'S KIND AND- NOT
SOMETHING THAT KIND OF THE STAFF
LEVEL WE CAN KIND OF SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT SHOULD BE KIND OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WE DO THAT IT'S KIND
OF A POLICY CALLED THE
LEGISLATURE IS TRYING TO.
BALANCE ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
GOALS AND PRIORITIES BUT- WE DO
THAT KIND OF THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THOSE ARE AND TRYING TO BE AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE ABOUT. KIND OF
YOU KNOW WHICH WHICH OF THOSE
PRIORITIES IS KIND OF REALLY AT
THE TOP OF THE LIST AND THEN
KIND OF STRUCTURING YOUR BUDGET
PACKAGE KIND OF AROUND THAT.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. SO WE
HAVE. THE PRESIDENT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN. THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN. DISSECTING SINCE THE
SINCE NOVEMBER. AND I'M TRYING
TO. DETERMINE WHAT'S THE OVERALL
STRATEGY. BUT THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AC SOME.
PROJECTS ARE EXTENDED. OTHERS
ARE DISCONTINUED. BUT DO YOU
SEE. ON THIS. THE STRATEGY
LINKING LAST YEAR'S THREE POINT
NINE WITH THE SIX POINT ONE THAT
THE GOVERNORS ASKING FOR. THE
BECAUSE I'M GONNA ASK YOU AT THE
AIRPORT AND SEE SEE SEE WHAT YOU
WERE EXPLICIT DESIGNED TO
AUGMENT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. MR
BROWN YEAH I CAN DO UP TO THIRTY
ONE TAKE THE QUESTION ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT-
WITHOUT FOR ALL. I WAS GONNA ASK
ROSS FIRST BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO
LOOK AT THAT FOR THE FIRST
OVERALL STRATEGY FOR GIVEN WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
. AND I'VE BEEN OFF. YEAH SO I
MEAN I THINK IN GENERAL THE
STRATEGY CONTINUES HELLO I'M
JUST KIND OF PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING AS
PART OF LAST YEAR'S PACKAGE SO
IT'S KIND OF- YOU KNOW JUST SORT
OF EXPANDING THOSE IN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THERE ARE
SOME AREAS WHERE THERE ARE- KIND
OF ARE TARGETING SOME NEW- NEW
AREAS SO THAT AGAIN THE
EQUITABLE AT HOME CHARGING IS
KIND OF A- YOU KNOW A NEW FOCUS
OF THE PROGRAM IT'S KIND OF ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE- I DO I
DO THINK AGAIN IT'S GONNA BE. AS
I MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER
COMMENTS JUST THESE QUESTIONS
ARE. THE PACKAGE FITS IN WITH
WHAT FEDERAL FUNDING IS GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE OR IS ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE IS AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXPLORE AND- HOPEFULLY GET SOME
CLARIFICATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON KIND OF HOW
IT'S THINKING ABOUT. BOTH THE
FUNDING THAT THE STATE KNOWS
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE GETTING
FROM THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE AS WELL AS SOME OF THESE
OTHER. COSTS OF MONEY THAT ARE-
ALLOCATED ON ANY. KIND OF
COMPETITIVE BASIS AND SO. THE
DETAILS OF THOSE ARE NOT QUITE
CLEAR SO I THINK KIND OF
THINKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW HOW
KIND OF THIS PACKAGE CAN BE
STRUCTURED TO ENSURE THAT IT IT
KIND OF SNOW CAN COMPLEMENT THAT
MONEY AND- THAT'S AVAILABLE FROM
THE FEDS AND- IF THERE IS IN
GREAT DETAIL- THERE IS. WE'VE
BEEN KIND OF A STRONG RATIONALE
FOR- FOR THINKING ABOUT NOT
WAITING AND KIND OF GET IN MORE
DETAIL AND ENSURING THAT THE
MONEY THAT STATE IS ALLOCATING.
IS IS REALLY KIND OF JUST BEING
USED IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE
EITHER TO KIND OF LEVERAGE
FEDERAL FUNDING OR FILLING GAPS
THAT ARE- THAT MIGHT BE THAT-
THERE FROM FEDERAL FUNDING. S.
S. ROSS WHO IS THERE AN OVERALL.
STRATEGY GUIDING. THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. YES
STOPS. SO LET ME THINK ON THE
FEDERAL P. FIRST AND THEN I CAN
HELP HIM TO THE LARGE STRATEGY.
ON THE FEDERAL SIDE THERE ARE
TWO BUCKETS. THERE'S THE FORMULA
GRANT FUNDING. AND A COMPETITIVE
GRANT FUNDING. OF THE FORMULA
GRANT FUNDING THAT THAT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE MILLION OF WHICH
WHICH WILL COME TO CALIFORNIA
OVER FIVE YEARS. ABOUT SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. ON
FEDERAL GUIDANCE BUT BELIEVE. I
WANT TO TAKE THAT REAL LEVIN BUT
VERY RECENTLY. WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED AGAIN WITH A CALL AND
OTHER AGENCIES GREAT A CALIPHATE
CALTRANS. AND WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND FOLLOW THE GUIDANCE
WHICH IS FAIRLY LIGHT AT THIS
POINT. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO SUBMIT
PLANS BY THIS SUMMER. AND
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE APPROVED BY
THE END OF SEPTEMBER- THAT
FORMULA GRANT FUNDING TO CREATE
THAT DIFFICULT WORK WE SPENT. A
LOT OF PARAMETERS ON THE POWER.
OF THE CHARGERS. AND THEN THEY
NEED ALTERNATIVE FUEL CORRIDORS.
SO YOU KNOW. THAT ONE IS GOING
TO COME TO CALIFORNIA DELLA
COMPLEMENT WHAT WE'RE- ASKING
FOR HERE. THE OTHER DAY YEAH
THE- SO WE CAN BOTH HAVE A
ROBUST NETWORK ON THE ALTAR OF
BUCCAL CORRIDOR. WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND THEN ALSO
HAVE BEEFED UP THE THEM AND
PUBLIC CHARGING. ACROSS THE
STATE AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS A BASKETBALL I COMPLETED IT
AND REALLY BUILD OUT ALIVE WILL
NOT WORK. WE NEED. DO THAT
REALLY WELL. HE COULD GRANT HE
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION. ACROSS
THE NATION WHAT DO TRY TO BRING
AS ABOUT HELP. WE A FEDERAL
GUIDANCE HAS NOT BEEN REAL ON
THE YET. OPEN TO FEED IN THE
NEXT MONTHS. THE FEDERAL P. VERY
MUCH THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE-
LAST YEAR IS 80% FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND THEN TWENTY PERCENT- NOT
FUNDING WE WANT TO INCREASE THAT
LEVEL EVEN MORE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO USE OUR PROGRAM. TO
GET MORE AND MORE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT YOU MAKE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IN OUR STATE FUNDING GO
EVEN FURTHER. BUT OTHER AREAS.
NOW IT SHOULD JUST BE ABOUT THE
PACKAGING A WHOLE OUR STRATEGY
AROUND THIS BOOK TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE BUILT UPON MY- PACKAGE.
ON INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE- WHAT
WE'RE FORTUNATE TO GET FROM A
LOT OF BLOOD PRESSURE AND THE
FATE OF THE PURPLE BOX HERE.
WELL PROTECTED TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GOALS- BUT WE KNOW WE NEED
TO CONTINUE DOING MORE IN THE
EQUITY. THE BLACK CHARGE. A
BROADER. PCS NETWORK AND YOUR
POINT BEING. A MEDIA. CURRENTLY
YOU CAN BE DOING IN A LONG TERM
BASICALLY DOING REALLY PLAYS A
FACTOR CREATING ACCESS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND VEHICLE
PURCHASES SO WE CAN START
GETTING PEOPLE TO THERE MUST BE
A CULTURE TODAY I FEEL LIKE
EVERY PURCHASE THAT NOT OF THEIR
MAKING VEHICLE SUCH ANOTHER
VEHICLE ON THE ROAD TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS- SO WE WANT TO TALK
TO ALL OF THAT BUT LET ME STOP
YOU THERE YESTERDAY YOU HEARD
THE PRESIDENT SAY. THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN AN INFLATION PROBLEM AND
EVERYBODY WHO'S LISTENING TO
THIS AND IT'S NOT LISTENING TO
US NO STAT AND ONE THIRD OF THE
INFLATION IS. IS DETERMINED BY
THE VALUE OF CARS IN THE INSANE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE ARE PAYING FOR
USED CARS WE'RE IN THE WORST
POSSIBLE TIME TO ENCOURAGE POOR
PEOPLE OR FINANCIALLY CHALLENGED
PEOPLE TO GET INTO ABOUT TO
PURCHASE A- USED CAR BECAUSE
IT'S AT THE ABSOLUTE HIGHEST
PRICE IT COULD BE. MY THREE AND
A HALF YEAR OLD SUBARU IS WORTH
MORE TODAY THAN IT WAS. IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN I
BOUGHT IT THEN YOU'VE GOT A
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO GET A LOT OF. UNSOPHISTICATED ACTUALLY-
FINANCIALLY INSECURE PEOPLE TO
GO BY ZIPS NOT EXAMS RIGHT NOW
AT THE AT THE HIGH POINT FURTHER
FUELING INFLATION IN CALIFORNIA
HOW COULD THAT BE A STRATEGY I
MEAN I GUESS IT MAY BE A GOOD
STRATEGY BUT JUNE AND WE VOTED
FOR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION BUT NOW
CARBON IS ASKING FOR MORE MONEY
ON THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION YOU
GUYS ARE ASKING FOR AT THE WORST
POSSIBLE TIME. WITH IT WITH
INFLATION WE DO HAVE SOME
ECONOMIC CANNOT HEAR WHY WOULD
YOU HAVE THAT STRATEGY. WHAT
WOULD YOU NOT. CHILL OUT ON THIS
UNTIL THE PRICE OF USED CARS
CAME DOWN IN THE PRICE OF USED
CARS IT TOOK. A INSULT TO INJURY
THE CARD HAS NOW CHANGED THE CVR
PETE SO THE WHOLE BATCH OF
MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM. HOW
DOES THAT MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE I
GET THE SHINY PENNY I KNOW YOU
WANT EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD IN
CALIFORNIA HAVING A SET UP BUT
HOW DOES IT MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE.
TODAY RIGHT NOW GIVEN THE
INFLATIONARY PRESSURES FROM
EVERY CALIFORNIAN. JUSTIFIED. MR
REGULAR RUSSIAN ARTIST YOU'RE
SICK ALL. A DIFFERENT STRUGGLE
ARE FIRST AND THE GENERAL BUDGET
PRIORITIES HAPPY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE PROGRAM STYLE I DON'T KNOW
IF THE LEFT WANTS TO JUMP IN.
YES SIR I AM PART OF FINANCE
YEAH I THINK THE CAN READ THEM
PLACE AN ISSUE DEFINITELY IF I'M
THE KIND OF WORK MONITORING. I
THINK YOU KNOW REGARDLESS WE
THINK EITHER STILL SOME.
CRITICAL CARE METHODS THAT HELP
ACCELERATE OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFORMATION GOLD. BALL DRIVING
ON EQUITY. AND YET THIS POIGNANT
KATHY HOW LONG B. INFLATION
ISSUES WILL LAST- BUT THESE ARE
OUR MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT THAT
WE ARE PROPOSING HERE OVER OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. BACK AND HELP THE
DRIVE. AND FURTHER SUPPORT
LOCAL. COMMUNITIES I'LL BE ABLE
TO- ABOARD. OR OR AT LEAST HAVE
SOME. ADDITIONAL INVENTIVE BAND
AND FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET
SOME OF THE- COSTS OF- THERE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE. WE SHOULD HAVE
BREAK IN WE GET IT AND RUN AWAY
AND- YOUR- YOU'RE MISSING THE
POINT YOU'RE SPURRING INFLATION.
AND ADDING WHEN YOU WE HAVE
BUDGET OPTIONS WE DON'T HAVE TO
GIVE MORE MONEY FOR CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL OR- OR OR MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY HAS IS IT WE CAN PUT
OTHER- QUALITY. CARBON REDUCTION
PROGRAM SO WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
WHOLE SUITE OF THEM BUT THIS
THIS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST.
COMPONENT THAT FUELS INFLATION
YOU GUYS ARE DOUBLING DOWN. THE
RESTRICTIONS COMING UP AT THE
WORST POSSIBLE TIME. AT THE
WORST POSSIBLE TIME. MR RUSSELL
TWO THIRDS OF THE PROPOSAL THAT
YOU HAVE HERE IN THE IN THIS SIX
POINT ONE BILLION- BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET IS FOR HEAVY DUTY
AND MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT SEEMS LIKE A
LONG TERM INVESTMENT VERSUS A
SHORT TERM INVESTMENT WHY FOCUS
ON THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY-
SECTOR WHAT SPECIFIC OUTCOMES
ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING FOR HERE.
AND HOW WILL THEY HELP US WITH
OUR CLIMATE AND AIR QUALITY
GOALS AND- BE SPECIFIC PLACE.
YEAH I COULD PICK THAT PRECEPTOR
CYTOMETRIC CRACK ONCE BECAUSE
THE CAR PART OF THAT- ON THEIR
PERFECT YOUR SIDE WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS
EARLY. TO HELP MAKE THE
TRANSITION HAPPENED AND IT
REALLY IS GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY I
MEAN I HAVE TO TELL YOU THERE'S
A REASON WHY A LOT OF ANTI.
GLOBAL ARE MAKING A SELECTION
VEHICLES ARE OFTEN CHEAPER TO
OPERATE LESS MAINTENANCE. LOWER
FUEL COSTS WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THAT IT'S A GOOD FOR OUR
BUSINESS IN THE CALIFORNIA. GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S
GOOD FOR ECONOMIC OR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. EITHER
VEHICLE THAT. GENERALLY RUN ON
PEOPLE. REALLY POLLUTING WE KNOW
WE TO GET THE UPPER. THEY AHEAD
OF TIME AND IT DOES TIME TO
BUILD UP. THAT THERE COULD BE
ANYWHERE FROM. NINE MONTHS TO
YOUR PROJECT GET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT. SO WE NEED
TO MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS TODAY.
AND WE HAVE THE PROGRAMS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED. KEEP HELPING THE
POOR THESE BUSINESSES THAT WANT
TO DO THAT. PROBABLY IN THE
MEETING THAT YOU HAVE THE
DESPAIR BUT ALSO VERY TARGETED
IN PLACE OF LIKE FRIENDS ABOUT
THE- ALTHOUGH IF YOU USE THE
TRANSIT THAT THEM. AND ALSO PORT
EQUIPMENT BURGER YOU HAVE BEEN
WHILE. THAT WE THOUGHT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
MAKING INVESTMENTS THERE. TO
BUILD ON THAT. I MEAN WHEN I
THINK AND WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
PICTURES. JUST ROWS AND ROWS OF
COMBUSTION TRUCKS COME IN AND
OUT OF AIRPORTS. WE'VE SEEN YOU
KNOW THE GRAY SKIES IN THE IN
THE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WHO'S
SEEN THE MAPS OF ACCELERATED
CANCER RISK. AND ACCOUNT
DECLINING AIR QUALITY IMPORTANT
FREE COMMUNITIES. THIS IS JUST A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AREA AS A
MATTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH. ALSO.
ALSO. WE'RE HANGING ON THAT WORD
IT'S ALSO. WELL I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS MR IDEA ARE YOU CAN
INVEST IN FIXED RAIL FROM OUR
PORTS TO MOVE CARGO TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE THE SAN JOAQUIN
AND HAVE ZERO EMISSIONS WHY TWO
THIRDS OF THIS INVESTMENT GOING
IN TO. HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND
CREATING WORSE IS NEAR ZERO
EMISSIONS YOU KNOW WHAT I AM
TRYING TO CREATE THAT TO FOCUS
IN ON THE NEAR TERM WE CAN DO
THINGS FOR. NEAR TERM EMISSIONS
FOR. BIO FUELS TO BE MIXED WITH
WITH DIESEL THAT WOULD REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN THE SHORT TERM AND
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY. TOMORROW
BUT WE'RE GOING FOR THE SHINY
PENNY AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHY
THESE CHOICES. WE'RE DOING OUR
PART OF FINANCE I GET A LITTLE
BIT IN TERMS OF THE KIND OF
HIGHER AMOUNT YOU THAT WE HAVE
ON THE HEAVY DUTY PRIDE THOUGH.
I THINK NEAR KNOWLEDGE AT THIS
SEGMENT IS IT A LITTLE BIT OF A
LESS MATURE SEGMENT THAT DON'T
NEED ADDITIONAL OR AT THIS
STAGE- AND BIG KNOWLEDGE THIS
SEGMENT IS ONE THAT CAUSES
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES. EARLY FOR LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. ABELARD INVESTMENT
AND THE HEAVY DUTY- AND KIND OF
OPERATE. NOW WE CAN CAN DRIVE
ECONOMIC OF SCALE L. BROUGHT IN.
MY CHANGE- KIND OF WORK FOR
COMMON COMPONENTS. TO ENSURE
THAT IN THE LONG TERM. WE DO
HAVE A MORE EQUITABLE
TRANSITION- TO THE REMISSION
TECHNOLOGY ENSURE THAT WE DO
HAVE THE- NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
WHO- KIND OF. ALIGNED WITH THE
REGULATIONS THAT WERE BEATING IT
AND- ACTUALLY INVESTMENT IN THAT
AREA NOW. WE THINK COULD HELP
BUT MORE IN THE LONG TERM GIVEN
THAT THIS IS OUT OF THE-
VARIOUS. SEGMENTS ONE OF THE-
LESS MATURE SEGMENT.
INTERMISSION VEHICLE. SO HOW ARE
YOU GOOD AT HOW DOES THAT
ADDRESS OUR CONGESTION PROBLEMS
HENRY I GIVE NO WE'VE BEEN IN A
PANDEMIC FOR TWO YEARS AND
PEOPLE. ARE IN A HAPPY PLACE
BECAUSE THERE'S- A LOT OF FOLKS
ARE PEOPLE WORKING REMOTELY BUT
WE HAVE. A CONGESTION PROBLEM
AND IF ALL YOU'RE DOING IS
TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF BUSES
BECAUSE YOU'RE DURING COURAGE
THEM TO BUY. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WITH REBATES AND
INCENTIVES AND TAKE THE TRUCK'S
NOT REPLACE ANY TRUCKS BUT MAKE
THEM ZERO MISSION. ARE YOU JUST
CREATING CLEAN CONGESTION I MEAN
IF YOU'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE
CONGESTION. YOU'RE SAYING- WE
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAN. DON'T YOU
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO BOTH OF
THEM WITH US AND THE GOVERNMENT
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY. TO BOTH
OF THEM AND COME UP WITH SOME
INCREMENTS OF ELECTRIC TRAINERS
SOME WAY TO MOVE CARGO OUT THE
PORCH. BEFORE IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE. BUT I
SEE. IF YOUR LONG TERM BENEFIT
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT TWENTY
FORTY FIVE IF YOU LOOK AT TWENTY
FORTY FIVE YOUR YOUR BIG BAD IS
THAT WE WANT TO. WE WANT TO.
EIGHT MAGIC SO THAT EVERY HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK IS ZERO EMISSION NOT
NEAR TERM BUT NEAR ZERO ZERO AND
WE'RE NOT PUTTING ANY
INVESTMENTS INTO FIX RAIL. TO
MOVE THEM. YEAH I THINK THE ONE
THING I KNOW IS THAT WE DO HAVE
OTHER ZERO EMISSION MOBILITY
PROGRAMS THAT I THINK THAT-
EBOOK AND I'M BACK I DON'T KNOW
IF ZOOM DROP ME FROM CLEARLY
THAT SORRY ABOUT THAT BUT MR
REGULAR FINISHES THOUGHT AND
WE'LL COME BACK TO MR SICKLE. IN
ORDER TO KNOW ON YOUR- WE DO
HAVE- THERE- MISSION MOBILITY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BUILT AND
WITHIN THEIR THEIR MISSION
PACKAGE- WHICH WHICH DO HAVE
HELP WITH DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTION THEY'RE
NOT ONLY JUST THE VEHICLES BUT
PROVIDE DIFFERENT TYPES OF- KIND
OF PROGRAM FOR COMMUNITY THAT
BEING THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT MORE WHICH I THINK.
ARE REALLY GET THAT QUICK
QUESTION. THIS IS A LOT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE'LL GET TO GET BACK TO
HELP THAT. THAT THIS HOUSE HOW
ARE WE- TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BUT MR SCOTT
SORRY BUT THE- THE
TECHNICALITIES YOU HAD. A NO
PROBLEM YOU'RE GOOD IT DIDN'T ME
ON. WHY WE HAVE NEW RULES FOR C.
V. R. P. AND- THEN WHAT THE BIG
THE BIG PLANETS. I WAS GOING TO
DO THAT AND I THINK WHERE I WAS
WITH A HEAVY DUTY PEACEFUL
COMPLEXITY TO IT SOUNDS AND
STRAGGLERS COVERED SOME OF THAT
STUFF. JUST TO RE EMPHASISE THIS
IS REALLY THE MOMENT AND HEAVY
DUTY YEAH THERE IS A LOT. NOT
ONLY ARE THESE THESE TRUCKS
DRIVING BOTH CLEAN AIR AND
CLIMATE FAILURES AND TOXIC RISK.
THEY'RE ALSO AT THIS FASCINATING
COST MOMENT IN WHICH BIG
INVESTMENTS ARE BEGINNING TO GO
INTO THAT SPACE FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. AND IT IS OUR CHANCE I
REALLY THINK TO FOCUS
INVESTMENTS IN A LONG TERM AND
STRUCTURED WAY GIVEN. THE SPEED
AND PACE THAT FLEETS TURNOVER
AND THE NEED FOR CONTINUED
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS WITH
CERTAINTY. TO REALLY DRIVE
INVESTMENTS. THERE SO FROM MY-
I'M THIS PROGRAM. THE CHUCKLE
OUT OF BOX. THE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO COUNTER
CLIMATE CHANGE IN A BIG AND
IMPORTANT WAY. AND THEY HELP US
FOCUS ON THE EQUITY AIR QUALITY
NEEDS WE NEED AND BY INVESTING
IN MARCH NOW. THERE IS A CHANCE
TO REALLY SUPPORT THAT
TRANSITION AT A MOMENT WHEN IT
REALLY MATTERS. I'M ON LIGHT
DUTY AS I KNOW THAT'S AN AREA OF
INTEREST TO. SAY A FEW THINGS
ON. THE BOARD AND THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH GIVE DIRECTION
AND SENIOR PEACE OR IMPLEMENTING
DIRECTIONS FROM OUR BOARD IN
NOVEMBER. WHICH WAS FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THOSE INVESTMENTS SOME
FROM THE LAST CYCLE WOULD LAST
OVER SEVERAL YEARS WE'LL
CONTINUE TO FOCUS THAT
PARTICULARLY ON THE LOWER INCOME
FOLKS WHO NEEDED THOSE
INVESTMENTS MOST. SO IT'S REALLY
AN EFFORT TO CONTINUE OPERATING
THE PROGRAM ACCORDING TO BOARD
GUIDANCE ON AND WE'RE JUST
FOCUSED PARTICULARLY IN EQUITIES
SO THAT KIND. OF A MULTI MONTH
PROCESS THAT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED
NOW. I'M IN RESPONSE TO
CONTINUED I'M STRONG UPTAKE
INDEED WE JUST SAW THE MILLION
ON TV SALE SO WE ARE SEEING SOME
PROGRESS THERE. AS WELL. WE L.
BYE BYE I- HERE BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT BIG ORDERS SET ST UP ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION FEB ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY TWENTY
THIRTY WHO'S GOING TO BUY THESE
CARS WHO'S GOING TO BUY THESE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES I KNOW YOU YOU
THINK YOU GOT THE NECK OF THE R.
CAR D. DEALERS ARE DOWN ON THE
GROUND BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SELL THEM BUT WHO'S
GOING TO BUY THESE CARS IF YOU
DON'T PROVIDE THEM WITH
INCENTIVES WHEN THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS 90% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BOUGHT ELECTRIC VEHICLES. I
READ THE REPORT SAID THAT THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS PAID PLAYED A
ROLE IF YOU COULD CURLING THEM
BACK WHEN WE'VE AGREED WE
FINALLY REACH ONE MILLION AND WE
GOT THIRTY MILLION VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD. IN OUR OUT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IS DONE THERE HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND THAT
YOU GIVE US A THREE YEAR
APPROPRIATION AND WHICH WE'RE
TRYING TO BOTH LIVE WITHIN OUR
MEANS MAKE SURE WE KEEP
SUPPORTING THIS PROGRESS. AND
ANOTHER THING I GUESS I'D SAY.
THAT WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
OVERALL PACKAGE INCLUDING
INVESTMENT STOCK EXTEND THIS TO
LOWER INCOME FOLKS I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. WE ARE
SEEING COST ON THESE VEHICLES.
I'M DOWN WE'RE SEEING HUGE
INVESTMENTS AS THE PRESIDENT
OBSERVED LAST NIGHT INSTEAD OF
THE UNION. BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FASTENS TO THE PUNCH
REALLY DELAYS BEING MADE TO
SOUND I HAVE TO SAY. THERE'S
REALLY STRONG DEMAND HERE NOT
ONLY IS THE MARKET EXPANDING IN
CALIFORNIA AGGRESSIVELY. WERE
SEEN BEING PRIVATE COMPANIES
EVENT HERE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE BETTER VEHICLES THEY
LAST LONGER. THEY'RE CHEAPER TO
RUN. AND THEY FIND IT MORE FUN
TO DRIVE SO THIS EXCITEMENT
HERE. AND A LARGE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION NOW I THINK IT'S
CONTINUED TO ACCELERATE IN THE
US BUT LIVING WITHIN OUR MEANS
MOVING FORWARD AND CONTINUING.
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THE MARKET
THAT'S A FEW PIECES RIGHT. IS
BOTH CARDS MAJOR REGULATORY
EFFORTS LIKE ADVANCED CLEAN CARS
TWO WHICH WILL IMPLEMENT THAT
REGULATORY DRIVER. AND THEN
THERE KEEP PROGRAMS LIKE THOSE
IN THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION AND
ELSEWHERE. THE HELP ENSURE BOTH
INCENTIVES AND RATE STRUCTURES
MAKE SENSE. AND FINALLY THE
ONGOING INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING INVESTMENTS
LEGISLATURE INSTRUCTED US O
MAKE IN WHICH WE ARE MAKING.
THAT INSURE THESE VEHICLES REACH
PEOPLE IN COST EFFECTIVE WAYS
THAT INCLUDES BOTH MIDDLE CLASS
FOLKS. AND FOLKS OF LOWER
INCOMES WHO TRADITIONALLY HAVE
BEEN OVERLOOKED IN WHERE WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS. ON THE EVENTS. AND HOW OFTEN. LAST FROM THE-
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
A- ABOUT A- APPROPRIATELY AS
THIS RENTAL. TO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT. YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING AT
THAT JUST AREN'T THAT MANY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IF YOU HOW CAN
YOU SAY IN ONE BREATH THAT
PEOPLE LIKE HIM TO RUN BETTER
BUT THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
PEOPLE WHO OWN THEM YOU HAVE TO
GIVE UP YOUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
FOR IT TO BECOME. BECOME USED I
WANT TO SELL IT AND YOU'RE
CREATING THERE'S SCARCITY IN THE
MARKET WITH VEHICLES PER SE I'VE
I'VE MADE MY POINT- I GUESS. IT
IS THE. IS THE IT'S A PROPOSAL
THAT YOU HAVE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE SET OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WE COULD PURSUE YOU KNOW
THE VALLEY- TALKED ABOUT ALL
KINDS OF POSSIBLE INVESTMENTS
YOU HAVE YOU HAVE. REALLY
NOTHING HERE IN THE FARMER
PROGRAM NOTHING HERE FOR CARL
WARRIOR OTHER YOU KNOW YOU GAVE
NOTHING FOR C. P. R. P. I MEAN
YOU GUYS CAN ACTUALLY PROPOSING
MINISTRATION TO PROPOSE MORE
MONEY FOR CVR PETE DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE THE SENATE. YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SAY WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS PROGRAM MORE EFFECTIVE SO
MORE PEOPLE BUY NEW CARS IT'S
OKAY. THIS IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO MAXIMIZE THE
INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES. OR PROVE YOUR QUALITY NOT
JUST. HELLO SIR DR APARNA BY AND
I THINK WE ALL HAVE BEEN INTO
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WANT TO.
ADD ON HERE AS WELL IT
DEFINITELY CAN YOU KNOW I THINK
WE DEFINITELY DID LOOK ACROSS
THE BACK OF THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE IT WAS ONCE YOU PRIOR TO
THAT THANK YOU FOR KIND OF
THROUGHOUT THE DIFFERENT.
STATIONS BY- BOGUS RENTAL
INSURER- GOAL IS THE FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND HOW BAD BEING ONE OF
THE KEY- DRIVING FACTORS AND-
CATERPILLARS OF WHAT THIS
PACKAGES AND- WHEN LOOKING AT
ADD EQUITY I THINK YOU KNOW IT
DEFINITELY STILL HAVING- KIND OF
OTHER REAL OTHER LANDED. IN HOW
. AND BENEFIT BOTH ALL FIVE-
FROM THE KIND OF ECONOMY TIED UP
BY. WHEN YOU ONLY ON AT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO MISS EQUITY AND-
LEAVE BEHIND A COMMUNITY. THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE. NOT BE ABLE TO-
PART OF THE BAY AND ACCORD AND-
GET A DIVISION VEHICLE THAT AND
BE PART OF THE PROGRAM. AT THE
WEEKEND ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS
WHERE- YOU KNOW THE STATE COULD
STEP IN AT WORK. BASICALLY AND
IN THIS AREA AND SO YOU KNOW.
WELL WELL THERE'S DEFINITELY A
LOT OF OTHER KEY CONSIDERATION
THAT WAS DEFINITELY ONE OF. THE
BIGGEST DRIVING FACTORS- WHICH
IS WHICH IS WHY YOU KNOW WE ARE
BUILDING AND THE- KIND OF
ALLEGATIONS THAT THAT WE ARE I
DON'T KNOW YOU GUYS KEEP DRONING
ON ABOUT EQUITY EQUITY EQUITY.
BUT THE CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS
COST US ELEVEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER METRIC TON
IN GREENHOUSE GAS. COST
EFFECTIVENESS TO YOUR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT IS FIVE THOUSAND.
FIFTY BOOKS YOU GET A JURY
DIGESTED THAT WILL INCREASE AIR
QUALITY AND IN PARTICULAR- PROVE
OUR QUALITY AND CARBON. LIKE
LESS THAN A HUNDRED. YOU KNOW
THIS CHART HERE DEMO PILOT FOR
THE HEAVY DUTY AND OFF ROAD SEPT
IS. EIGHTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER METRIC TON.
DID IT SOUNDS FRENCH FROM PAGE
SEE A- IT'S NOT YOU KNOW WE
WE'VE GOT TO GIVE THE PUBLIC. A
RETURN ON THEIR IN. NOT PLEASE
YOU KNOW THIS IS A FANCY. SHINY
PENNY THAT WE WANT TO HAVE I
MEAN YOU CAN YOU CAN NAME IT
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO GO. BUT
CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS- ELEVEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS I
MEAN THEY L. WILLIAMS. GIVES YOU
A CHART AND SEE THE CORAL MORE
YOUR PROGRAM WHICH GETS
POLLUTING FARM EQUIPMENT OFF. IS
ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
JUST THE ECONOMIC CITY WE COULD
DO THREE TIMES AS MUCH IN THE-
GETTING BAD POLLUTING FARM
EQUIPMENT OFF THE OFF THE- OUT
OF THE SYSTEM. OR KARL MOYER
SOME SMALL GENERATORS THEN THIS
FANCY SPREADSHEET PROGRAM. DID
YOU GUYS TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
- YEAH I THINK WE DEFINITELY DID
AND I AND I'LL JUST KIND OF KNOW
THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WHILE WE DON'T SEE ALL THE
PROGRAMS LISTED HERE- FOR
EXAMPLE FARMERS ALREADY FIND
ARMOR GOT RID GOT MULTI YEAR
FUNDING IN LAST YEAR'S PROPOSAL
I THOUGHT. OTHER PROGRAM EVEN
THOUGH WE DON'T EVEN LOOK AT
THAT PART OF THEIR MISSION
VEHICLE PACKAGE DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE NOT ALREADY IN THE
BUDGET. NO NO I REMEMBER LAST
YEAR I WAS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE BUDGET AND OVER THREE YEARS
WHAT I'M ASKING IS YOU GUYS ARE
DOUBLING DOWN ON SOME PROGRAMS.
AND YOU'RE SAYING WE'VE GOT TO
GO WIN BECAUSE IT'S WE'VE HAD
SOME SURE RATS WHATEVER YOU DID
AND WE WON YES I'M SAYING THAT'S
NOT. DEFECTIVE WHY NOT THAT WHY
NOT COMING WITH MORE MONEY ON
THIS PROGRAM THIS IS A POPULAR
PROGRAM THIS REDUCES. OUR CARBON
IN THE SHORT TERM. I THOUGHT
THAT EXPRESS. NOTHING IN THERE
IF YOU GO WHAT EIGHTY THOUSAND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND THIRTY
THREE GESTURES AND WE KNOW
METHANE IS KILLING US. ABOARD
YOU HAVEN'T COME UP WITH ANY
PROGRAMS ANY AGGRESSIVE PROGRAMS
NOT SIX POINT ONE BILLION. YOU
KNOW ONE THING I WIL SPEAK TO
ANYONE I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
MINISTRATIONS ALLOCATION
DECISIONS THAT'S A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUT I WILL SAY THAT
SYSTEM CHANGE. REALLY IS
CRITICAL HERE SORT OF THINK
ABOUT THE METRICS THAT INFORM
OUR PROGRAMS THEY'RE MORE THAN
JUST STRAIGHT COST EFFECTIVENESS
NOW PROGRAMS ARE GENERALLY QUITE
COST EFFECTIVE. BUT THESE ARE
ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT LONG TERM
STRUCTURAL CHANGE SO IT'S
SPECIAL ANYTHING BUT THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WE'VE
INVESTED AS A STATE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO CONSTRUCT A SYSTEM THAT IS
DEEPLY INEQUITABLE EXPOSES FOLKS
TO AND RESOLVE NOT SEVERE
POLLUTION. BUILDING OUT OF THAT
DOES TAKE TIME BUT OVER THE LONG
HAUL THAT IS A BIG AND IMPORTANT
CHANGE IT'S NOT JUST COMMUNITIES
CALLING FOR IT IT'S THE VISION
THAT CALLOUSED AND OTHERS HAVE
EXPRESSED I THINK LARGELY.
BECAUSE OF THAT IN THE LONG TERM
HEALTH MOVE US AWAY FROM HAVING
TO BUY EVERYONE SINGLE FAMILY OR
SINGLE PASSENGER CARS IT'S A
BROADER VISION BUT HELP SHIFT
THE SYSTEM STATE. SO JUST
MULTIPLE METRICS WE NEED TO
CONSIDER ALL OF THESE FRONTS
THAT I THINK ARE QUITE IMPORTANT
TO THINKING ABOUT OUR NEXT YEAR.
WOULD YOU CUT YOU WE'VE GONE
THROUGH COVERT NOBODY'S ON THE
BUSES NOBODY'S ON THE FIXED RAIL
WHY DON'T YOU COME UP WITH A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD SUBSIDIZE THE
A BUS PASS OR TRANSIT PASS IN
SACRAMENTO PEOPLE PAYING SEVEN
BUCKS A DAY TO RIDE THE BUS IN
SACRAMENTO TO SOME LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND- GOVERNMENT WORKERS.
COME UP WITH A PROGRAM TO TREAT
AT THAT INSTANT INCENTIVIZE THEM
OR- GALVANIZE THEM TO RETURN TO
THE BUS MAYBE ONE OR TWO DOLLAR
TO A FLAT RATE AND SOMETHING
THAT YOU SAY THANK YOU MIDDLE
CLASS PEOPLE GIVE PEOPLE THE
DRIVE TESLAS TO GO BACK AND USE
TRANSIT. EVEN THINKING ABOUT
THAT I THINK THERE IS A METRIC
OF POT YOU KNOW IT REALLY GREAT
COUNTRIES ARE ONES WHERE THE
WEALTHY RIDE TRANSIT AND I AGREE
IT IS WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THAT
THOUGH BECAUSE ONE OF THE BIG
COMPONENTS OF CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
OUR MOBILITY OPTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
TRANSIT PASSES- IN ADDITION TO
CERTAIN ADMINISTRATION LARGER
VISION OF TRANSPORTATION SO
THERE'S NO NEED. IN THESE
PROGRAMS THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENTS AND WE'RE QUITE
EXCITED ABOUT THAT ALONG WITH
SOME OF THE REGULATORY WORK
WE'RE DOING AND HELPING TO ELECT. OR SCIENCE OR SLEEVES WE LOOK
FOUR TO SEVENTY. ON THAT FOR A-
ALLEY- HIS PRODDED IT SAYS CAN'T
USE NEW PROGRAM. AND WE NOT
SEEING DETAILS ON THEM- I'VE
SAID ENOUGH. CENTER WOW. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I JUST WITNESSED BUT
THAT WAS AWESOME SOMEBODY IS
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR SOME DETAIL
MEN ASKING FOR A LONG TIME. SO I
WANT TO THANK- THE PRESENTERS-
SO WE HAVE THE QUESTION I HAVE
IS THAT LOOK WE'RE WE'RE
SPENDING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
COUPLED WITH LAST YEAR'S IS THAT
INVESTMENT WE'RE GONNA SPEND TEN
BILLION THAT DOES THE PROPOSAL
IS TEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
NEXT SIX YEARS. AND IT'S OUT OF
SEVERAL POTS- BUT DO YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR CAME UP WITH. BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE. NO CELL. OF COMBUSTIBLE
ENGINE VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE PLAN
IS ON HOW THE INFRASTRUCTURE I
WANT I WANTED MAYBE SPRING BOARD
OFF OF WHAT THE SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE H WAS TALKING ABOUT
THERE'S A LOT OF INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT IN THE
TECHNOLOGY SECTOR BECAUSE WERE
POPPING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
GRANTS FOR PEOPLE TO DO THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS TRYING TO GET
US TO AS MY COLLEAGUE QUOTED THE
SHINY PENNY AT TWENTY FORTY FIVE
BUT HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
THERE. SO TELL ME BETWEEN NOW
AND TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. WHAT IS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW IS
THIS BUDGET. GOING TO GET US. TO
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE NO
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES SALES OF
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
THE FIRST QUESTION. YEAH I CAN
SPEAK TO THEM FOR SOCCER SIDE-
THAT YOU MENTIONED SO WE HAVE
ROBUST TOOLS AND PLANTS THE
PLANTS THAT ARE GOOD FOR HER
COMPONENT MANY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN GIVEN TO US BY THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS A STATE
WIDE. OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS WE PROJECT
FOR TWENTY THIRTY BEYOND- WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT A. B. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE A REPORT BUT
ALSO RECENT LEGISLATION SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY THREE AND OUT
THERE IN THE PAINTING ON THE
HYBRID FIVE WHICH WE ARE GOING
TO WANT LATER THAT YEAR WELL. WE
ALL HAVE THINGS LIKE THAT
DEMOCRAT ACTUALLY PLANNED AND
ABOUT THE COMPANY WANTS LOOK-
BRICK CORRIDORS YOU HAVE A LOT
OF PLANNING AROUND THAT TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL COMMUNITY AND THE FUNDING
WE'RE REQUESTING HERE IN THE
MAJOR PORTION OF THAT IT'LL HELP
US FUND PROGRAMS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE ACTUALLY LAUNCHED
A ROLE COMMUNITY FAR FROM LAST
YEAR I'M HEARING A COLDER. USER
AS WELL AND MANY OTHERS THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE INVESTMENT THEY'RE. JUST KIND OF A ONE THOUSAND- A
VIETNAM FIFTY. WEATHER
TEMPERATE. RELATIVE TO THE
GEOGRAPHIC LAYOUT OF THE STATE.
LOUIS COMMUNITIES NOW POPULATION
CENTER. WE ACTUALLY PUT THAT
RESEARCH TO WORK- SO CAN YOU
WANT TO GO POTENTIAL AND- THE
APPLICATION WINDOW CLOSES IN
ABOUT A WEEK OR TWO. AND IF IT'S
ANYTHING LIKE OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT WILL ALSO BE
OVERSUBSCRIBED. THE MONEY
RECIVED LAST YEAR AND MONEY
WERE OUT BEFORE TODAY. WILL HELP. YOU EVEN MORE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING YOUR- AND
CENTER JUST TO BUILD ON THE
SUNDAY. SIDE AS THIS RESULTS
NOTED RECORDING REALLY CLOSELY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT BILL
THAT'S HAPPENING IN A REALLY
THOUGHTFUL WAY MISS BOTH. PUBLIC
FUNDS. AND INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF PRIVATE SECTOR FUNDS FOLKSY
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE I MEAN.
IT'S A PRETTY HARD TIME SEO IS
WITH THE AUTO COMPANIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FIRMS POURING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THIS
DIRECTION THAT MAKES SENSE YEAH
THEY RECOGNIZE THIS IS WHERE THE
WORLD IS GOING TO WANT TO GET
AHEAD OF IT. I THINK SOME OF OUR
TASK THE CARD. IS MAKING SURE WE
HAVE BOTH THE REGULATORY AND
INCENTIVE SCAFFOLDING TO HELP US
GET IT. THERE SEEN A LOT OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES AT ONCE SO
THAT MEANS BOTH CREATING REALLY
CLEAR REGULATORY DIRECTION AND
BOTH THE LIGHT AND HEAVY DUTY
SIDE TO MAKE SURE WE'VE GOT PICK
UP. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
ARE REALLY THINKING ABOUT THINGS
LIKE DURABILITY AND USED
VEHICLES. MAKING SURE ALL THESE
MARKETS WORK. AND ON THE
INCENTIVE SIDE. REALLY TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE FOCUSING AND
TARGETING THOSE PUBLIC DOLLARS
AND SMART WAYS WHICH IS WHY WE
FOCUS SO HEAVILY ON EQUITY AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND THINKING
THROUGH HOW THIS WORKS FOR THE
MANY LIKE UT SECTORS. AND OF
COURSE ARE ALWAYS VERY OPEN TO
DIRECTION WAYS TO DO THAT BETTER
I THINK IS WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
WELL YOU DIDN'T NEITHER OF YOU
ANSWERED MY QUESTION THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THE GUY YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
YOUR GIVING OUT TO. IN GRANTS
AND. DOING STUDIES ABOUT HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DO.
DISADVANTAGED AND ALL THAT.
ACTUALLY TELL ME HOW WE'RE GOING
TO. ELECTRIFY THIRTY MILLION
CARS. IN CALIFORNIA WE WOULD
JUST LAST YEAR I MEAN THIS IS
JUST INSANE LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR ASKED US NOT TO CHARGE
OUR CARS DURING THE P. S. P.
WHEN WE HAD WHEN WE HAD WIND
ADVANCE WE HAVE IT AND THAT THIS
IS THE ELECTRIC GENERATION SIDE
OF OUR STATE. NOBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT THAT. SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
WERE WE DIDN'T GENERATE POWER
BECAUSE WE HAVE P. S. P. S. IS.
NOW YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT WERE
IT BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WHICH
IS RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ELECTRIC GRID
SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE TO PUT
ALL THESE. VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA THE REAL CHARGE OF.
WE HAVE NO CHARGING STATIONS WE
HAVE NO GENERATION I'M TALKING
ABOUT JURORS WORK WE'RE GONNA
SHUT DOWN. THREE THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS AT DIABLO CANYON. AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HOW YOU CAN
REPLACE THAT. WE DON'T COUNT
LARGE HYDRO THESE THESE ARE THE
QUESTIONS I WANT TO KNOW WE LOOK
I WILL I'M IN THE TRUCKING
BUSINESS. AND CARB UNDER AB
THIRTY TWO FORCED ME TO HAVE TO
CHANGE THE TECHNOLOGY IN MY
TRUCKS AND IT COST ME A HECK OF
A LOT OF MONEY AND BY THE WAY
THE TECHNOLOGY DIDN'T WORK. THE
TRUCKS BROKE DOWN CAUGHT ON FIRE
ALL KINDS OF THINGS. YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE BY TWENTY THREE BY
THERE'S NO DETAIL IN HERE OF HOW
THE PLAN GOES AND HOW WE'RE-
GONNA REDUCE CARBON. CALIFORNIA
ADMITS 1% OF THE WORLD'S CARBON
. I'M GONNA PIVOT NOW BECAUSE
YOU'RE TELL ME THAT HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO. WILL IT GET INTO THE
QUESTION HOW'S THAT GENERATING
ELECTRICITY CALIFORNIA GONNA
COME IF YOU'RE GONNA SHUT DOWN
DIABLO CANYON AND IT'S BEEN A
FEW YEARS. AND WHERE'S ALL THIS
ENERGY GONNA COME FROM. HOW'S IT
GOING TO HAPPEN HOW WE GONNA
CHARGE THESE CARS AND PUT IN
THESE FIVE THOUSAND DC FAST
CHARGERS. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ONE I'M ACTUALLY VERY GLAD YOU
ASKED THAT. SO I WANT TO START
BY NOTING THAT DIDN'T LIKE PS
YEAH THANK. YOU YOU ARE A
FUNCTION OF. WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
DONE FOR CLIMATE CHANGE RIGHT.
WILDFIRES AND DROUGHT ENDED THE
INACTION. OF NOT DEALING WITH.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT HAVE
BANDAID SOLUTION TO REALLY
CONNECT. TO THE REMOTE COMPUTER.
LET ME ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT REGRET IN. RESILIENCY AND
LIVE ARE TO OUR MISSION. AND
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF PROACTIVE
WORK IN THIS SPACE- I THINK
FRANKLY WE COULD D A BETTER JOB
OF EDUCATING FOLKS OF ALL WE ARE
DOING IN THE STATE HAS ADVANCED
ELECTRIC THE COMPLAINING
CONSTANTLY. DEMAND FORECASTING
CAPABILITIES. ACROSS ALL
SEGMENTS HEATING ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. AND WE- WE HAVE MULTI
AGENCY COLLABORATION OF ENERGY
COMMISSION AND- THE NETWORK OUT.
THE TYPE OF TRANSMISSION
PLANNING PROCESS. THE BEAUTY
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING.
AND WE CONTINUE TO ADD MORE
CAPACITY TO THE GRID. WE CANNOT
LET THE GRAND BE A BARRIER TO
OUR ADOPTION. WE'VE GOT A TWO
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF THE
STATIONERY STORES IN THE LAST
YEAR ALONE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
ADD EVEN MORE ENERGY. FOR A COPY
CAN GENERATION. SO AS WE LOOK AT
UP GRIP ALL THE NEED TO BE CROSS
ABOUT IT ACROSS. EIGHTY P. AND
UTILITIES WE ALSO LOOK AT THE
LOAD THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
COLLECTOR VEHICLES AS WELL. WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE BY TWENTY
THIRTY WILL HAVE BETWEEN 12221%
NEW LOW COMPARED TO TODAY. AND
THAT IS NOT EXPECTED TO CREATE A
NEW SYSTEM WIDE PEAK I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THE
INVESTMENT WE NEED TO BE MAKING
OUR DISTRIBUTION MODEL FOR
DISTRIBUTION P. WE'RE PLANNING
POLITICALLY BOTH THE- MODEL. AND
THE DISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH WELL.
BUT I DO WANT TO KNOW MORE LIKE
A VEHICLE OR QUITE REMARKABLE.
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDE ON SITE
RESILIENCY IN A WAY THAT I GOTTA
FEEL COOL COULD NEVER GET THIS
IS NOT SOME FAR FETCHED THING
WE'RE GONNA DO IN THE FUTURE
THIS IS- WHAT THE FORD F. ONE
FIFTY LIGHTING. WILL BE ABLE TO
DO IT RECALLED LAUGHTER I THINK
YOU HAVE ONE ORDER- I DO TOO SO
WE ALL HAVE THAT ONE RELATIVELY
SOON. AND THEN THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY VEHICLE DOING IT YOU KNOW
JUST A BIT DEEPER BALL THERE WAS
A CUTE BABY SEX. SHOULD BUY TO
REPLICATE THE BUILDING AS WELL
EITHER WE'RE PLANNING FOR TODAY
THE TECHNOLOGY HERE. WE DID NOT
HAVE THE WILL TO CONNECT ABOUT.
S. DRIVER PART OF MY BILL THING
ALL JUST KNOW IS AGENDA I NUMBER
THREE ACTUALLY ON THE- GREEN
ENERGY IN. AT THE BUILDING IT IS
BENEFITS WHICH I THINK WILL BE A
TO DO IT OUT THERE AND DETAIL.
THE NECK AGENDA. WHICH I THINK
PARTIALLY GET YOUR QUESTION ON
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING. IN TERMS OF THAT KIND OF
BROADER ENERGY PORTFOLIO. AND
THAT THEY'LL BE THE NEXT DAY
THAT. WELL OKAY I'M CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE THE
POWER AND I THIS IS A HECK OF A
LOT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE JUST
HANDING OVER AND THERE'S NO
DETAILS IS BASICALLY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SAYING GIVE US THE MONEY
AND WE'LL TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW
WE'RE GONNA SPEND IT OR WHAT
WE'RE BUYING LATER AND THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME WHEN WE'RE
PAYING. IN A RANGE FROM. THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY TO A THOUSAND TO
SIX TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
TIME. TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
IN THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE SEEN
THAT WITH THE- WITH THAT PUT THE
BULLET TRAIN. THE ACTUAL
REDUCTION IN CARBON THAT THAT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE IS WHEN WE CAN
GET INTO AN ESTIMATE OF THE
THOUSANDS PART TIME IF IT EVEN
DOES IT. SO FOR ME IT'S LIKE WE
NEED A LOT MORE. DETAIL ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE AND I
THINK THE PUBLIC IS STARTING TO
DEMAND IT BECAUSE- LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE PORTS IN THE DRY
TRUCKS FOR A- FOR A MOMENT. LAST
NIGHT I WAS MAYBE TWO WEEKS AGO
WE HAD THE PORT AUTHORITY PERSON
THERE'S ONE THERE'S ONE VEHICLE
AVAILABLE AND WE I ASKED ABOUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS GONNA HAVE
TO COME INTO THE PORTS. AND ALL
I HEARD WAS ABOUT WE REALLY GOT
TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE AIR
QUALITY PROBLEMS FOR. OUR PORTS.
SO I DID SOME RESEARCH. THE
REASON WE HAVE AIR QUALITY
PROBLEMS IN IN THE PORTS IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE. SUPER TANKERS
SITTING OUT THERE IDOLING
WAITING TO UNLOAD OIL COMING
FROM ECUADOR. SAUDI ARABIA AND
OTHER COUNTRIES BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT A BIT WE DON'T HAVE THE BILL
WHICH HAVE NO. NO REGULATIONS
LIKE WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THEY'RE SITTING OUT EARLY IF IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU. CHANGE
THE PORT AT ALL IT'S THE SHIPS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY CAUSING. THE
POLLUTION THAT IS POLLUTING SAN
DIEGO THERE WAS AN NBC STORY
ABOUT IT. BUT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
HOW WE COULD PRODUCE. CLEAN FUEL
GASOLINE OUT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
ASKED LAST WEEK ABOUT THIS SIX
HUNDRED WELLS VETERAN PERMITTING
PROCESS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
PERMITTED BECAUSE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET THE JOB
DONE FOR THESE OIL PRODUCERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH THEY PRODUCE
THE MOST. CLEAN ENERGY IN THE
WORLD. AND WE'RE WE'RE WATCHING.
NOW ECUADOR SENDING. 27% OF OUR
OIL IN HERE AND THEY'RE
DESTROYING THE RAINFOREST SO HOW
CAN CALIFORNIANS FEEL GOOD ABOUT
. ALL THESE PROGRAMS WE TALK
ABOUT IT WE'RE GONNA LEAD THE
WORLD IN CLEAN TECHNOLOGY BUT WE
DON'T USE OUR OWN TECHNOLOGY
HERE WORK FOR FORCING US TO
BRING OILS. AND OTHER PRODUCTS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES IN AND
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM. TO ME
IS A IS THIS A PROCTOR SEE THE
THINK THAT. WE'RE GOING TO LEAD
THE WORLD BUT WE DON'T TELLTHE
TRUTH THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
WHERE EXPERT BRINGING EXPORTS IN
HERE AND WE'RE NOT DEVELOPING
OUR OWN RESOURCES IN A CLEAN.
AND EFFICIENT MANNER AND
ACTUALLY GETTING TALIB
CALIFORNIA'S TAX BASE AND JOBS
HERE. SO FOR SO- SOMEHOW
SOMEBODY HAS TO. EXPLAIN TO ME
HOW WE'RE GONNA DRIVE THE COST
ON THE LAST THING I'LL POINT OUT
WHICH I POINT OUT EVERY SINGLE
TIME. IS WE TALK ABOUT WILDFIRE
. WE DON'T COUNT CARBON FROM
WILDFIRE. WHICH IS THE IT WHICH
WE NEED TO BE SPENDING WE NEED
TO SPEND ABOUT TEN BILLION
DOLLARS ON WILDFIRE IS THAT A
TEN BILLION DOLLARS ON. GETTING
PEOPLE IN EV'S. BECAUSE WE'RE
BURNING DOWN OUR OUR IT- FORCED
A MILLION ACRES BURNED IN MY
DISTRICT LAST YEAR AND WE'RE NOT
SPENDING THE RESOURCES WE NEED
TO SPEND THERE AND IT DEVASTATES
A WILDLIFE THE WATERSHEDS THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS NEED AND IT'S A
PLACE WHERE WE SEQUESTER CARBON
. SO WE NEED A LOT MORE DETAIL
WHERE THIS MONEY'S GOING WE NEED
TO BE DOING THIS IN A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH WE NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF A WILDFIRE SO WE DON'T
HAVE THE P. S. P. S. IS THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST. WE NEED A
SICK MAKE OUR- OUR WATERSHEDS
HEALTHY. AND THAT'S WHERE WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING THE MONEY AND
IT'S THE CHEAPEST PLACE WE CAN
REDUCE CARBON. EXCELLENT AND I
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION ON THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE
THAT'S- BEFORE US ON THE-
BETWEEN THE AIRPORT AND THE C.
E. C. HOW ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO
ADMINISTER THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
THAT ARE COMING THE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE HOW DOES
THAT. SOUND ON THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURES CODE TO CARVE
DIFFICULT THAT THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY HOW. YOU GUYS TOUCHED
ON THE KAUFMAN I REMEMBER IN THE
FALL THE AIRPORT WAS GOING
THROUGH SOME REGULATIONS. YES
SOME REGULATIONS ON THE ACTUAL
MACHINES AND THEY WERE DEBATING
WHETHER THEY WOULD SWIPE YOUR
CREDIT CARD OR YOU HAVE
TOUCHLESS. THERE'S A QUITE A
ACRIMONY THAT HOW DID THAT. END
UP BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO HAVE. THE
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY- AND IT
SEEMS SILLY TO ME BUT. MAYBE
MISTER SIEGEL HOW YOU COULD. IN
ME SURE- SINISTER SPEAKING
FEDERAL FUNDS AS ACTS WITH YOUR
CARD ASKED TO THE AXIS
REGULATION THAT COMES FROM A
STATUTE THE LEGISLATURE ASKED US
TO INSURE OPEN ACCESS TO
CHARGING THAT WE SEE REALLY
IMPORTANT- WE HAD SOME
COMPANIES- SUGGESTS THAT. SOME
ASPECTS OF THAT REGULATION THAT
ENSURE FOLKS WITH CHIP CARDS IS
NOT EVERYONE IS A TAP CARD I'M
IN CHARGE- WILL BECOMING
OUTDATED. WE DID A COMPREHENSIVE
SURVEY AND TECHNICAL ANALYSIS IS
NOW OUT OF THE DRAFT REPORT
WHICH BASICALLY SHOWS THAT
ALTHOUGH THOSE TAP CARDS ARE
BECOMING MORE PREVALENT. THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF FOLKS WHO DON'T
HAVE THEM THAT WILL BE REPORTING
TO THE BOARD AND THAT WE CAN
COMMENT ON THE DRAFT I BELIEVE
RIGHT NOW- LATER. IN THE SPRING
AND THEN THE BOARD CAN CHOOSE
WHERE IT WANTS TO GO FROM THERE.
I UNDERSTAND FROM THE BANKS THAT
ANYBODY CAN GET A CARD WHEN I
WAS SENT WHEN I WAS A COP TWENTY
SIX. IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND A
SWIPE MACHINE EVERYTHING WAS
TAPPED EVERYTHING WAS GOOD IN
SCOTLAND- AND ALL THAT IT IS
GREAT BRITAIN BUT THIS GOT THAT.
GENTLEMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR INPUT ON THIS ONE IT'S
A OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP OUR EYE ON
AND WE'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSIONS AND- WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. DURING THE
BUDGET DISCUSSION SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WILL
HOLD THAT MATTER OPEN AND HE
SAID THE CLEAN ENERGY.
INVESTMENTS- AND I THINK I HAVE
. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BUT FROM
EDUCATION GOOD MORNING IF IT'S
STILL MORNING MORNING IT WOULD
BE- GOING SHARE- SENATOR DOLLY
MY NAME IS DREW BOWING I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND- KEVIN WILL BE TESTIFYING ON
A NUMBER OF MATTERS BEFORE YOU
THIS MORNING SOMEBODY MOVED VERY
QUICKLY. WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY SECTOR OVER THE
LAST DECADE OR SO AT THE LA-
REPORT NOTED CALIFORNIAN TWENTY
TWENTY WAS POWERED BY CLEAN
ENERGY- JUST SHY OF 60% OF OUR
ENERGY WAS FROM CLEAN ENERGY FOR
ALL RETAIL SALES 36% OF THAT WAS
FROM RENEWABLES. IN ADDITION THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR SEVERAL YEARS
AGO REACHING THE SP THIRTY TWO
GOAL OF 40% GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS BY NINETEEN NINETY BY
TWENTY THIRTY- BETTER BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY TWENTY
THIRTY- A COUPLE YEARS AGO SO
WELL OVER A DECADE IN ADVANCE SO
I THINK THESE ARE THINGS TO BE
PROUD OF. ON THE OTHER HAND THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOUR REFLECTS
THE MASSIVE. AMOUNT OF WORK
STILL LEFT TO BE DONE. THE SCALE
OF THE SHELL AND THEN. IN JUST
ABOUT THIS WHEN YEAR WE
PUBLISHED THE SB ONE HUNDRED
FOUR AND IT MADE A COUPLE OF
REALLY KEY FINDINGS FIRST BUT I
KNOW IT IS A 100% CLEAN EIGHT A
1100% CLEAN GRID BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE IS ACHIEVABLE SH BUT WE'LL
NEED TO APPROXIMATELY TRIPLE OUR
ELECTRICITY GENERATION FROM
SOLAR AND WIND. AND WILL NEED TO
INCREASE BATTERY STORAGE RATES
BY MUCH MORE THAN THAT. SO THIS
PACKAGE BEFORE YOU PROPOSE TO
INVEST TO BUILD TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ACROSS SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS AND PROGRAMS A FEW
OF. WHICH YOU'LL HEAR FROM US A
LITTLE BIT LATER THIS MORNING
WE- ARE THE ENERGY COMMISSION
WOULD MANAGE A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION OF THAT. RESIDENTS
DESIGN TO DO A FEW THINGS FIRST
MAINTAIN A LASER FOCUS ON THE
LIABILITY I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE IN THE
LAST PANEL. ABOUT THE NEEDTO BE
VIGILANT ABOUT RELIABILITY
THAT'S JOB NUMBER ONE. SECOND
SPUR PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAN
GENERATE JOBS. BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO LEVERAGE LEVERAGE SOME OF THE
FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S GOING TO BE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA OR COULD BE
IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL ITH THE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS. AND WE WANT
TO PROMOTE EQUITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING IN TRIBAL
LOW INCOME AND UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. THIS PROGRAM- THIS
THIS PACKAGE WAS DEVELOPED WITH
A NUMBER OF OTHER AGENCIES. AND
WE THINK IT REPRESENTS REALLY
STRONG BOTH SHORT TERM
INVESTMENTS THE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE EARLIER THERE'S A NEED
RIGHT NOW TO START REDUCING
POLLUTION AND ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES AND THEN. ALSO THE LONGER
TERM. THE PUBLIC THAT THE PRIOR-
HANDLED LOOK AT TRANSPORTATION
DECARBONIZATION I'M GONNA TALK
TO YOU BRIEFLY- TODAY ABOUT HOW
WE'VE WE POCKETED THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN THREE AREAS
PURCHASE OR CHRISSY GENERATION
CARBONIZATION. THE SECOND IS
BUILDING THE CARBONIZATION AND
THE THIRD IS INDUSTRIAL
ORGANIZATION. YEAH LOTS TO COVER
SOME OF MOVE REALLY QUICKLY
FIRST. PROPOSING FOR ELEMENTS OF
ELECTRICITY SYSTEM THE
CARBONIZATION I'LL TAKE THOSE
BRIEFLY WONDERED THE FIRST. LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE AND WERE
SEEKING TREATMENT EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THIS IS. REALLY KEY TO
OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. IT WILL
HELP US ENSURE RELY RESILIENT
LECTURER WHEN THE NUMBERS ARE
NOT AVAILABLE- CENTER DOLLY SHE
POINTED OUT WELL WHEN THE GRID
IS DOWN FOR FURTHER RESEARCH.
THREE PRIMARY DRIVERS FOR THIS
PROPOSAL THE FIRST AS WE HAVE
DONE REALLY WELL WITH- LITHIUM
TECHNOLOGY EVERYBODY OWNS THE
SHOP ONE OR MORE. OUR NEXT HOUR
BY LITHIUM. BUT IT IS NOT
PARTICULARLY WELL SUITED FOR THE
GRID SCALE- STORAGE THAT WE NEED
TO MOVE INTO THE FUTURE SO WE
WANT TO INVEST IN A
DIVERSIFICATION. PROGRAM AND
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES OTHER CHEMISTRIES
LIKE SAY IRON FLOW BATTERIES
MECHANICAL STORAGE LIKE
COMPRESSED AIR AND FLY WHEELS
ANDTHERMAL TECHNOLOGIES THAT'S
ONE REASON BEHIND SECOND IS. TO
HELP COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE
GRID OUTAGES AGAIN CENTERED ALL
YOU KNOW TO THIS EARLIER-
THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER PS PS A
MENTION OF THE PAST TWO SUMMERS.
BY THE OUTAGES SOME OF WHICH
HAVE EXCEEDED FOUR HOURS AND
FOUR HOURS IS GENERALLY THE
BENCHMARK OF WHERE LITHIUM WORKS
VERY EFFECTIVELY BEYOND THAT
IT'S NOT THE BEST CHEMISTRY THAT
WE ARE AWARE OF. TODAY SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE FOCUS ON
THAT AND GET- STORAGE THAT LASTS
LONGER AND THEN FINALLY A GREAT
SUPPORT THE ISSUE IN A REPORT
INDICATES WE NEED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
ADDITIONAL STORAGE BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. AND WE GOT TO BRING
THE COST DOWN TO GET THE
PERFORMANCE BETTER IN THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS INVESTMENT WILL DO ARE
BASICALLY SPELLS OUT THE PLAN
AND A LOT MORE DETAIL- BUT I'M
GONNA LEAVE IT AT THAT AND
INVITE QUESTIONS AT. THE END.
NEXT TO THE GREEN HYDROGEN.
TREMENDOUS PROM IN HIDE YOUR-
YOU'VE HEARD OF IT'S IMPACTS
INCREASE. IT'S ALSO. VERY
HELPFUL AND HARD TO ELECTRIFY
SECTORS LIKE INDUSTRY THAT
REQUIRES VERY HIGH TEMPERATURES.
AND THEN FINALLY A GREAT SUPPORT
IT I USUALLY CAN COMPLEMENT. OR
REPLACE THE FOSSIL GASBURN THAT
WE SEE TODAY. AND IT CAN ALSO BE
USED FOR STORAGE I DIDN'T TO BE
SHORT FOR A LONG TIME THEN USE
LATER. HOWEVER WE HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN ABOUT. IT BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY A NEWCOMER TO THIS CLEAN
ENERGY SPACE. WHAT WE PROPOSE
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS A NO REGRETS
STRATEGIES. THAT'S BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE GONNA USE HYDROGEN YOU
GOTTA PRODUCE IT YOU CAN'T PUT A
WINDOW YOU CAN PUT UP A SOLAR
PANEL YOU GOTTA PRODUCE IT USING
ELECTRICITY FROM SOME OTHER
SOURCE SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE SOURCES ARE GOING.
AND WHAT WE WOULD PROPOSE TO DO
IS USE- BUT LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS. DIFFERENT SKILLS
THAT WE CAN USE ELECTROLYSIS
SPLITTING THE HYDROGEN OUT OF H.
TWO O. WATER TO- SECURE THAT
HYDROGEN WILL BE USED FOR THE
PURPOSES WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING.
SO RIGHT NOW ABOUT 95% OF ALL I
DID IN THIS USED COMES FROM
FOSSIL FUELS AND WE WANT TO
REVERSE THAT TREND. WE
APPRECIATE AND NOBODY QUESTIONS
ON THIS THAT THERE IS FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THIS AND WE THINK WE
ARE. OBJECTIVELY POSITION TO.
RECEIVE A LARGE AMOUNT OF THAT
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA. AND HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT THAT LATER AS
WELL. NEXT UP THE THIRD OF THE
FOUR AND ELECTRICITY
DECARBONISATION IS OSCAR WIN.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN ENORMOUS
UNTAPPED OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT
SURE WHEN. IT'S NICE BECAUSE IT
COMPLEMENTS SOLAR WIND OFTEN
BLOWS WHEN THE SUN ISN'T
SHINING. CENTRAL IS THIS VERY
LARGE COASTAL ECONOMIES CAN
BENEFIT FROM THIS PARTICULAR UP
ON THE NORTH COAST AND IN THE
CENTRAL COAST. AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF THE
GOALS THAT- BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LAID OUT-
LOOKING AT THE POTENTIAL FOR
THIRTY GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE
WIND BY TWENTY THIRTY NATIONWIDE
. THE SP ONE OTHER REPORT CALLS
FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
OFFSHORE WIND. AND WE WOULD USE
THIS FUNDING FORTY FIVE MILLION
FOR EARLY STAGE PLANNING. AND
FOR SOME INITIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED. FINALLY- FIRST SECTOR IS
ENERGY MODELING THIS IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENTS
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO
SHIFT OUR CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY.
SHE SHE LED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE SP ONE HUNDRED REPORT AND WE
LOOK IT UP A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS. SHOP THE CARD WITH A
CORE SCENARIO THAT COMBINED INTO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT EFFORTS WE
LOOK AT THIS VERY DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS WITH DIFFERENT-
COMBINATIONS OF RESOURCES. AND
MODELING WAS CRITICAL TO THE
SPOUSES. INVEST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE A SMALL INVESTMENT IN
MODELING SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
WISE DECISIONS THROUGHOUT. EACH
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP IS BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION WE'RE SEEKING
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AND WE'RE
CALLING THE EQUITABLE BUILDING
THE CAR BECAUSE- THAT'S REALLY
WHAT OUR FOCUS IS. WE'VE DONE
REALLY REALLY WELL IN CALIFORNIA
NEW BUILDINGS WE HAVE AMONG THE
CLEANEST- CLOSEST TO ZERO CARBON
APPROACHING. ZERO CARBON
BUILDINGS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
BUT HE HAS BEEN BUILDING LEVEL
OF WORK TO DO. AROUND HALF OF
ALL BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA WERE
BUILT BEFORE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION STARTED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. CREATING
RULES ABOUT- ABOUT BUILDINGS AND
HOW THEY CAN BE ENERGY EFFICIENT
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TARGETING WITH THIS FUNDING IS
AN EXISTING BUILDING STOCK. THE
PROPOSALS AIMED AT THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT DIRECT INSTALLS. IN
REBATES DIRECT INSTALLS IN
PARTICULAR WE THINK WILL WORK
WELL IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND MIDDLE INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND THE REBATES WOULD BE
TARGETED AT ALL CALIFORNIA
COACH- I THINK I'M GONNA SKIP A
LITTLE HERE IN MY NOTES TO MOVE
ALONG BUT AGAIN HAPPY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR ANSWER QUESTIONS
WERE LOOKING TO- DO WORKSHOPS ON
ALL THESE TOPICS. AND REALLY
REFINE FOR PRECISION WHAT WE
WOULD BE- STYLING THE PROGRAM
STATUS. SO FINALLY I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONISATION WHERE WERE
SEEKING FUNDING FOR TWO
PROGRAMS. THE FIRST IS THE FOOD
PRODUCTION INVESTMENT PROGRAM I
THINK YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THIS
WE WATCHED IT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WITH FUNDING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMON INVESTMENT. PROGRAM AND
IT WAS A VERY SUCCESSFUL WE
RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FUNDING
THAT WERE TWICE AS MUCH AS THE
FUNDING WE HAVE AVAILABLE THERE
WERE MANY UNSUCCESSFUL
APPLICANTS. WHO HAD MERITORIOUS
PROJECTS BUT WE HAD TO PICK THE
BEST OF THE BEST AND SOME DIDN'T
MAKE IT. SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE SHOWING 7280% ENERGY SAVINGS
SO THIS IS BEEN A DEMONSTRABLY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM ONE THAT WILL
YIELD IMMEDIATE RESULTS. ARE
RELATIVELY IMMEDIATE RESULTS
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO GET GRASS
OUT THERE. ABOUT 85% OF THE SITE
TO THE CURRENT FOOD PRODUCTION
INVESTMENT PROGRAM CALLED AFTER
WE'RE IN DISADVANTAGED OR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND WE AIM TO
DO- THE SAME WITH THE- WITH THE
NEW FUNDING TARGET. THOSE
COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED. CARBS
ESTIMATE OF THE EFFECT OF PRO
PLAY THIS ONE VERY HIGH. SO IT
WAS IT WAS- DEFECTIVE AS A
MATTER OF GETTING FUNDS OUT
AREAS WHERE THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF- OKAY SO ON THE SORT OF THING
AND IT WAS EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE AS WELL. FINALLY WE
ARE SEEKING TO EMULATE THE
SUCCESS WE'VE HAD WITH THE FOOD
PRODUCER WITH WITH THE WITH THE
F. TYPE PROGRAM. WITH A BROADER
INDUSTRIAL THE CARD SO WE WANT
TO TAKE THE LESSONS WE LEARNED
FROM THE ACTIVE PROGRAM IN
APPLIED TO OTHER INDUSTRIES
CALIFORNIA HAS- IS THE BEST
STAFF REPORT NOTED. FORTY
THOUSAND INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES
EMPLOYING ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIA'S. SECOND THE
SECTOR IS RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER
35% OF THE STATE'S FOSSIL GAS
USE IN MORE THAN 20% OF OUR
STATE'S CHICHI EMISSIONS. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT REALLY THAT THE
TOP INDUSTRIAL GHG EMITTERS NOT
INCLUDING OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
WE'RE LOOKING AT- CEMENT
CHEMICALS GLASS AND THOSE. THOSE
ARE THE TYPES OF INDUSTRIES-
WE'RE LOOKING AT
ELECTRIFICATION. STORED WHERE IT
MAKES SENSE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND A WHOLE SUITE OF TOOLS THAT
WE THINK WILL. HELP INDUSTRY.
AGAIN WE'LL BUILD MORE WE
LEARNED ON F. TIPPED AND- BUT
BUILT SOME OF THOSE THINGS IN
THE INDUSTRIAL D. KERR PROGRAM
WHICH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO
YOU THIS MORNING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS YEAH.
MR MENON AT THE AIRPORT. I THINK
THAT. PART WAS GOOD RESTAURANTS
. DELEO THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN-
MY MISSING SOMEBODY SCREWED
BEFORE IS OR SOMETHING WITH THE
AIRPORT ARE YOU. I WAS ON.
THERE'S I THINK THERE'S SOMEBODY
FROM THE WATER BOARD THAT GOES
BEFORE ME AFTER DREW I THINK
IT'S TEN CRACK. OUR YES HI GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR-
WHAT I WONDER AT PRESENT TODAY
AS PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PACKAGES AN OVERVIEW OF A
SPECIFIC. ENERGY STORAGE PROJECT
THAT'S INCLUDED WHICH IS TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION TO
RESTORE ON STORAGE OPERATIONS AT
THE LAKE ORVILLE COMPLEX- THIS
IS- IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
PUMPED STORAGE THIS WOULD BE A
PROPOSAL TO. TURN A LAKE OR A
BILL INTO A VERY LARGE BATTERY
TO SUPPORT THE ELECTRIC GRAD WE
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO GENERATE
UP TO NINE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
ELECTRICITY OUT OF THE LAKE
ORVILLE COMPLEX WHICH IS
BASICALLY A COMPARABLE TO THE
POWER NEEDED TO PROVIDE- A CITY
THE SIZE OF SAN FRANCISCO JUST
TO GIVE ME A SENSE OF THE- THE
SCALE. SO THAT PUMPED STORAGE IS
A PROCESS THAT IN THIS CASE
WOULD BE UTILIZED- EXCESS SOLAR
GENERATION THAT'S AVAILABLE
DURING THE DAY TO PUMP. WATER
INTO LAKE LAURA BELL. AND THEN-
GENERATE POWER OUT A LAKE OR A
BILL RELEASED OUT WATER DURING
THE LATE AFTERNOON AND EVENING-
TO GENERATE ELECTRICITY SO
REALLY ACT AS A LARGE BATTERY-
TO TAKE SOLAR ENERGY DURING THE
DAY AND THEN- RELEASE IT TO
GENERATE ELECTRICITY AT TIMES OF
THE DAY ONE WHEN POWER IS
NEEDED. TO SUPPORT THE ELECTRIC
GRID- ONE OTHER THING THAT MAKES
THIS PROJECT VERY ATTRACTIVE IS
THAT. MUCH OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS ALREADY IN PLACE SO THIS
PROJECT CAN BE DONE AT A
FRACTION OF THE COST OF THE
COMPARABLE. ENERGY STORAGE
PROJECT OF THIS SIZE AND IN A
TIME OF ABOUT TO CAP THE AMOUNT
OF TIME IS IT A TYPICAL. A
PROJECT OF THIS AND SO OVERALL
THIS IS A PROJECT AT ALL- YOU
KNOW REALLY SUPPORT THE STATE'S
ELECTRIC GRID- AT A- BETTER.
CARE COSTS AND ALSO IN A SHORTER
TIME THAN AND THEN ON THE OTHER
PROJECTS. AND SO MAYBE AT THIS
POINT ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT THEIR BOARD. AND
MR- IT'S GIVEN TO COVER THE NEXT
ELEMENT OF THE PACKAGE AND I'LL
JUST SAID THAT WE WERE PLEASED
TO SEE THE ADMINISTRATION MOVE
THAT PROJECT FROM THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE THROUGH THE CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENT BUT- LET'S HEAR FROM
THE AIRPORT. YEAH THANKS TED
ANDREW. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HI MY
NAME IS MIKE THAT'S GIVEN. YEAH
I'M WITH. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD'S RESEARCH
DIVISION- HYDRO FLUOROCARBONS OR
AGENCIES ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
GREENHOUSE GASES IN CALIFORNIA
AND GLOBALLY. THESE AGENCIES ARE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
WITH HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL. THOUSAND TIMES THAT
OF CARBON DIOXIDE. AND THEY HAVE
A DISPROPORTIONATE ADVERSE
CLIMATE IMPACT IN THE NEAR TERM.
SO ONE OF THE LARGEST USES OF
HSCS IS IN REFRIGERATION. AND
AIR CONDITIONING EQUIPMENT-
CARBERY EARLY ON NEED TO
REGULATE THESE GASES AND MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE FOLLOWED HER
LEAD IN ADOPTING SIMILAR RULES
TO MITIGATE THESE POLLUTANTS.
INCENTIVE FUNDING WILL HELP US
MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY TARGETS
AND START TO ADDRESS AGENCIES
UNDER CARBON NEUTRALITY- THIS
PROPOSAL ASKED FOR FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING. TO BUILD
UPON THE ONE MILLION ALLOCATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
WHICH WAS FOCUSED FOCUSED ON
COMMERCIAL REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS
COMMONLY USED IN SUPERMARKETS
AND GROCERY STORES. ULTRA LOW
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL
TECHNOLOGIES EXIST TODAY HOWEVER
A HIGHER INCREMENTAL COST AND
LACK OF FAMILIARITY WITH THESE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES. I MERRY
BARRIERS TO THEIR ADOPTION. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
EXISTING STORES BECAUSE IT IS
VERY EXPENSIVE AND CHALLENGING
TO TRANSITION TO AN ULTRA LOW
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL SYSTEM
DUE TO INCOMPATIBILITY IS
BETWEEN THE OLD AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. IN THE ABSENCE OF
INCENTIVE FUNDS EXISTING STORES
ARE LIKELY TO EITHER CONTINUE TO
LOOT USE THEIR LEGACY SYSTEMS.
OR DO A REFRIGERANT RETROFIT TO-
MIDRANGE GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL REFRIGERANT RATHER
THAN INSTALLING A NEW SYSTEM. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE CARD
AWARDED FIFTEEN GRANTS TO
SUPERMARKETS TO IMPLEMENT STATE
OF THE ART CLIMATE FRIENDLY
REFRIGERATION TECHNOLOGIES. THAT
REDUCE THE CLIMATE IMPACT OF
CONVENTIONAL HFC REFRIGERANTS
BY. 99% THE PROGRAM IS 22%
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND HAPPY AWARDS
ONE STORES LOCATED IN LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER THIS REPRESENTS LESS
THAN 1% OF ALL SUPERMARKETS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES ARE NEEDED TO HELP
TRANSITION THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
HFC SYSTEMS IN THE STATE AND
WOULD BE CRUCIAL IN HELPING
SMALLER STORES IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. BESIDES
SUPERMARKETS WE WOULD CONSIDER
INCENTIVES FOR OTHER COMMERCIAL
REFRIGERATION CATEGORIES AS WELL
AS AIR CONDITIONING EQUIPMENT.
SO DEPENDING ON THE SELECTED AND
USES THIS FUNDING CAN REPLACE
EXISTING HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL REFRIGERANT SYSTEMS
AND ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND STORES. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS FUNDING IS
EXPECTED TO HELP THESE
TECHNOLOGY TYPES RICHARD CONNER
IS A SCALE WHICH WILL LEAD TO
FURTHER MARKET ADOPTION. AND
THEREFORE GREATER GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. SO THANK YOU- THAT
WRAPS UP THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRESENTATION ON THAT ENERGY
PACKAGE AND OF COURSE WE WOULD
ALL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FOR VERY GOOD WILL.
PRECEDE THE FOLLOW THROUGH FROM.
LAST YEAR'S SENT MR BROWN YOUR
COMMENTS FROM THE ALIEN'S
PERSPECTIVE FOR GO TO. OF MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MR SHEARER- SIMILAR TO THE
PACKAGE WE RELEASED OUR ANALYSIS
OF THE PROPOSED CLEAN ENERGY
PACKAGE LAST WEEK AND SO THAT'S
ALSO POSTED OUR WEBSITE ON YOUR
AGENDA INCLUDES A LOT OF OUR
COMMENTS SO AGAIN I'M GONNA TRY
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE- A FEW
COMMENTS FROM THAT- FROM THAT
ANALYSIS. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS SO I'M GONNA DIVIDE MY
COMMENTS INTO. TWO DIFFERENT
PARTS ONE WITH JUST SOME
OVERARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
PACKAGE AS A WHOLE AND SOME
CONSIDERATIONS AND THEN I'LL GET
INTO. A FEW OF OUR SPECIFIC
COMMENTS OR RECOMMENDATIONS ON A
FEW SPECIFIC PARTS OF THE
PROPOSAL SO FIRST. ON THE OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS- WE THINK THE
PACKAGE GENERALLY TARGETS A
REASONABLE SET OF ACTIVITIES TO
PROMOTE DEEP DECARBONIZATION SO
IF YOUR GOAL IS KIND OF. LONG
TERM DEEP DECARBONIZATION A
PARTICULAR BILL ACTRESS DEGRADED
AND EVEN INDUSTRIAL SECTOR THAN
WE THINK. IN A FUNNY MOOD
SUPPORT KEY AREAS WHERE
SUBSTANTIAL. PROGRESS COULD HELP
THE COST OF ACHIEVING THOSE THE
VERY LONG TERM GOALS AND SO- BUT
ALSO IN ALL THE OTHER LARGEST
PIECES OF FUNDING RELATED TO
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION TARGETS
ONE OF THE- LARGEST SOURCES OF
STATEWIDE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND WHERE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT. CHALLENGES TO KIND
OF DECARBONISATION. S. KIND OF
BIG PICTURE COM I THINK IT- WE
DO OUR- STATE GENERAL RATHER
THAN RATEPAYER FUNDS ELECTRIC
REPAIR FUNDS IN PARTICULAR DOES
HAVE MERIT- AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
MANY OF THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAMS HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN
PAID FOR BY- I'LL YOU RATE-
THROUGH HIGHER ELECTRICITY
RATES- AND- YOU KNOW THE COST
FOR THESE CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS
ARE ONE. ONE FACTOR ONE OF MANY
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTES TO KIND
OF CALIFORNIA'S RELATIVELY. HIGH
RETAIL ELECTRICITY RATES AND WE
THINK THAT THOSE THOSE HIGH
RATES HAVE A VARIETY OF ADVERSE
EFFECTS INCLUDING. ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE- DISCOURAGING
ELECTROCUTION BECAUSE- THE FUEL
IS IT IS MORE EXPENSIVE- AND
JUST ON ON THE CANADA. ECONOMIC
INEQUITY SIDE THOSE ELECTRICITY
RATES. ARE ARE. KIND OF
REGRESSIVE APPROACH TO RAISING
REVENUE FOR- FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS FOR KIND OF CLIMATE AND
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS AND SO YOU
THINK. THERE'S A LOT OF MERIT
AND KIND OF YOU KNOW ALLOCATING
STATE GENERAL FUNDS FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS RATHER THAN
RELYING ON. ELECTRIC RATEPAYERS
- I THINK I LOVE. COMMENTS SO
BACK. TO A KIND OF A DISCUSSION
EARLIER AND SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT- THAT SURE WAS RAISING.
THAT IS REALLY REALLY THIS
PACKAGE WILL REQUIRE KIND OF
LEGISLATURE BALANCING LONG TERM
BENEFITS AGAINST NEAR TERM
PRIORITIES SO. AGAIN MUCH OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDING IS FOCUSED ON
ACTIVITIES INTENDED TO MEET SOME
OF THESE LONG TERM GOALS- ENERGY
ISSUE REDUCTION BENEFITS FOR
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ARE LIKELY
TO BE RELATIVELY MODEST OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS AND SO. THE
LETTER SAID YOU REALLY WILL HAVE
TO KIND OF BALANCE SOME OF THOSE
LONG TERM GOALS WITH OTHER
NEARING MEDIUM TERM PRIORITIES.
SUCH AS KIND OF. PROGRAMS TO
MEET THE DONATED TWENTY THIRTY
GHG GOALS. OTHER ENERGY RELATED
PROGRAMS OR SENATOR DOLLY WAS-
KIND OF HIGHLIGHTING. YOU KNOW
ISSUES AROUND GRID RESILIENCY
AND RELIABILITY- COULD BE KIND
OF A MORE OF A NEAR TERM
PRIORITY- OR JUST OTHER
STATEWIDE PRIORITIES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME GOOD USE-
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES FOR. THE
FOURTH THANKS. REDUCTION COME I
WANTED ON AGAIN BECAUSE OF
RELATES THE AN ISSUE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WHICH IS-
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES- SO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NATIONWIDE FOR. THREE
HUNDRED AND HUBS CARBON CAPTURE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
INDUSTRIAL MISSION DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS- IN MANY CASES THERE
ISN'T DETAILED FEDERAL GUIDANCE
ABOUT HOW THE FUNDING CAN BE
USED AND HOW IT WILL BE
ALLOCATED AND SO- AT THIS POINT
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THE GOVERNOR'S.
PACKAGE KIND OF STRATEGICALLY
TARGETS FUNNY IN A WAY THAT BEST
COMPLEMENTS THAT FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. SO FOR
EXAMPLE- ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES
TO USE STATE FUNDING TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN A WAY THAT.
FURTHERS THE STATE GOALS SO SOME
OF THE MAJOR FEDERAL PROGRAMS
SUCH AS PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
PREVENTING OUTAGES AND ENHANCING
GRID RESILIENCE. OCCUR ACQUIRE
STATE MATCH- BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HERE DOESN'T. HAVE
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR THAT STATE
MATCH THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO.
EXPLORE THE ADMINISTRATION. ALSO
EITHER KEYCAPS AND FEDERAL
FUNDING OF THIS KIND OF. STATE
FUNDING IS HELPING TO FILL. SO
THAT'S- PROBABLY GOT INTO MY CAR
THAT I HIGHLIGHT ON THE OVER
ARCHING- PROPOSAL- JUST REAL
QUICKLY I'LL TRY TO RUN THROUGH
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS IN
COMMON SO WE HAVE ON THOSE ON
THE EQUITABLE. EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION PROGRAM
WHICH IS A LARGE CHUNK OF THE
FUNDING HERE- WE'RE JUST
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTED MINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON. HOW
THAT PROPOSAL FITS IN WITH THE
STATE'S OVERALL BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION STRATEGIES SO.
IN WAT ROLE WAS THE ROLE OF
THESE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND
DIRECT INSTALL PROGRAMS-
RELATIVE TO OTHER POLICY CHANGES
THAT COULD TRY TO ACHIEVE THE
SAME GOALS SUCH AS AGAIN-
COMPLEXITY RATE STRUCTURES AND
CHANGES TO KIND OF ENCOURAGE.
ELECTRIFICATION WHAT IMPACT WILL
THE ELECTRIFICATION EFFORTS HAVE
ON REMAINING NATURAL GAS COSTS
AND- FOR CUSTOMERS THAT COME
WITH MY CONTINUED OUT TO PAY FOR
THOSE FIXED COSTS OF THE NATURAL
GAS SYSTEM. AND WHY IS THIS DO
YOU SEE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
AGENCY TO ADMINISTER THE DIRECT
INSTALL PROGRAM- SO COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT IS
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY THAT
OPERATES A COUPLE OF.
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TARGETED AT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND SO. WHAT IS IT.
ABOUT WHETHER. THE DIRECTIONS
PROGRAM TARGETED INCOME HOW IS
LOOK AT AT AT THE INTERVIEW CAN
OR ANOTHER. THE SECOND KIND OF
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON IS THE WEARABLE PUMPED
STORAGE PROJECT- WE DO THINK
THIS PROPOSAL HAS POTENTIAL
MERIT AS A WAY TO INTEGRATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY UNDER THE
GROUND- HOWEVER WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T- HASN'T
PROVIDED A DETAILED ANALYSIS OF
THE COST EFFECTIVENESS THIS
PROPOSAL COMPARED TO
ALTERNATIVES. SO WE RECOMMEND-THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTLY
MINISTER TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DETAIL ON THAT ISSUE I'M NOT I
DON'T. A SECOND IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES PROVIDE GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THAT
PROJECT WE RECOMMENDED ADOPTION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES ANNUAL
REVENUE GENERATED FROM THIS
PROJECT ONCE IT'S OPERATIONAL
AND TRANSFER THAT FUND INTO THE
GENERAL FUND- THIS IS BECAUSE IN
OUR VIEW IT ESTATE TAX TAXPAYERS
ARE PROVIDING THE FUNDING FOR
THE PROJECT. TO BE REASONABLE
FOR THE TAXPAYERS AND TO RECEIVE
THE FINANCIAL BENEFITS FROM THE
PROJECT- RATHER THAN KIND OF
USERS OF THE STATE WATER PROJECT
IN US FINANCIAL BENEFITS.THIRD
AND FINALLY- THIS IS A SMALLER
PIECE OF THE PROPOSAL BUT-
ENERGY RELIABILITY OFFERED CITY
W. ARE THE PACKAGE INCLUDES
THREE MILLION GENERAL FIND FORTY
W. R. TO SUPPORT ENERGY
RELIABILITY ACTIVITIES- BUT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING A LETTER SENT
TO REGRET THIS PIECE OF THE
REQUEST BECAUSE- GWR HASN'T
ADEQUATELY DESCRIBE. THAT MONEY.
OVER OR KIND OF JUSTIFIED THE
NEED FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
RESOURCES SO. THAT WE MIGHT.
THERE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YES ALI. YOU ARE THE
JUST THE- START ON. THE POP STAR
BECAUSE OF SOME I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH- THE I WANTED I
WANTED TO ASK THE QUESTION THAT
YOU WOULD USE IT SOMEWHAT- THE
ONLY- SOMEWHAT ANSWERED. AND
DOESN'T M. W. D. WHO RUN THE
POWER PLANT RIGHT NOW THAT'S
EXISTING ON ORVILLE AND NOW
THOSE- RATES THE MONEY THAT IS
GENERATED FROM THOSE MEGAWATTS
THERE THERE. GOES INTO PAYING
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO-
WOULDN'T WE WHY WOULD THE
TAXPAYER BE ON THE HOOK HERE-
FOR THIS PROJECT WHEN INDUCTEES
ALREADY OPERATING. THE POWER OF
THE ORVILLE. I BELIEVE IT'S M.
W. D. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SENATOR I'M D. W. R. IS
THE OPERATOR OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. AND THEN WE HAVE TWENTY
CONTRACTING ENTITIES THAT HELP
PAY THE COSTS OF THE PROJECT AND
THE BEAUTY IS ONE OF OUR LARGER
CONTRACTORS AND CONTRIBUTES-
MAYBE ABOUT HALF OF THE-
REIMBURSABLE COSTS OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT. IN THE CASE OF
THIS- PUMPED STORAGE PROJECT.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE
BUSINESS CASE TO INVEST THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM A REPAIR
PERSPECTIVES- I HAD BECAUSE THE
COST BENEFIT RATIO OF THE
PROJECT- IT'S NOT MAKES SENSE
FROM THE WATER SUPPLY. REPAIR
CHARGES- HOWEVER THE PROJECT
PROVIDES YOU KNOW GREATER PUBLIC
BENEFITS BY SERVING AS THIS
BATTERY. THAT CAN THEN. PROVIDE
RELIABLE POWER TO THE ELECTRIC
GRID. SO YES CURRENTLY THE
FUNDING MARKETS- ARE NOT
ADEQUATE TO BASICALLY YOU KNOW
PAY FOR THE PROJECTS ON ITS OWN
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SPEAKING AT
GENERAL FUND SUPPORTS AND THEN.
YOU KNOW THE L. L. AS
RECOMMENDATION- AT TAKING A LOOK
AT THE NET REVENUES AND
SOMETHING WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS WELL MOVING FORWARD. FIRST
I I'M IN FAVOR OF POP STORAGE I
THINK IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO- REUSE WATER AND WHEN WE'RE
OVER PRODUCING IT TYPICALLY.
DURING THE DAY WHEN WE HAVE A
LOT OF SUNSHINE I'M FOR THAT THE
SECOND THING I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
THAT AND THIS IS A DETAIL
PROJECT WE HAVE THE THERMAL ITO-
WE'RE WE NEED COLD WATER VERSUS.
WHAT WILL FIRST ALL BAG NEEDS
WARM WATER FISH DEEP COLD WATER-
AND SO HOW DOES THAT INTEGRATE
WITH THEIR MALITO AND HOW THAT
PROJECT IS GOING TO- INTACT FISH
- YES SO WHEN BE THE EFFECTS
OPERATE. THE FIRST AS AS A
PUMPED STORAGE FACILITY IS THAT.
WATER DOES WARM UP IN THE
FAMILY- AFTER BAY AND SO WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO ADD HERE IS
THAT AT TAPPING INTO THE COLDER
PORTION. OF LAKE OROVILLE- TO
OFFSET THAT WARMING EFFECTS THAT
OCCUR- DURING PUMP STORAGE
OPERATIONS- AND WE'D BE HAPPY
TO. PROVIDE SOME GRAPHICS- AFTER
THIS THIS- HEARING I HAD TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAIL IF
THAT'S HELPFUL SENATOR THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL I'M VERY.
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROJECT AND
I'M ALSO FAMILIAR WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE- ACT
VERSUS- YOU KNOW THE TYPES OF
WATER TO COME OUT OF THAT
PROJECT SO- THAT WOULD LOOK FOR
THAT SO MY NEXT QUESTION WOULD
BE. NOT ONLY WAS IT THAT POKE
ABOUT THE INDUSTRIAL- IN
CALIFORNIA THE- DECARBONISING
INDUSTRIAL SO I WANT TO DO
AEROBIC ANYBODY CAN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION. WHAT WE SEE IN LEAKAGE
IT WHEN I SAY LEAKAGE I MEAN
COMPANIES THAT HAVE- CEMENT
MANUFACTURERS IN MY DISTRICT
THAT- HAVE SHUT DOWN IN THE PAST
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET PERMITTED
AND IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE TO DO
WORK IN CALIFORNIA BUT THEY MOVE
THEIR COMPANIES. OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA STILL TRUCKING- THEIR
THEIR PRODUCTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA- SHIPPING THEM INTO
CALIFORNIA- IS THERE EVEN ANY
STUDIES DONE THAT SHOW THAT SHOW
HOW MUCH CALIFORNIA'S REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT DUE TO- ART TRYING
TO OFFSET OUR CARBON- THAT
ACTUALLY PUSHES. COMPANIES OUT
OF CALIFORNIA OR TO OTHER
NATIONS- AND THEN WE STILL GET
THE PRODUCTS IN HERE BUT WHAT
ART- DONE IN A- ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDLY WAY- BOARD. THIS IS THE
MAN NOT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GOOD MORNING. THE-
INFORMATION AVAILABLE SO OUR
COLLEAGUES OVER AT THEIR BORDERS
AND- I DON'T HAVE THOSE STUDIES
LOOKING BUT I WILL- COORDINATE
WITH THEM AND GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT QUESTION. I WOULD REALLY
PERSON I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR. A
LONG TIME ABOUT. YOU KNOW. IN
CALIFORNIA WE SAW OVER THE LAST.
SEVERAL YEARS NOW. COMPANIES
LEAVING CALIFORNIA. IN DROVES
AND THAT'S A TAX BASE THAT WE
NEED HERE. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
LOT OF MONEY IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW BUT IT'S- MONEY THAT HAS
BEEN PUMPED IN BY. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS US. WE WORK
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS
WELL AS OVERSEEING DEBT PILED ON
TO THE FUTURE GENERATIONS. AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WERE SEEN
PEOPLE LEAVE CALIFORNIA IN
DROVES- QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE
IT'S TOUGH TO DO BUSINESS HERE
AND OUR REGULAR REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT. IS REALLY STRICT SO
I NEED THERE SOMEBODY HAS TO DO
THE EVALUATION OF ARE WE REALLY
. ANY DIFFERENCE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND FOR JUST PUSHING
COMPANIES AND WORK FORCE OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPLY THOSE
PRODUCTS BACK INTO CALIFORNIA
FROM EITHER ANOTHER NATION
ANOTHER STATE THAT DOESN'T HAVE
THE SAME. REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE HAVE HERE. AND SO I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE
LEAKAGES AND IT DOESN'T SEEM
THAT WE CAN GET AN ANSWER ON
THAT BUT I DO KNOW- AT LEAST IN
MY DISTRICT THAT THERE ARE MANY
COMPANIES THAT- HAVE RELOCATED.
TO NEVADA OR SOME OTHER STATE OR
ACTUALLY OUT OF THE COUNTRY AND
THEY'RE SHIPPING- THOSE PRODUCTS
BACK INTO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
IT'S- THEY CAN DO IT CHEAPER
THERE THAN ON THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT AND- WE'RE STILL
USING THOSE SO- THAT HURTS OUR
TAX BASE AND IT HURTS OUR JOB
MARKET HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN HER
SEAT VARMINT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
FOLLOWING THE SAME. LAWS THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO TO
LEAD THE NATION. WELL WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD.
GOOD PAYING JOBS IN THE IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE NEED. THAT
DELIVERED TO CALIFORNIA ARE
ACTUALLY PRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M LIKE WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
OVER THE PAST A COUPLE YEARS NOW
WITH THE- OIL IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE DON'T. WE'RE NOT
PRODUCING AS MUCH AS WE CAN IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE'RE EXPERTS
OVER BRINGING EXPERTS IN FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT DON'T HAVE
THE SAME. REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT. WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT WE'RE STILL. MORE POLLUTING
THE WORLD. SOMEWHERE ELSE NOT
HERE AND DRIVING THE COST OF
LIVING UP IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- INFORMATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO- THE LEAKAGE
INFORMATION FROM SOMEBODY I
DON'T KNOW WHO WOULD SUPPLY THAT
MAYBE ELLY ELLS OFFICE- COULD DO
A STUDY ON HOW MUCH HOW MANY
JOBS WE ARE HOW MANY COMPANIES
HAVE LEFT CALIFORNIA- OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS. DUE TO THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT BUT STILL
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS HERE. THAT
SHOULD BE THE CARPENTRY BUT-
PORTION OF THE AIRPORT- WE'VE
BEEN INSTRUCTED BY THE ALLEY- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROCEEDS FROM
OUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM DON'T
GO TO THE COVERED ENTITY'S
SWITCHER 75% OF THE POLLUTING
ENTITIES WE SEE THAT THE
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION AND
THE FOOD PRODUCTION- INVESTMENTS
OUR GENERAL FUND- HIGH
INVESTMENTS NOT CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES OF. WE SEE THAT BUT
ALSO THERE'S JUST A GENERAL
FLAVOR THAT THE POLLUTER SHOULD
PAY BUT WE KNEW THAT WE SAY IF
YOU'RE POLLUTING IF YOU'RE
EXTERNALITIES ARE SET TO BE
PAYING FOR THAT SO. CAN YOU.
EITHER CLARIFY OUR- THESE MONIES
ANTICIPATED TO GO TO THE 25% OF
THE POLLUTERS THAT ARE NOT
COVERED AS A CARROT. FOR THE
FOOD PRODUCTION INVESTMENTS IN
THE INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION.
BETTER I CAN TAKE THAT QUESTION
IT WOULD- OUR OUR INTENTION IS
NOT TO NARROW THEFIELD OF
POTENTIAL PARTICIPANTS WE WOULD
NOT BE FUNDING DIRECTLY- THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE BUT WE WOULD BE
BRINGING DOWN- COMPANIES AS AS
WE'VE SEEN WITH THE FOOD FOOD
PRODUCERS PROGRAM WE WOULD BE
BRINGING DOWN THEIR COSTS. AND
THE GOOD THING ABOUT IT IS THAT
WE MAKE A STATE INVESTMENT WE
WITH WITH- WITH AFTER WE WORK WE
ARE FUNDED I BELIEVE IT WAS
ABOUT 60% OF THE INVESTMENT WE
REQUIRE 40% MATCH SO THE
INDUSTRIES. ARE ALL REQUIRED TO
PUT IN FUNDS THEMSELVES BUT ONCE
THE PROJECTS ARE DONE THE
SAVINGS ARE DURABLE THEY GO ON
WELL INTO THE FUTURE SO ONCE THE
EFFICIENCIES HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED- THEY EVERY YEAR CAN
SAVE MONEY IF THEY CAN HELP WITH
THAT. QUESTION THE JOBCENTRE
DOLLAR RAISED AS WELL ABOUT
COMPANIES- THE COMPANY'S COST.
NO I NOT IN A WE HAD A- OUR
ISSUE THAT TWO WE- ANIMATORS
COACHING ABOUT THE COST PER
METRIC TON AND MIKE MATHIS
SAYING THAT THIS MAY BE THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER METRIC TON. AT
LEAST ON THE FOOD PRODUCTION.
INVESTMENT SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
IT'S RIGHT IT'S A- MERE. EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION VERSUS SIX POINT
ONE BILLION. OTHERS THAT THAT
SORT OF JUMPS OUT AT THE TYPICAL
LEGISLATORS- THAT OU'RE DOING.
YOU'RE DOING- THE- EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
EMPHASIS ON. HAVING PEOPLE GO
WHEN INPUTTING AN ELECTRIC.
EQUIPMENT HAVING PEOPLE- GET
REBATES TO BUY ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES AND IT CAN SHE WIN
SEE LITTLE BIT ABOUT GOOD OLD
FASHIONED WEATHERIZATION. NO
I'LL GO BACK TO MY SHINY PENNY
IN TWENTY FORTY FIVE- WE'VE HAD
A ANIMATED- WRESTLING MATCH WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON ON
REFERRED TO FUNDING FOR
REFRIGERATED FRIENDS FUNDING FOR
WEATHERIZATION IT SEEMS THAT WE
ALWAYS GET PUSHED BACK UP TO SEE
THAT YOU GUYS ARE PROPOSING
SOMETHING BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE DOING SORT OF. THE BREAD AND
BUTTER ISSUES IN THE ALLEY- ASK
WHY WEISS FOOD ENERGY COMMISSION
VERSUS THE VIET- HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THAT DOES
THESE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
. LOW HANGING FRUIT CAN YOU HELP
ME TO MY READING THE PROPOSAL
WRONG. NO I THINK YOU DESCRIBED
IT ACCURATELY IN TERMS OF- THE
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING OUR
PROPOSAL TO DIVIDE THE FUNDS
WE'RE LOOKING AT- THE BULK OF
THE FUNDS GOING TO THE DIRECT
INSTALL SO SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO MILLION OUT OF THE
OUT OF THE TOTAL BALANCE OF
THREE MILLION GOING TO- TO
REBATE PROGRAM. AND- THE DIRECT
INSTALL WE WOULD NOT BE LOOKING
JUST ELECTRIC APPLIANCES WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT BUILDING
ENVELOPE SO INSULATION WINDOWS
ETCETERA AND YES THERE ARE
SIMILARITIES TO WHAT SHE HAS TO
THE COMMUNITY- CHOOSE A
DEVELOPMENT THAT DIVISION DOES-
BUT IT WOULD WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM WE DO
THINK THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS
THE RIGHT ENTERTAINMENT TO
MANAGE THESE FUNDS. THE PROGRAM
IS MUCH NARROWER- IT FOCUSES
MUCH MORE ON INTEREST ENVELOPE
SO WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE. PACKAGE
THAT- APPLE MAPS BUT- DOESN'T
DUPLICATE WHAT THEY- AND WILL BE
CLOSELY TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING THAT YOU
KNOW NOT DOING THE SAME SORT OF
THING IN THE SAME NEIGHBORHOODS
IN THE SAME. CERTAINLY NOT THE
SAME TOPICS. MR BROWN ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH ANY BUDGET REQUEST
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION ON.
HISTORY THE GENERAL. HAVE
SOMEBODY COME BY AND COCKY
WINDOWS TO SCUM HELLO YOU KNOW
LOW HANGING FRUIT FOR WEATHER
RISING- OUR APARTMENTS AND HOMES
AND BUSINESSES. DID I MISS IT IN
THE BUDGET. WELL THAT WOULD BE
THAT. OTHER THAN THIS PROPOSAL
JUST THE JUST THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE THAT UP
WITH OTHER AGENCIES NOT WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. YEAH I
APOLOGIES IF- RIGHT I THINK IT
WAS DIRECTED TOWARDS ME BUT- MR
BOAG CAN KIND OF JUMP IN AS
WELL- I THINK- I I'D HAVE TO GO
BACK AND LOOK IN THE PART OF
FINANCE MIGHT HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ON THAT I THINK
THERE WAS. SOME FUNDING FOR A
KIND OF- LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION AS PART OF KIND
OF THE RESILIENCY PACKAGE LAST
YEAR DON'T- I HAVE TO KIND OF GO
BACK AND DOUBLE CHECK THAT.
THERE IS SOME KIND OF GOING BACK
TO THE FEDERAL FUNDING ISSUE AS
PART OF THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. PACKAGE THERE
WAS A FINDING OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR WEATHERIZATION TYPE
ACTIVITIES- AND CST KIND OF HAS
ITS KIND OF ONGOING PROGRAMS
RELATED TO THAT ISSUE SO. THERE
IS SOME MONEY IN THERE AND HAVE
TO AGAIN I CAN KIND OF GO BACK
AND TRY TO PULL TOGETHER SOME OF
THOSE DIFFERENT PIECES THAT ARE
KIND OF SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THAT TO. YOU AND YOUR SPOUSE.
SERGIO I GO OUT WITH THE PART
OF- I COULD JUST JUMP IN HERE
REAL QUICK AND- YET. THEY'RE
LUCKY CAREER FUNDING PROVIDED AT
PART OF LAST YEAR'S MULTI YEAR
PACKAGE OF BILLS. IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THERE'S NOTHING
ADDITIONAL- TWENTY FIVE MILLION
AND THEN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IMPORTS YEAH. THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM SO THERE
IS ALREADY. A FUNDING. IN THE
BUDGET WORD A COUPLE YEARS. YEAH
YOUR CURRENT PROGRAM. I DON'T
THIS. NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO MILLION TWENTY FIVE MILLION
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
TWENTY FIVE MILLION SO WE CAN I
REMEMBER THOSE DEBATES WITH
FINANCE TO GET THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN THERE THAT DIDN'T PAN
IN THE BUDGET DISCUSSION SO I
JUST DRAW SOME ATTENTION DEAR TO
SOME OF THE LESS POPULAR TYPE
PROGRAMS THAT ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS SO MAYBE WE SHOULD
STEP BACK IN IN THE PAST THE
OVERALL STRATEGY YEAH BECAUSE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE LONG TERM
VERSUS THE SHORT TERM AND YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION AND THE
REFRIGERATION PROGRAMS CREATE
MUCH MORE BENEFITS IN THE SHORT
TERM. AND I GUESS I'M LOOKING
FOR THE THOUGHT PROCESS TO SEE
MINISTRATION WENT THROUGH WHEN
BALANCING THE SHORT TERM VERSUS
LONG TERM INVESTMENTS- AND IS
THERE AN ARGUMENT ABOUT DOING
MORE IN THE SHORT TERM TO DRIVE
STEEPER EMISSIONS. IN THE NEAR
TERM YOU KNOW I GUESS AGAIN TO
FIGHT. LET'S JUST BRING UP THE
REFRIGERANT PROGRAM PUT MORE
MONEY IN THERE TO GET THE GET
THE BENEFIT OF IT. US SENATOR.
REBEL AND I WOULD RESPOND. TO
THAT BY SAYING IF YOU LOOK AT
THE- BIG TICKET ITEMS THAT WOULD
BE DIRECTED TOWARDS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- ABOUT HALF THE
FUNDING. GOES TOWARDS BUILDING
THIS IS VERY SHORT TERM SO WE
NEED TO BUILD THE PROGRAM WE
NEED TO DO THE PUBLIC OUTRAGE TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE WE'RE DESIGNING
IT PROPERLY WE WANT TO BE A MIX
OF THE SORT OF- WHY WITH TYPE
STUFF THAT. THE INSULATION- THE
WEATHER IS ATION. COUPLED WITH
THE LONGER TERM SO EVEN IN ONE
PROGRAM WE'RE LOOKING AT PAUL
FOR A LOOK AT A QUICK INSTALLS
DON'T HAPPEN QUICKLY. BUT THE-
ADDRESS BOTH THE IMMEDIATE
PRODUCTION AND DEMAND-
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS AND
THEY'LL START MOVING TOWARDS-
GETTING MORE ELECTRIC APPLIANCES
IN THE- HOMES. THAT THEY CAN
HELP WITH OUR- COMMUNITY OUT
THERE TO BUILD THE- THE-
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT IS IN
THE BUSINESS- MAKING YOUR-
CONNECTIONS. IN THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO THAT ONE DEFINITELY A
SHORT TERM. INDUSTRIAL AFTER
THAT YOU POINTED OUT VERY GOOD
VALUE LOW COST PER PER TON- ALSO
VERY QUICK WE'VE WE'VE GOT MANY
OF THOSE PROJECTS COMPLETE
ALREADY AND IT'S ONLY A COUPLE
YEAR OLD PROGRAM. WE THINK IT'LL
STILL BE CURRENT CAN BE THE SAME
THING. THE OTHER ONES ARE LONGER
TERM WE ARE LOOKING AT LONGER
RATIONS STORAGE AS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF. IF YOU TAKE THIS CAN
TAKE SOME INVESTMENTS WE'VE GOT
SOME TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE'VE
INVESTED IN WE'VE GOT OTHERS
THAT WE SPENT STUDYING. AND WE
BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
JUST ON THE CUSP OF BEING ABLE
TO SCALE AND SO THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL YIELD RESULTS
IN THE SAME TIME FRAME AS THE
OTHERS. BUT THEY THEY WERE
HOPEFUL THAT THEY COULD BE
AVAILABLE QUICKLY HI JIM ALSO
WHEN SIMILARLY THESE TAKE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER. ARE ARE YOU.
ARE REPEATS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DRIVE THE KIND OF-
APPLIANCES ADAPTATION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. OTHER OTHER
SORT OF POLICY TOOLS YOU COULD
USE. ORDERED I MEAN THAT'S
BECAUSE- IDEALLY WE'D WE'D- WE-
REALLY LIKED THE FLEXIBILITY WE
PUT FORTH THE DIVISION OF TWO
THIRDS ONE THIRD TWO THIRDS
DIRECT INSTALL FOR A REBATE. BUT
WE WHAT WE WANT TO WORKSHOP THAT
AND FIND OUT IN ONE MAY PROVE TO
BE A BIT MORE EFFECTIVE THAN THE
OTHER WE HAVE ESTIMATES ON WHAT
THE COST PER TON WILL BE FOR
EACH. BUT YOU KNOW WE KNOW WE'VE
GOT A LOT TO LEARN AND EXPECT TO
DO SO DURING THE- DURING THE-
OPERATION THAT WE CONDUCTED.
WELL I KNOW THAT THE- TURNING TO
THE FEDERAL FUNDS THEY'RE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
THE SIMILAR ACTIVITIES HELLO IN
TWENTY THREE OF OUR STAFF REPORT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CLEAN
ENERGY HYDROGEN HUBS I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SECOND MOST HYDROGEN STATIONS IN
THE WORLD. IN BED NEXT TO JAPAN
AND I KNOW THAT ENERGY
COMMISSION IS PROUD OF THAT AND
IF WE JUST DO THE TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS WE WILL BE NUMBER ONE IN
THE NATION SO HI RIGHT OF ALL
THE THINGS I'M ANXIOUS ABOUT
GETTING ONE OF THE FOUR ENERGY
HUBS IS NOT ONE OF THEM RIGHT
THAT'S NOT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD DO BUT
WE HAVE CARBON CAPTURE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS. AND I
KNOW NOTE THAT THE- THIS
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS SILENT ON
CARBON CAPTURE FOR
ELECTRIFICATION CAN YOU. IS THAT
BY DESIGN IS UP BY OVERSIGHT. N.
N. Y. IF IT IS. WELL IN AN
INDUSTRIAL THE CURVE WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF- TAKING CARBON AND
EMBEDDING IT IN PRODUCTS SO THAT
FORM OF SEQUESTRATION WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF WE DIDN'T THINK
THAT- THE TIME FRAMES ARE ARE
ARE ARE. GOOD TO BE LOOKING AT
INVESTING STATE DOLLARS IN IN
THE IN THE- THE SITUATION I
THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHERE
WE YOU PUT IT UNDERGROUND OR
OTHERWISE TRY TO MOVE IT OUT OF-
OF THE ABSTRUSE LONG PERIODS OF
TIME SO WE BEGIN WE'RE FOCUSING
ON WHERE WE COULD PUT IN
PRODUCTS. BUT THE BUT NOT THE
OTHER PART IN YOUR RIGHT THERE
IS QUITE A BIT OF MONEY IN IN
THAT SPACE IN THE- IN THE
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
MISTER BROWN WE YOU READ THE-
LIVERMORE LABS REPORTED SAID
EVEN IF WE DO EVERYTHING THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO DO. AND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO
BE A HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT.
METRIC TONS PER YEAR SHORT AND
ONE OF THE ANSWERS HIS. NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. AND DIRECT CARBON
CAPTURE AND THEN- THE CARBON.
ALL FASHION CARBON CAPTURE I
GUESS I WOULD SAY- DOES THAT
CONCERN YOU WE'VE GOT SO MUCH
FEDERAL TOO ON THE- OUT THERE
THAT WE COULD USE TO MEET OUR
SHORT TERM AND MEDIUM TERM-
CARBONATION PROBLEMS AND THEN
WORK FOR LIMITING THE PROTECT
THE PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GOOD TO
GO AFTER. YEAH AND ACTUALLY THIS
IS- THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE-
HIGHLIGHTED ARE NOW ALSO SAYS
WELL AND I JUST DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO KIND OF GET TO IT IN MY
COMMENTS BUT- I THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE I MEAN THERE ARE
CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES IN CERTAIN
TYPES OF CHRONIC CARBON
REDUCTION. ACTIONS THAT ARE
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED FROM THIS
PACKAGE AND THE- CARBON CAPTURE
GEOLOGIC STORAGES IS ONE EXAMPLE
OF THAT SO- I MEAN I THINK BIG
PICTURE IN A MEETING- THE SORT
OF LONG TERM DECARBONISATION
GOALS BY. TWENTY FORTY FIVE OR
SOME OTHER TYPE OF SIMILAR DATE
IS. IT'S FRANKLY- EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE WILL I THINK NEED TO
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER IT
WANTS TO. TAKE CERTAIN TYPES OF
OPTIONS OF TECHNOLOGY IS OFF THE
TABLE TO KINDA YOU KNOW IN
MEETING THAT GOAL AND SO WHEN
THERE ARE SOME TRADE OFFS I MEAN
IF YOU KIND OF FEEL EXPANDED TO
A LARGER SET OF POTENTIAL
TECHNOLOGIES THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT COULD GO TO EACH. WOULD BE
A LITTLE BIT LESS BUT WE DO
THINK THAT AT THIS POINT KIND OF
THINKING ABOUT THINGS AS BROADLY
AS POSSIBLE AND KIND OF THING
INCLUDING AS MANY DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
OUT THERE AND TRYING TO EXPLORE.
WHICH ONES ARE ABLE TO KIND OF
ACHIEVE THE GOALS COST
EFFECTIVELY GOING FORWARD- AND
KIND OF EXPLORING THOSE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES- WE THINK
IT'S KIND OF A REASONABLE
APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE TO
THINK ABOUT THINK ABOUT HOW TO
EXPANDING THE- THE- OF THE OF
TECHNOLOGIES AND KIND OF
FACILITIES THAT COULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING.
THERE'S VALUE IN NEAR ZERO
REDUCTIONS NOT ZERO BUT NEAR IS
A REDUCTION IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
PATH. AS A MYSTERY I GUESS THE
NEXT QUESTION IS THAT YOU KNOW
SOME OF THESE FEDERAL PROGRAMS
REQUIRE. A MATCH IN THE IN THE-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
ALLOCATE ANY STATEMENTS FOR THE
GRID RESILIENCY AND I WAS
WONDERING. AGAIN ON THE SAME
SORT OF VEIN. WHY NOT IT'S A BIT
TOO HIGHLIGHTED IN PAGE TWENTY
THREE OF OUR OUR OUR. STAFF
REPORT WHY ARE WE NOT. DOING
THAT WHEN THE FEDERAL. YOU KNOW-
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AND JOB CHECK
WAS WAS OUT AND OCTOBER OR
NOVEMBER WE KNOW ABOUT THAT. AND
IF THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE ANY
OTHER GAPS IS OUR STAFF REPORT.
TALKS ABOUT. BUT SENATOR I WOULD
POINT TO THE THERE'S SEVERAL
THERE'S A THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STATUTORY ELEMENTS
UNDER GREATER LIABILITY AND WE
WERE LOOKING AT A BROADLY AS
OTHERS A SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
THAT THAT IS FOR THAT IS A
FORMULA GRANTS TO CALIFORNIA
WILL GET. SHOULD IT BE A
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF ONE OF
THOSE POTS OF MONEY WHICH IS A
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND WE'RE
USING IS A ROUGH. ESTIMATE
THAT'S 10% OF THAT SO CALIFORNIA
IS LOOKING TO GET FIVE OR
MILLION- FROM THE- FROM THE
FORMULA GRANTS. THERE'S ANOTHER
FIVE BILLION IN VERY SIMILAR
IT'S WORDED SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY
BUT IT'S VERY SIMILAR FUNDING
FOR GRADE A LOT GREATER
LIABILITY. AGAIN ALSO FIVE
BILLION AND THAT'S COMPETITIVE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER POT
SHOULD SHIP WITH UNDER THAT
WITHIN THAT SO WE'RE LOOKING OF
COURSE AT THE FORMULA GRANT. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN.
LEVERAGE THE EXPERIENCE WE'VE
GOT PERHAPS SOME OF THE FUNDING
WE WE'RE WE'RE SEEKING THE LONG
DURATION STORAGE FUNDING COULD
BE MATCH FOR- FOR THE SCREEN
RELIABILITY IT'S NOT CERTAIN YET
WE'RE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
DELIA. AND THEY'RE THEY'RE STILL
WORKING ON A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS BUT WE THINK THERE MAY
BE A WAYS TO LEVERAGE SOME OF
THE STATE'S FUNDING. AS A AS A
FORM OF MATCH FOR THAT ONE
CERTAINLY THAT'S TRUE FOR
HYDROGEN. AND SOME OF THE OTHER.
HELLO AND THAT DOG MILLION MORE
CHECKING FOR. COULD BE USED
LEVERAGE THE- NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN HYDROGEN
FUNDING. AND THAT'S NOT FOCUSED
CHIEFLY ON ON VEHICLES IT'S MORE
ON OTHER ASPECTS OF HOW HIGH SHE
CAN PLAY A ROLE IN THE ECONOMY.
BUT I MEAN WE HAVE A THIGH AGAIN
LIMIT WE'RE WITH THAT. THEN WITH
THE ANTICIPATED ADDITIONAL
REVENUES COMING IN IT SEEMS LIKE
THOSE ARE. YOU KNOW WE'RE I'VE
BEEN INSTRUCTED TO LOOK AT
PROJECTS ARE LOOK AT.
INVESTMENTS THAT WOULD HELP US
COME UNDER THE CAN LIMIT- AND IT
SEEMS TO ME IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PUTTING MONEY IN.
AND JUST SIT. THIS PICKING
CARBON CAPTURE THIS HERE THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PARALLELS THOUGH SO THAT WE CAN
PARTICIPATE AT LEAST
COMPETITIVELY. INSTEAD OF.
CHOOSING WINNERS AND LOSERS NOW
BEFORE HER. YOU KNOW IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. WE GOT TO THREE TO
GET TO. BUY MY SHINY PENNY SIZED
IN THE SKY. OKAY- I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS OPEN-
OBVIOUSLY REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
LOOKING FOR ON FOR ALL THE
AGENCIES HERE- SO WE CAN
CONTINUE. OR SOMEBODY CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE OVERSIGHT AND
WE'LL KEEP THIS MATTER OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVED BACK
TO THE PUBLIC COULD YOU DO TO
LEASE COMMISSIONS. THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED MINISTRY OF
LAW JUDGE DIVISION MANAGEMENT
AND PRECEDING SUPPORT THIS IS
ONE POINT TWO MILLION FOR A
PERMANENT. POSITIONS- GO AHEAD.
OKAY MORNING CARE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
TERROR HOUSEKI HONORABLE
SENATORS RACHEL PETERSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION YES WE HAVE THE NEXT
SEVERAL ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AND-
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TOWARDS
SIXTY CHEAP ALE J. WHO'S GOING
TO SPEAK ABOUT- ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
A COUPLE OF TOP LINE POINTS
ABOUT ALL THE PROPOSALS TODAY-
WE ARE WE HAVE CAREFULLY
DESIGNED THEM TO ACCOMPLISH THE
PERMANENT AND ONGOING WORK LOAD
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS SET OUT
FOR US THAT'S TRUE THAT'S DRIVEN
BY OUR STATUTORY RULES AND
MANDATES- SET OUT BY THE
LEGISLATURE ACROSS THE SECTORS
THAT WE REGULATE SO ENERGY
TRANSPORTATION
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
CYBERSECURITY AND CLEAN WATER.
NEXT POINT IS WE ARE INVESTING
OVER TO OUR RESOURCES
STRATEGICALLY WE SCANNED OUR
CORE OPERATIONS AND IDENTIFY THE
AREAS- WHERE WE DO HAVE AN
INCREASED PERMANENT AND ONGOING
WORK LOAD. WITHIN THOSE CORE
OPERATIONS DRIVEN BY LEGISLATION
AGAIN DRIVEN BY NEW COMPLIANCE
CONTROLS- THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THROUGH EXTERNAL AND
INTERNAL AUDITS AND BY INCREASED
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS. NOW WE
DEFINITELY TAKE A LEAN APPROACH
TO THOSE CORE OPERATIONAL
PROPOSALS AND REALLY TRY TO ONLY
FOCUS RESOURCES RESOURCE
REQUESTS WHERE THEY ARE TRULY
NEEDED. AND THEN THE LAST OUR
PROPOSALS I BELIEVE ARE ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S AMBITIOUS
POLICY GOALS WHICH HAVE BEEN
UNDER ROBUST DISCUSSION THIS
MORNING- BUT ESPECIALLY AROUND
CLEAN ENERGY BROADBAND FOR ALL
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER AND
SAFE- PASSENGER TRANSPORTATION.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING WE HAVE ALL OF OUR
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS LINED UP
TO TAKE THROUGH THE ISSUES ON
THE AGENDA. AND WE WILL ALL BE
HERE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU TURNED OUT TO BE
ASSISTANT CHIEF. ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE PAXSON. THANK YOU ALL-
GOOD MORNING SHARE THE MORNING
SENATORS MY NAME IS PAT THEN I
AM AN ASSISTANT CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE IN A-
J. DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. I
AM PRESENTING ON AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR- BE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE DIVISION MANAGEMENT
AND PRECEDING SUPPORT. WE'RE
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF EIGHT
POSITIONS WHICH INCLUDES ONE
ASSISTANT CHIEF ALJ FIVE SUPPORT
STAFF POSITIONS AND TO ASSUME
SEATED MANAGERS. AS DETAILED IN
THE AGENDA THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE DIVISION CONDUCTS
FORMAL PROCEEDINGS SIMILAR TO A
COURT SYSTEM AND HAS TWO BASIC
RESPONSIBILITIES. ONE CONDUCTING
HEARINGS CONSISTENT WITH DUE
PROCESS TO DEVELOP A COMPLETE
EVIDENTIARY RECORD TO SUPPORT
PROPOSED DECISIONS BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE COMMISSION.
AND TO ADMINISTER THE CPUC.
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. THIS
DIVISION ALSO ACTS AS AN
APPELLATE BODY WHEN AN ENTITY
CITED THROUGH ONE OF THE
COMMISSION'S TWENTY SEVEN
CITATION PROGRAMS FILES AN
APPEAL. THIS B. C. P. IS
DESIGNED TO MAKE STRUCTURAL
IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT OUR COURT
SYSTEM FUNCTIONS BETTER AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY. HE HAS TWO ELEMENTS
FIRST ADDITIONAL MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE PROCEDURAL
AND SUBSTANTIVE REVIEW AND TO
ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT TURNOVER AND
THE NEED FOR RECRUITMENT HIRING
AND TRAINING. AND SECOND ANALYST
IN SUPPORT POSITIONS PROVIDE
DIRECT SUPPORT TO BAIL J. N. A.
L. G. MANAGEMENT. FIRST ON THE
MANAGEMENT ASPECT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. DUE TO RETENTION
ISSUES FOR THE ALJ POSITION
WHERE AT 20% ANNUAL TURNOVER
WITHIN RANK AND FILE HE'LL CHASE
. CURRENTLY MORE THAN HALF OF
OUR JUDGES HAVE LESS THAN THREE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WHICH IS
TYPICALLY THE TIME IT TAKES FOR
NEW A. L. J. AT THE C. P. U. C.
TO BECOME FULLY TRYING. THIS
MEANS THAT YOUR AGING MANAGEMENT
MUST SPEND ADDITIONAL TIME TO
TRAIN AND REVIEW WORK PRODUCTS.
AS WELL AS CLOSELY MONITOR
PROCEEDINGS SOTHAT WE CAN
CONTINUE- WITHIN THEIR SUBJECT
OVERSIGHT. WITH THIS REQUEST
WE'RE REQUESTING ONE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANT CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
POSITIONS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FILL OUR VACANCIES
AND PROVIDE ADEQUATE TRAINING
AND OVERSIGHT FOR THE JUDGES.
THIS PORTION OF THE REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES CHIEF ANALYST POSITIONS
THAT WILL PROVIDE ANALYTICAL AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT TO THE NINE
MEMBERS OF THE LG MANAGEMENT
TEAM. CURRENTLY WE SHARE ONE
LEGAL SECRETARY THAT PERFORMS
DOCUMENT PROCESSING FUNCTIONS.
SECOND WE'RE REQUESTING
PROCEEDING SUPPORT FOR THE
JUDGES IN THE FORM OF TWO
ADDITIONAL ANALYSTS AND ONE
LEGAL SECRETARY. FOR EACH FORMAL
PROCEEDING AT THE C. P. U. C.
THERE IS AN ASSIGNED
COMMISSIONER AND ONE OR MORE
ASSIGNED ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE. UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
PROCEEDINGS ARE OPENED AND
CLOSED EACH YEAR WITH
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE OPEN AT ANY GIVEN
TIME. THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE ASSISTS THE ASSIGNED
COMMISSIONER IN DETERMINING
SCOPE FOR EACH PRECEDING.
DEVELOPS THE PRECEDING RECORD
CONDUCTS HEARINGS AND PREPARES
PROPOSED DECISIONS FOR
COMMISSION CONSIDERATION. ALL
WITHIN STATUTORILY PRESCRIBED
TIMELINES. THESE POSITIONS WILL
PROVIDE DIRECT PROCEEDING
MANAGEMENT AND DOCUMENT
PROCESSING SUPPORT TO JUDGES.
OUR STATUTORY PERIOD FOR
COMPLETING PROCEEDINGS WERE
SHORTENED BY S. B. TWO OH FIVE.
POLITICIAN ALL REQUIREMENTS WERE
ADDED TO IMPROVE PUBLIC ACCESS
AND TRANSPARENCY THIS TEAM WILL
HELP MAKE SURE THAT WE MEET
THOSE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
SERVE FUNCTIONS SIMILAR TO
PARALEGALS OR COURT CLERKS IN
THE CIVIL COURT SYSTEM. WE WILL
ALSO PROVIDE THE MORE COMPLEX
LOGISTICAL SUPPORT FOR HEARINGS
THAT WE'RE HOLDING REMOTELY AND
IN HYBRID FORM. THE LAST POINT
THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT
OUR DIVISION HAS UNDERGONE A
TRANSFORMATION IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS. AS YOUR AGENDA POINTS OUT
WE HAVE HIRED THIRTEEN JUDGES IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS AND TWO OF
THOSE YEARS WERE DURING THE CALL
THAT PENDANT. BY ADDRESSING BOTH
MANAGING MANAGEMENT AND
ANALYTICAL SUPPORT. IT'S B. C.
P. IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN TRAIN OUR NEW JUDGES. BRING
THEM UP TO SPEED. AND MAKE OUR
COURT SYSTEM FUNCTION WELL TO
MANAGE OUR FORMAL PROCEEDINGS
THAT ADDRESS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
ESSENTIAL UTILITY SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. SERVICE
RELIABILITY EQUITABLE ACCESS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND AFFORDABILITY
. THIS COMPLETE PCP MAKE
STRUCTURAL IMPROVEMENTS WITHIN A
L. G. DIVISION ONE AND A. O. J.
MANAGEMENT AND THE OTHER
INDIRECT PROCEEDING SUPPORT TO
JUDGES. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS VERY THOROUGH
DIGESTION- MISTER BROWN DO YOU
HAVE ANY OBSERVATIONS ON THE- LG
DIVISION MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL. MR
SURE WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND- IN CASE
IT'S HELPFUL WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUES OR CONCERNS WITH THE REST
OF THE KIND OF ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA OF COURSE WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
YOU SEE THAT THEY WERE GONNA BE
ON THE HOT SEAT THIS IS THE
START IS STARTED I GUESS MY
QUESTION WOULD BE SHOULD WE
EXPECT A DECREASE IN THE
TURNOVER WITH THESE RESOURCES I
MEAN YOU'VE OUTLINED THAT THERE
THERE COULD BE A SIGN THERE-
AND- IS SET. TELL ME WHAT I
SHOULD EXPECT IT SHOULD IT BE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE.
TRAINING AND MORE BACK OF
SUPPORT HIS SECOND HELP WITH THE
TURNOVER PROBLEM OR SUGGEST
SOMETHING ABOUT. THE P. YOU SEE
THAT PEOPLE LEAVE. ALSO THE
FIRST ON THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR SO- THAT'S
RECEIVING SUPPORT THAT THE- LAID
OUT REALLY DOES ACTUALLY AFFECT
THE QUALITY OF THE JOB-
EXPERIENCE FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES. THE LAST TIME THAT
YOU NEED TO SPEND ON- SUPPORT
ITEMS LIKE MARSHALING EVIDENCE
AND INSURING THAT I. T. WORKS
FOR THE HEARINGS THAT ARE
MANAGING HONESTLY THE HAPPIER
THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY GET TO
FOCUS ON THE REASON THAT THEY
BECAME AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE IN THE FIRST PLACE. THE
HIGHLY INTERESTING SUBSTANCE.
THE PROCEEDINGS THAT WE.
ANYTHING ELSE. TO ADD I JUST
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS ONE OF
THOSE. TELL CHANGES YET AND THAT
IS EXACTLY RIGHT- B. B. THE
REQUEST THAT WE HAVE HERE IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS SORT OF THE
TURNOVER AT THE RETENTION
ISSUES- THERE ARE STRUCTURAL
THINGS THAT WE CAN'T CHANGE BUT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A
ENVIRONMENT. WHERE JUDGES ARE
ABLE TO WORK ON THE VERY
INTERESTING WORK THAT WE DO
HERE- AND THEY'RE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON THE SUBSTANCE- ON THE LG
MANAGEMENT SITE- THE ADDITIONAL-
ASSISTANT CHIEF ALJ IS REALLY
ALSO INTENDED TO PROVIDE A MORE
ROBUST. TRAINING AND SUPPORT TO
JUDGES SO THAT WE AVOID BURNOUT
AND THAT- WE ARE ABLE TO RETAIN
REALLY SMART AND GOOD PEOPLE AS
THEY BECOME MORE EFFICIENT AS
THEY BECOME BETTER AT MANAGING
PROCEEDINGS AT THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU WHAT WE'RE GONNA
FOLLOW STEP INSTRUCTIONS-
RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP THIS
MATTER OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND THE
CLARIFICATION ON ON THE PROGRAM
AND WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS AUTHORIZATION FOR
PERMANENT FUNDING OF LIMIT OF
KEY LIMITED TERM POSITIONS. IN
SUPPORT OF ENERGY POLICY
STATUTES AND WE HAVE. HER
BACKGROUND PROVIDES ALL THE
STATUTES STEP WE'RE. GOING TO
HAVE COVERED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
UGH MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND GOOD
MORNING SENATORS- MY NAME IS
NICK SAID JOHNNY I'M WITH THE
CQC'S ENERGY DIVISION PRESENTING
ON THIS ITEM. WE ARE REQUESTING
AUTHORIZATION FOR PERMANENT
FUNDING OF NINETEEN AND A HALF
HE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO BE
MADE. PERMANENT AND THAT SUPPORT
WORK CURRENTLY ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING ELEVEN SEPARATE
ENERGY POLICY STATUTES WHICH YOU
REFERENCED MR CHAIRMAN. IN AREAS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON MICRO
GRIDS AND RESILIENCY- BIOMETHANE
ENERGY STORAGE INTERCONNECTION
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY CUSTOM
PROJECTS. WE ORIGINALLY RECEIVED
THIRTY ONE AND A HALF POSITIONS
TO PERFORM THE INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATUTES.
WE HAVE TRIMMED DOWN THIS
REQUEST BY TWELVE POSITIONS ARE
JUST SHORT OF FIFTY PERCENT. THE
ORIGINAL REQUESTS WERE- RELATED
TO NASCENT INDUSTRIES AND WE'VE
HAD SOME TIME SINCE THEN TO
DETERMINE WHAT YOUR NEEDS ARE
AND THAT IS WHAT'S REFLECTED. IN
THIS PARTICULAR BCP BECAUSE
PREVIOUSLY IT WAS UNCLEAR WHAT
THE PERMANENT WORKLOAD WOULD BE
AND WHAT WOULD INVOLVE- SO WE
ARE REQUESTING NINETEEN AND A
HALF- POSITIONS TO BE MADE
PERMANENT- THEY WILL CONTINUE
THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE CQC'S
WORK AND SPECIFICALLY- THE
POSITIONS ENCOMPASS THE ENTIRE
MICROGRID SECTION WITHIN ENERGY
DIVISION FROM THE SUPERVISOR
DOWN TO ALL THE STAFF AND THEY
ARE NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
INCREASED RELIABILITY. REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK AND REDUCE COSTS
TO RATEPAYERS TO BUILD EXTENSIVE
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE.
MICRO GRIDS ARE UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO HELP CALIFORNIA
RESPOND TO THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRE DISRUPTIONS IN THE
LARGER GRID INCLUDING THE PS PS
EVENTS THAT SENATOR DALLY.
REFERENCED EARLIER. HAVING THE
POSITIONS IN PLACE TO CONTINUE
MY PROGRESS POLICY WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE
PRETTY CLEARLY AND HERE TO
STRICT SAFETY STANDARDS AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND TO FILL
THEIR POTENTIAL TO GENUINELY
IMPROVE. RESILIENCY AND REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK CAN ALSO SAVE
MONEY FOR REPAIRS. THE BIO
ENERGY POSITIONS ENCOMPASS ALL
OF OUR RENEWABLE GAS AND
BIOFUELS STAFF WITH AN INTEGER
DIVISION AND ALL OF THE STAFF
DEDICATED TO GASIFICATION WORK
AND ENERGY PRODUCTION WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH BIOMASS
PROCESSING. AND THEY ARE
ESSENTIAL TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND TO HELP US REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND TO
DECARBONIZE OUR FUEL MOVING
FORWARD AS WELL AS TO IMPROVE
LOCAL AIR QUALITY EMISSIONS. BY
THE DEVELOPMENT OF HYDROGEN AND
OTHER CLEAN FUELS- THESE
POSITIONS ARE ALSO ESSENTIAL IN
IMPLEMENTING THE RENEWABLE GAS
STANDARD BUT THE PC JUST ADOPTED
AT ITS LAST VOTING MEETING. LAST
WEEK. THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
POSITIONS ARE CENTRAL TO
IMPLEMENTING THE STATUTE THAT
REQUIRES US TO PROVIDE ONGOING
OVERSIGHT OF CUSTOM ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS THAT HAVE TO
BE REVIEWED ON A TIMELY BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH REPAIR INTEREST.
THOSE PROJECTS ARE ANTICIPATED
TO GROW ABOUT 20% OVER THE NEXT
DECADE SO HAVING A STAFF IN
PLACE TO PERFORM THE STATUTORY
CHARLIE REQUIRED FUN IN THE
MANNER. IS ESSENTIAL. AND
FINALLY THE ENERGY STORAGE
INTERCONNECTION POSITIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO COST EFFECTIVELY INTEGRATE
ENERGY STORAGE TO SUPPORT G. SHE
REDUCTIONS FOR LIABILITY AND
RENEWABLES INTEGRATION- AS
ENERGY STORAGE QUICKLY BECOMES
THE DOMINANT RESOURCE BEING
TORTURED AND INTEGRATED INTO THE
GRID. THE CQC BY APPROVING THIS
B. C. P. WILL HAVE THE STAFF
RESOURCES NEEDED TO CONDUCT
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF THIS
RAPIDLY GROWING AREA OF
PROCUREMENT. REPAIRS ARE ALREADY
PAYING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
BULK ENERGY STORAGE AND THE CQC
STAFF PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
EVALUATING WHICH PROJECTS TO
IMPROVE SO THAT ENERGY STORAGE
RESULTS IN NET SAVINGS AND NOT
NET COSTS. TO REPAIRS WHILE ALSO
SUPPORTING RELIABILITY GHG
REDUCTION AND RENEWABLES
INTEGRATION FURTHERMORE THE
INTERCONNECTION POSITIONS WILL
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
INTERCONNECTION WHILE
MAINTAINING THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY. AS DRAMATIC
INCREASES IN THE QUANTITY AND
COMPLEXITY OF NEW DISTRIBUTED
RESOURCES ARE ADDED TO THE GRID
AND WITH THAT I'LL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU SUPERVISORS. THE JOHNNY- MR
BROWN. THREE YEARS AGO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION CAME TO US ASK
FOR THIRTY ONE AND A HALF
POSITIONS LIMITED TERM AND THEY
WERE GOING TO WORK ON ALL THIS
PRODUCT NOW THEY'RE BACK THREE
YEARS LATER AND SAYING HEY WE
WANT TO CONVERT NINETEEN AND A
HALF OF THESE POSITIONS TO FULL
TO PERMANENT POSITIONS IT'S
ALMOST A MODEL OF HOW STATE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD RUN BUT WE
HAVE A GOAL WE HAVE THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE PASS ALL THIS
LEGISLATION TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
COME IN WE WANT TO DO LIMITED
TERM WE'RE GOING TO GET IT
TOGETHER. AND THEN I GUESS
PEOPLE COULD SEE THE GET THIS
THE LEGISLATURE DEMANDED THAT
YOU HAVE LIMITED TERM AND COME
BACK TO US REPORT TO US IT'S
ALMOST I COULD TEACH A GRADUATE
CLASS ON HOW GOVERNMENT WORKS
HERE FIVE WOULD YOU DISAGREE
WITH THAT OR AGREE WITH THOSE
THOSE OBSERVATIONS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK I WAS THINKING
THE SAME THING AND AGREE THAT
THIS SEEMS TO BE KIND OF A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF- KIND OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS WORKING IN SORT OF WHY
YOU HAVE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
WHEN THE- ONGOING WORKLOAD IS IT
IS NOT CLEAR IF THERE'S KIND OF
A NEW PROGRAMMER NEW INDUSTRIES
AND O. IMPROVING THEM ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS AND THEN RE
ASSESSING WHAT THE ONGOING
WORKLOAD. IS GOING FORWARD-
SEEMS LIKE A- VERY REASONABLE
APPROACH TO US AND THAT'S WHY WE
KIND OF OFTEN RECOMMEND THAT
APPROACH AND IT SEEMS LIKE-
THAT'S APPROACH THAT IS BEING
TAKEN HERE IT SEEMS TO WORK
PRETTY WELL. VERY GOOD EXCELLENT
REPORT SUPERVISORS AND CONNIE
AND WE WILL KEEP THIS MATTER
OPEN AND I THE REASON I DWELL ON
THAT THE BENEFIT THAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM SO THAT THE
BLANKET EXEMPTION WERE. THE THE
PC USES THEIR OPERATING BUDGET
CREATES POSITIONS WE DON'T HAVE
OVERSIGHT AND THEN AND THEN.
COMES AND ASKS FOR FORGIVENESS
TO LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX- THE COMMUNICATIONS
LICENSING COMPLIANCE SECTION-
PERMANENT POSITION AUTHORITY.
CAN WE TICKETS ARE LIKE OUR SKI
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M ROBERT OSBORNE DIRECTOR OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION AT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WE'RE REQUESTING THE AUTHORITY
AND FUNDING TO CONVERT TO
BLANKET POSITION BUT WE CREATED
TWO YEARS AGO. CAMPBELL THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD AND A
LICENSING AND COMPLIANCE
SECTION. TO CONVERT THOSE TO
PERMANENT THESE TWO POSITIONS
ARE SPECIFICALLY AT PUBLIC
UTILITIES REGULATORY ANALYST
TREAT. ANY STAFF SERVICES
ANALYST. FOR MAKING THIS REQUEST
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE COMMISSION
IMPOSE NEW LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALL
INTERCONNECTED VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL CARRIERS.
WHICH ADDS NEW WORKLOAD TO THE
PC. CERTAINLY THE NEW LICENSING
. IS A RESPONSE TO THE PC IS
EXPANDED REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
OVER INTER CONNECTED VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL CARRIERS THE
SIGNS THAT A PUBLIC UTILITIES
CODE SEVEN TEN. ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. I'M IN A POSITION
OF AUTHORITY IF NECESSARY TO
CONTINUOUSLY AND EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE THE INCREASING NUMBER OF
COMMUNICATIONS LICENSES AND
RELATED COMPLIANCE FUNCTIONS
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE THE
LIABLE AND REASONABLE
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURES
AND SERVICES IN THE STATE. WITH
REGARD TO OUTCOMES CONVERTING
THESE TWO TEMPORARY BLANKET
POSITIONSTO PERMANENT WELL
FIRST WITH OVER ONE THOUSAND
COMMUNICATION CARRIERS OPERATING
IN THE STATE THE PROGRAM WILL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE BETTING CARRIER
FILINGS TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
INCLUDING WHETHER TO ISSUE
CITATIONS. ALLOWING THE
LICENSING AND COMPLIANCE ACTION
TO CONTINUE AND EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE THE HIGH VOLUME OF
TELECOMMUNICATION LICENSES AS
WELL AS THE RELATED COMPLIANCE
CITATION FUNCTIONS. AND MOREOVER
IT WILL ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO
CONTINUE EMPOWERING PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA THROUGH ACCESS TO
SAFE RELIABLE AND REASONABLE
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDINGTHE
PREVENTION OF FRAUD WASTE AND
ABUSE AND THE PROVISION OF THOSE
SERVICES BUT THAT'LL BE
HAPPENING AT. YOUR QUESTION. ALL
RIGHT. MR YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT
YOU WERE MORE OR LESS OKAY ON
THESE. CONCERNS THAT YOU SHARE-
CORRECT- PETERSON THIRD THAT IS
OUR STAFF REPORT. POINTS OUT
THESE ARE GENERALLY REASONABLE
YOU KNOW IT'S LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
COMMUNICATIONS BUT YOU GET MY
DRIFT ON TO THE USE OF THE OF
THE BLANKET AUTHORITY THAT WE
GIVE THEM WE WANNA- THERE IS. A
GREAT INTEREST IN ACCOUNTABILITY
BY BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
AGENCIES OF WHAT'S GOING ON AND
YOU SAW EARLIER MATTERS
REQUIRING REPORTING SO THAT WE
CAN GET INFORMATION ON WHAT'S
GOING ON. AND SO THE INTERIM
POSITION IS ARE NICE WAY OF. YOU
KNOW ANTICIPATING WORKLOAD AND
THEN SEE WHAT THE REAL WORKLOAD
IS AND COME BACK- BUT WELL ON IT
BUT IT IS JUST FULL OF. SONGS
EVERYBODY GETS MY DRAFT. YES
HERE I'VE GOT YOUR DRIFT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THAT
MATTER OPENING GOA WITH T.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES THIS IS ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR TEN NEW
PERMANENT FULL TIME POSITIONS
FOR. INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR SENATORS
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT. I AM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION.
TODAY OUR RESEARCH PRESENTING
MY- DIVISION SECURITY
ENHANCEMENTS. THE CBC'S BRING
FORWARD THIS REQUEST TO IMPROVE
CPC CYBERSECURITY POSTURE.
CONSOLIDATED ENTERPRISE IT
SECURITY RISK AND COMPLIANCE
ACTIVITIES ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL
AND ADDRESS AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
AND ASSESSMENTS BY THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGIES
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICE
SPECIFICALLY. WE ARE REQUESTING
TEN POSITIONS. WHILE AT THE I.
TEAM MANAGER TO LEVEL TO PROVIDE
A NEW CHIEF SECURITY OFFICER AND
I. T. RISK COMPLIANCE OFFICER
CONSOLIDATING THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER SINGLE
POSITION WHICH SHOULD FOCUS ON
CPEC STRATEGIC GOALS SECURITY
GOALS. THREE I. T. SPECIALIST
WHOSE. POSITIONS TO FOCUS ON
STRATEGIC IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
CPSC'S CYBER SECURITY POSTURE
IMPLEMENT AND UPDATE
TECHNOLOGIES TO KEEP PACE WITH
NEW INVOLVING THREATS. SIX I. T.
SPECIALIST ONCE RIGHT ADEQUATE
STAFFING TO MONITOR AND RESPOND
TO SECURITY INCIDENTS. THESE
POSITIONS ALSO ELIMINATE SINGLE
POINTS OF FAILURE IN THE CQC
CYBER SECURITY TEAM. ALLOW THE
C. PCA TO IMPROVE AND MATURE OUR
SECURITY POSTURE BY ADDRESSING
FINDINGS IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR AN INDEPENDENT SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS BY THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SECURITY OFFICE. AS A RESULT OF
THE AUDIT ADDITIONAL STAFFING
THE CQC WILL BE ABLE TO.
CENTRALIZE ALL IT SECURITY RISK
AND COMPLIANCE OVERSIGHT TO
STRATEGICALLY CONSOLIDATE ALL
RESPONSES AT THE ENTERPRISE
LEVEL. ESTABLISH ENTERPRISE DATA
SECURITY GOVERNANCE AND
STRENGTHEN EXISTING SECURITY
GOVERNANCE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
DEVELOPING A SECURITY ROADMAP
AND A FORMER SECURITY GOVERNMENT
GOVERNANCE PROCESS TO PROTECT
ENTERPRISE IT ASSETS. IT PROVES
OUR SECURITY POSTURE BY
DETECTING IDENTIFYING AND
RESPONDING TO CYBER SECURITY
ATTACKS USING THE LATEST. AND
BEST PRACTICES RECOMMENDED BY
STATE AND FEDERAL SECURITY
MANDATES. ENHANCE THE CPC'S
CLASSIC. BY ARCHITECTING AND
DEVELOPING SECURITY
ORCHESTRATION AND AUTOMATION
CAPABILITIES IMPLEMENTING
INDUSTRY SECURITY BEST PRACTICE
. IMPROVES THE PC'S DATA
SECURITY BY COMPLETING A FULL
INVENTORY AND CLASSIFICATION OF
ALL DATA. HERE LIES BY THE CQC.
IT ALSO CROSS TRAINED STAFF TO
ELIMINATE SINGLE POINTS OF
FAILURE IN THE CQC'S SECURITY
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES AND CREATE
AND IMPLEMENT SUCCESSION PLANS
TO ENSURE THE CONTINUITY OF ALL
CRITICAL I TEACH SECURITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FUNCTIONS. I
WOULD BECAUSE THERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A VERY
IDENTICAL TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WORLD PROPOSAL- THAT WAS
WITHDRAWN WHEN THE BUT WHEN
PANDEMIC OF LIKE IF YOU HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL INCREASE FOR THE- OF
POSITION MR BROWN COMMENT. OKAY
SERVICE. IT'S PRETTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CHIEF OF REFLECTION
OFFICER GOMEZ- I HAVE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS BASED ON THE
CLARIFICATION WE WILL HOLD THE-
OUR ISSUE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT. WHICH IS THE
PHYSICAL AND CYBER SECURITY
SECTION ANOTHER REDO OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET THAT
WAS WITHDRAWN FOR BECAUSE OF THE
- PANDEMIC. IN IN SHERMAN
STICKER SENATORS I'M DOCTOR DAN
BOUT I. SERVERS THE DIRECTOR THE
SIXTY POLICY DIVISION AT THE
COMMISSION IT'LL BE INTERESTING
TO PHYSICAL AND CYBER SECURITY
REQUEST. THE COMMISSION IS
REQUESTING THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO AUGMENT OUR
EXISTING STAFF. TASKED WITH
COLLABORATING WITH OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
THREATS TO CALIFORNIA'S CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE POSITION TO
ALLOW FOR MORE PROACTIVE
OVERSIGHT AND INCREASED ABILITY
TO EVALUATE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY COSTS RELATED TO CYBER
SECURITY. I DON'T HAVE THE
COORDINATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER. THE DEPARTMENT OF JEEZ
OFFICE OF CYBERSECURITY ENERGY
SECURITY EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
OTHER KEY AGENCIES THE IMPACT
CYBERSECURITY. THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE PHYSICAL AND CYBER
SECURITY BRANCH IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE RESTORE
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PARTNERS
THAT ARE ADDRESSING ASPECTS OF
THIS RISK LANDSCAPE HAVE
EXPANDED. THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL COORDINATION HENCE
THE REQUEST FOR THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING. THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. MR BROWN
COMMON. NONE OF IT THERE'S NO.
RIGHT R. O. FINANCE ANYTHING TO
ADD. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR
NO NO NOTHING AT. EVEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS IRISH
I'M FINE WITH THE ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT LOCAL THE MATTER OPEN
MOVED TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
STRENGTHEN INTERNAL OPERATIONS
COURT THIS IS EIGHT EXISTING
FULL TIME BLANCA POSITIONS AND
ONE FROM FULL TIME ENTER INTO
POSITION AND ONE EXISTING FULL
TIME TEMPORARY POSITIONS TO-
PERMANENT. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
SENATORS. I'M SEAN MORALES
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES AND I'M ADDRESSING
AGENDA ITEM ISSUE NUMBER NINE A
REQUEST TITLED STRENGTHENING
INTERNAL OPERATIONS CORE. THE
CPUC IS BRINGING FORWARD THIS
REQUEST TO CONVERT TEMPORARY
STAFF INTO PERMANENT STAFF TO
BETTER POSITION OUR AGENCY
INCLUDING INTERNAL OPERATIONS
MANDATES INITIATIVES GOALS.
OVERALL REPORT BY REQUESTING TEN
POSITIONS SEVEN IN ACCOUNTING
ONE IN HUMAN RESOURCES INTO
ILLEGAL DIVISION. WE MAKE
PERMANENT TO STRENGTHEN INTERNAL
OPERATIONS AND INCLUDES SUPPORT
AND OVERSIGHT OF THE COMMISSION.
THESE POSITIONS ARE NEEDED TO
HANDLE THE WORKLOAD DRIVEN BY
THE GROWTH OF THE AGENCY. IN THE
PAST FIVE YEARS CPC HAVE SEEN
STAFF INCREASED BY 16% AND ITS
BUDGET BY SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
THIS GROWTH HAS HAD A PERMANENT
IMPACT ON THE NUMBER OF TASKS A
LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY OF THE
WORKLOAD OF CPC'S INTERNAL
OPERATIONS. ALL REQUESTED
POSITIONS COMPLETE WORK THAT
SUPPORTS THE ENTIRE COMMISSION.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS IMPORTANT TO
THE CPUC BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF THE WORKLOAD. FOR THE SEVEN
ACCOUNTING STAFF EACH POSITION
FILLS A DIFFERENT ROLE WITHIN
THE ACCOUNTING OFFICE BUT
OVERALL. MAKING THE SACRAMENT
ALLOWS THE C. P. C. TO AVOID
DELAYS MY CAN OF OVERSIGHT THREE
MAIN AREAS. AND PROCESSING
EMPLOYEE TRAVEL CLAIMS IN VENDOR
INVOICES. AND PROCESSING DAILY
DEPOSITS AND REVENUE RECOGNITION
AND ON THE ACCURACY AND
TIMELINESS OF STATE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS TO FEDERAL GRANT
REPORTING. FOR THE HUMAN
RESOURCES SEE A POSITION. YES
THE CREATION OF THIS POSITION
WAS APPROVED BY CALLIE CHART IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO SERVE AS
HUMAN RESOURCES DIRECTOR FOR AN
AGENCY OF OUR SIZE THIS POSITION
IS CRITICAL TO THE PROPER
FUNCTIONING OF OUR HUMAN%
RESOURCES ACTIVITIES AND
REQUIRES EXTENSIVE MANAGERIAL
AND PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION
EXPERIENCE. FOR THE CONTRACT
ADMINISTRATION OF TURNING THE
CPUC MANAGES CONTRACTING IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND ALSO HAS
A ROLE IN MANAGING UTILITY
DIRECTED CONTRACTS. THIS
POSITION PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
LEGAL SUPPORT TO OUR REGULAR
CONTRACTING STAFF ON MORE
COMPLEX CONTRACTING ISSUES. AND
LASTLY FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
COUNSEL POSITION THE PUC ADDED
THIS POSITION WHEN IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THE ONE EXISTING IN
HOUSE COUNSEL. COULD NOT HANDLE
THE INCREASE IN WORKLOAD AS THE
NUMBER OF STAFF INCREASED HERE
THE C. P. C. SUMMARY MAKING
THESE TEN POSITIONS FROM THAT
WILL STRENGTHEN THE CPSC'S
INTERNAL OPERATIONS AND IMPROVE.
SUPPORT OVERSIGHT AND REPORTING.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY I KNOW THEY HAD
SOME WE GAVE SOME POSITIONS IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HOW DID THE DESIST
REQUEST CONNECT WITH THOSE I
KNOW YOU SAID THERE'S DIFFERENT
ROLES- IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
KNOW THAT THAT POSITIONS ARE NOT
THE SAME POSITIONS THE POSITIONS
THAT WERE REQUESTED IN PREVIOUS
BCPS. WERE FOR SPECIFIC ITEMS
OKAY BUT I CAN RESEARCH THIS BUT
THEY WERE FOR REQUESTED FOR
SPECIFIC WORKLOAD INCREASES THIS
THESE ONES ARE MORE GENERAL
RECORD. PATCHAM BASED ON SCIENCE
BUT WE'RE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND- I. T. E. O. N. OKAY
. FIVE MISS BROWN YOU'RE OKAY.
CONCERNS OKAY WE'LL HOLD MATTER
OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION LET'S MOVE THE
ISSUE TEN THIS IS TRANSPORTATION
LICENSING AND ENFORCEMENT BRANCH
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
DISTINGUISHED SENATORS. MY NAME
IS JACKIE TELL I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION. CAN
PROVIDE A SUMMARY OF A GENDER
ISSUE NUMBER TEN CQC'S
TRANSPORTATION LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH. I'LL REQUEST
TODAY IS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ABILITY TO MEET THE CHANGES AND
CHALLENGES FACING TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY. AND TO ENSURE SAFE AND
RELIABLE RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION
FOR CONSUMERS. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY COMPONENTS IN OUR
REQUEST WHICH CONSIST OF A TOTAL
OF NINE POSITION PLUS FUNDING
FOR CONTRACTS. SIX SESSIONS WILL
SUPPORT OUR TRANSPORTATION
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
UNITS. AND INCLUDES ONE ATTORNEY
TO PROVIDE LEGAL SUPPORT FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. THE
PASSENGER TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC AND AS
TRAVEL DEMAND RETURNS WE ARE
ADJUSTING OUR ENFORCEMENT
PRIORITIES TO MEET THE CHANGES
OCCURRING ACROSS THE INDUSTRY.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THESE
POSITIONS WILL ENHANCE OUR
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST AGAINST AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
TRANSPORTATION CARRIERS. AND
SUPPORT OUR ON THE GROUND
OPERATIONS. THE RESOURCES IN
THIS REQUEST WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT TOOLS
THAT WILL ALSO INCREASE OUR
EFFECTIVENESS AND SHE'LL. THE
REMAINING THREE POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REGULATIONS THAT
ADDRESS NEW AND EMERGING ISSUE.
THESE INCLUDE THE EXPANSION IN
THE RANGE AND TYPE OF INNOVATIVE
PASSENGER SERVICE IS BY
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES. THE GROWING ROLE OF
ECONOMISTS VEHICLES PASSENGER
TRANSPORTATION. AND THE
PROVISION OF ON DEMAND
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE SERVICE.
THE POSITIONS WILL ALSO IMPROVE
OUR DATA ANALYTICS CAPABILITIES
AS THE VOLUME AND COMPLEXITY OF
TRANSPORTATION RELATED DATA
CONTINUES TO GROW. IN TOTAL
REACT WE ARE REQUESTING NINE
POSITIONS AND RESOURCES FOR
CONTRACTS EQUIPMENT. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY SUMMARY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU I KNOW OUR STAFF REPORT SAID
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE YOU'RE
REQUESTING FOURTEEN POSITIONS SO
I GUESS HE FISSION SEES PREVAIL
AT THE- DEPARTMENT AS I'M SURE
IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH JUST
THE- SHRINKING OF THE- AMOUNT OF
CARRIERS AND PEOPLE USING
SERVICES PRESS. MR BROWN ANY
OBSERVATIONS YOU'D LIKE TO BE
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION. MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY WE'LL HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN TO MOVE TO THE
UTILITY AUDIT REQUIREMENTS WHICH
IS ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN AND OUR
FINAL MATTER ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND WE HAVE DIRECTOR WILLIAMS.
S. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME WAS I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF UTILITY OUGHT
RISK AND COMPLIANCE DIVISION AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE CPSC IS PROPOSING
TO MODIFY THE AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
FOR REGULATED UTILITY COMPANIES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THE
COMMISSION'S REGULATORY
JURISDICTION SPECIFICALLY THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS A MAN'S
BELIEVE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
SECTIONS THREE ONE FOUR POINT
FIVE SEVEN NINE TWO POINT FIVE
AND TWO SEVEN FOUR THERE IS NO
BUDGETARY REQUEST AT THIS TIME.
THESE CHANGES WOULD CLARIFY AND
UPDATE SPECIFIC TYPES OF
REGULATED UTILITY COMPANIES
SUBJECT TO AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
REMOVE THE PREDETERMINED ON HIS
SCHEDULE BASED SOLELY ON THE
SIZE OF A REGULATED UTILITY
COMPANY. INTRODUCED A RISK BASED
METHODOLOGY TO ALLOW FOR AN
EFFICIENT METHOD MESSED UP
DOLLAR CALL AND COMPREHENSIVE
OVERSIGHT AUDIT EFFORT AND
BETTER LIVES CQC'S EXISTING
RESOURCES. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I'M SURE THERE'S
ACCOUNTANTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT ARE. ARCHER WARM THAT WE'RE
MOVING TO A WRIST BASIS RATHER
THAN AN AUTOMATIC AUDIT EVERY
THREE YEARS SO IT'SA NICE FINAL
ISSUE MR. THE END ON MR BROWN
ANYTHING FROM THE OLEO. NOTHING
THAT MISTER CHAIR. THANK THANK
GOD THE ACCOUNTANTS ARE HAPPY
EITHER WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
MATTER OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE
LANGUAGE FOR THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL WE'LL DEAL WITH THAT AND
NOW I NEED TO GO TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PC
WE WILL- I'M HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE AND ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO- TESTIFY PLEASE COME
FORWARD I SHOULD SEE SOME BUT
HERE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
TERMITE CASKEY ARE THEY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JUSTIN WILSON ON
BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT- IS YOU
KNOW CHARGE POINT AS I CAMPBELL
BASED CALIFORNIA COMPANY THAT'S
BEEN A LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
EQUIPMENT AND NETWORKED
SERVICES. CHARGE POINT SUPPORT
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IN PARTICULAR THE FOCUS
ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INVESTMENTS IN DISADVANTAGED AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THOSE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES AT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS THIS COMMITTEE
CONSIDERS THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE BUDGET WE
RECOMMEND THE COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED HERE ALSO CONSIDER THE
FEDERAL FORMULA FUNDS AND
COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT ARE PART
OF THE- TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY
PARSE BY PARSE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE. WE ALSO BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
BE AWARE OF STATE INITIATIVE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE WHICH
ACCORDING TO ITS PROPONENTS WILL
SUPPORT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PROGRAMS AND BOUGHT FIVE RELATED
ACTIVITIES FOR PORK CHOPS POINT
BELIEVES THAT THE RIGHT
THOUGHTFUL AND COLLABORATIVE
ABOUT YOUR PROCESS AS WELL AS
TOP OF PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT AT
THE CDC CALIFORNIA CAN USE THESE
EQUITABLE MANNER TO ENSURE THAT
NO CALIFORNIA. IS LEFT BEHIND IN
THE STATES TRANSITION. TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WANTED TESTIFY HERE- AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANTS.
OUR NUMBER IS 844-291-6364 AND
THE ASSET ACCESS CODE IS THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY ONE TWO EIGHT THREE-
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS- WE'LL SEE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON THE LINE
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG. MORNING
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE TO
YOUR LINE NUMBER. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE SEE HOW MANY ARE
QUEUING UP. LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE TWENTY SIX IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME AND THAT NUMBER MAY
GROW A LITTLE BIT HIGHER. AND
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE TWENTY. ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND MORE THAN 75% OF THE
OCCUPATION. BY P. C. C. ISSUED
YET ANOTHER DIRE WARNING ABOUT
THE CLIMATE CRISIS EARLIER THIS
WEEK AND THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO LIVE IN
AREAS THAT ARE OUT OF ATTAINMENT
WITH FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. THE LEGISLATURE MUST
ACT DECISIVELY TO REPLACE FOSSIL
FUEL POWERED VEHICLES WITH ZERO
EMISSION CARS AND TRACKS.
CENTRAL CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. WE CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD HALF MEASURES LIKE
SO CALLED NEAR ZERO VEHICLES. DO
YOU SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET BUT WE ARE
WORRIED THAT TOO MANY OF THE
INVESTMENTS ARE PROMISED OVER
THE NEXT DECADE RATHER THAN
GUARANTEED IN THE COMING YEAR.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD FRONT
LOAD MORE NEED INVESTMENTS AND
THIS COMING BUDGET YEAR WHEN WE
NOW THE STATE HAS SURPRISED BY
THE BAILABLE. I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A COLD ON THE ROAD
TODAY ALSO DELIVERS CLEAN AIR
AND MEDIA RIGHT AND IT BENEFITS.
WILL CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE
LIFETIME OF THE VEHICLE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. TO
DELIVER A 1100% YEAR MISSION
FUTURE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
VINCENT FOR A LARGE- WITH
COVERAGE AND YOU'RE SPEAKING ON
AN ITEM THAT'S NOT ON THE AGENDA
BUT RELATED TO ENERGY RESIGNS.
WITH PUBLICATION OF THE REPORT
THAT GERAKAN JEFF CITED YEAH HE
HE HE IN FACT WE NOTED THAT THE
CHANGES WROUGHT BY GLOBAL
WARMING COULD SOON OVERWHELM. IN
ONE OF THE PRIMARY THREATS SUCH
INCREASING DRYNESS AND HEAT RISE
. EVENTS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THE THREAT TO OUR STABLE CREDIT.
REPORT ONCE AGAIN HIGHLIGHTS THE
NEED FOR THE STATE TO MAKE
STRONG INVESTMENTS INTO
RESILIENCE MEASURES ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCE THROUGH THE
USE OF QUEEN STREET ENERGY
RESOURCES. WHILE WE WERE PLEASED
TO SEE SUCH A STRONG FOCUS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
CLIMATE WE WERE DISAPPOINTED
THAT NO SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS
WERE MADE AND- LOCAL ENERGY.
IMAGE TECHNOLOGY TO MEASURES.
THAT ARE SPONSORED BILL SB EIGHT
THREE THREE MUCH YOUNGER DOG
MOVED TO ADDRESS THIS GAP BY
SETTING UP A PROGRAM THE ENERGY
COMMISSIONS OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN THE CREATION OF LOCAL
COMMUNITY AS YOU RESIGNED CLANS.
TO THAT END WE URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
BY ALLOCATING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL ON
SPREAD OVER MORE YEARS SHE TOOK
ON THE CREATION OF LOCALLY.
DRIVEN COMMUNITY ENERGY RESIGNS
. ADDITIONALLY RECOMMEND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. ON GEOLOGY OVER
SO YEARS. ON BEHIND ME SINGLE
COURSE. PRODUCTS CRITICAL.
ALIGNED WITH THE PLANNED CREATED
ENOUGH. RIGHT FINALLY WE URGE
THE STATE TO INVEST ADDITIONAL
BILLION OVER TWO YEARS FOR THE
NEW STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
COMMUNITY RESENTED PUBS PROGRAM
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET ALL THESE INVESTMENTS
SHOULD PRIORITIZE FUNDING
PROJECT MOBILE COMMUNITIES THAT
EXPERIENCE. AVERAGES THE
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP THE CITY
BOTH AT CLIMATE. ARE DRIVING
DOWN EMISSIONS MANAGES. WELL
HELPING COMMUNITIES ADAPT TO
HARSH NEW REALITIES THAT ARE
BEARING DOWN ON CLIMATE CHANGE-
I ALSO NOTE THAT. THE ENERGY.
OTHERS THAT YOU CAN QUICKLY ROLE
IN THIS INTERVIEW RESULTS. AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
NEXT. ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION ONE STARTED BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED CATEGORIES OF
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING BEING
ADMINISTRATION'S MULTI YEARS OUR
MISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE. THAT
INCLUDES THE LEGISLATURE TO GO
FURTHER TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR
YOUR MISSION TRANSIT BUSES
EMERGENCY EMERGING OPPORTUNITIES
AND RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE I
WANT TO CALL FOR CONTACT BETWEEN
THE AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED BY A.
R. B. REGULATION TO TRANSITION
TO POLICE EMISSION BUS FLEET BY
TWENTY FORTY. AND THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND ULTIMATELY
AVOID AGENCY LEVEL TRADE OFF
I'VE SEEN OUR SPEECH RAILING
VERY AGENCIES WALL THE SUBJECT
IS YOUR MISSION TRANSITIONAL
APARTMENT UNDER A ARBY'S
REGULATION. THAT WILL CREATE NEW
COST IMPACTS FOR THEM AS WELL IN
RELATED TO ELLIE IS
RECOMMENDATION OF WANTING
KNOWLEDGE THAT- A. R. B.
REGULATION TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A-
TRANSITION PLAN THAT DETAILED
THEIR PLANS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT. TO REACH FULLY ZERO
EMISSION BUS FLEET WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS JUSTIFIED MAINTAINING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR
TRANSIT AND IF THEY CLOSE MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
OUR BUDGET LETTER I AND ARE
SPONSORED BILLS ARE DIRECTED AT
INCREASING TRANSIT RIDERSHIP.
WELL WE GREENER FLEET WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH YOU
PERSONALLY AND DIRECTLY TO TALK
THROUGH SOME. OF THE STRATEGIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT. WINDS FIVE YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK MY NAME
IS LI MING I INTO. MY HUSBAND
AND I HAVE TO TALKED LAURA AND
WE'RE NOT RICH MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE BOTH RETIRED AND ON LIMITED
INCOMES WE'RE SHOCKED THAT YOU
SPREAD TO PG&E SLIDE. NINETY ONE
FELONY CHARGES DO YOU- DO TRUTH
CAUSING WILDFIRES AND IN OUR
STATE WE HAVE NO CREDIBILITY
JUST UNDER HALF OF ALL NEW
SETTLERS IS GOING INTO WORKING
AND MIDDLE CLASS HOUSEHOLDS AND
THAT'S A TREND THAT IS GETTING
BIGGER EVERY YEAR. A NEW STUDY
BY. LET REPORT. ON YOUR DOCTOR'S
INCOME AND DIDN'T TRENDS 39% OR
THAN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUAL INCOME 63% OR LESS THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS INCOME ABOUT THE SAME.
IT SAYS ARE LESS THAN FIFTY K.
AS ARE FAR GREATER THAN TWENTY-
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR. 80%
OR THAN. 20% OF THE AREA INCOME
A THRESHOLD SOMETIMES USED TO
DEFINE LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS CALGARY PC HAS BEEN
CAPTURED BY THE BRUTALITIES AND
THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING FOR US NOT THE UTILITIES
DID YOU KNOW THAT THE COMPUTER
CONSULTANT IS ALSO A VENDOR FOR
THE UTILITIES WHY IN THE WORLD
WOULD USE TRUST ANYTHING THEY
SAY. HOLD YOUR YOU SLANDER THE
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
A WAY OUT OF CRAZY ENERGY BILLS
THAT YOU. POLITICIANS DO NOTHING
ABOUT. DON'T USERS OUR OF THE-
WE PAY MINIMUM BILL IN THE- ALSO
. MONEY FOR MARSHALL CREDIT TO
PAY THE WIRES. WHY NOT USING
THOSE LONG DISTANCE FROM OUR
LINES WE ARE REDUCING THE COSTS
OF THE GREAT FOR EVERYONE. THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO STOP BEING
A SHOULDER TO PG&E AND STAND UP
FOR EVERYDAY PEOPLE LIKE ME. THE
CALIFORNIA YOU STEP NUMBER THREE
PROPOS. NEEDS TO INCLUDE YOU
DON'T FOLLOW NO SOLAR TAX NOT
ONE SINGLE SENT. IT ALL NEEDS TO
INCLUDE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
SOLAR BECAUSE IT'S MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR WORKING AND
MIDDLE CLASS HOUSEHOLDS NOT
BLACK. IT IS UNDER THE EXISTING
TWENTY YEAR PROTECTION FOR SOLAR
USERS. IS WHAT THE PUBLIC
OVERWHELMINGLY WANT OVER A
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE TOLD YOU IN THE
GOVERNORS THAT THE BOX A BOLD
WAY IMAGINABLE INCLUDING AT
LEAST THE CALIFORNIA PC MEETING
WHERE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WAITED
UP TO SEVEN HOURS TO SPEAK TO
YOU. LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT
YOUR JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ZACKS. NINE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK HER NUMBER TO GET
A CRAPPY BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL- A FEW
ITEMS THAT WE GET WITH EACH OF
THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
BILLION PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR EQUITABLE
BUILDING P. CARD PROGRAM AND- HE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE FUNDING
TARGETED TOWARDS LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE EFFICIENT
ALL ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP FOR
COOLING. ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
BUILDING INSULATION AND FEELING
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON DEFINING
PROGRAM THAT WILL PREVENT ITS
PLACEMENT AND RENT INCREASES
ALLOW FOR HABITABILITY.
IMPROVEMENTS IN OTHER HEALTH
RELATED. TO COMPLEMENT OF
INVESTMENT. WHAT ARE FUNDING FOR
LINEBACKER ARE LOOK AT YOUR THAT
AND INVESTING IN BILL DOLLARS TO
CONSTRUCT OF AN UPGRADE TO
COMMUNITY CENTER THAT STRATEGIC
ACCOUNT SRI LANKA THE PURPOSE
FUNDING FOR THE INDUSTRIAL CARD
PROGRAM IT DOES LOOK AFTER THE
MAJOR SOURCE MENTIONED THAT AIR
POLLUTION BUT AS THE YEARS
BEHIND OTHER SECTORS WILL BE
COVERED I THINK BE THE BEST
NUMBER NEEDED TO PILOT ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY WILL SUPPORT WORKING
HOT SHOT. RECRUITING MUST BE
CONDITIONED ON ENSURING PROJECTS
DELIVER COMMUNITY BENEFITS THAT
ALIGN OUR CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN ENERGY IF
YOU SUPPORT FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
OPPORTUNITY COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP THE HYDROGEN MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE YOU TO
RETAIN A FOCUS ON ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN MADE WITH CLEAN
ELECTRICITY. AND APPLY THEIR
TECHNOLOGY WHICH HAS THE MOST
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE A SCALABLE
CLEAN ENERGY POLLUTION AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION WE ARE PARTNERS
LITERATURE HAD COALITION
STRONGLY URGE DECISION MAKERS TO
PRIORITIZE INVESTING IN CLEAN
AIR AND THE BUDGET INCLUDING
RECORDING FOR YOUR MISSION
TRUCKS AND BUSES BETWEEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND
OTHERS YOUR MISSION TRACKING
SUPPORT AT LEAST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
INCLUDING GREEN CARDS FOR ALL
AND OTHER CRITICAL DATA BOTH.
COMMUNITY BASED TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS AND FINALLY AS
YOU KNOW AGENCIES ARE AMONG THE
MOST POWERFUL AND FASTEST
GROWING SOURCE OF THE CLIMATE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD
SURE YOU CAN BE THOUSANDS OF
TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN CO TWO
THE DAMAGE QUICKLY AND EVEN.
OUTSIDE IMPACT ON OUR CLIMATE.
INCREASED FUNDING EACH OF ABOUT
. BUT FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANKS NINE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO ANY KIND
ON. ITEM FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR SEVERE ENERGY IN
STRONG OF OUR MISSION PACKAGE. I
THINK THE BIG START- TO A
AFFORDABLE BUT NOT ENOUGH. AND
ON BEHALF OF STORE THE PERFECT
TO THE- CLEAN ENERGY AND- CALL
FOR CALM DIRECTION YOU STORE.
WHAT QUITE A AT THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS CALL FOR IN
THE GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET- HOWEVER
WE DO THAT COMMENT NEEDS. NEED
TO ENSURE THAT PROJECT THAT
PROVIDE QUICK BENEFITS ANOTHER
FIRST THEIR KIND BUT BEYOND THE
TRADITIONAL. PILOTS I DON'T ARE
NOT ONLY I WOULD YOU BOOK OR
TIMES BUT- AND FUNDING.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD URGE THE-
MEMBERS. TO ENSURE THAT GOING
AND AWARDS ARE ENOUGH HELP BOTH
CAR GET ACROSS THE FINISH. DON'T
NEEDED AND- ON INTER WITH NO AND
PROVIDE WITHOUT EACH LOCATIONS
AROUND OUR STATE. I'M THE NET
ALLIANCE THE COURT I'LL HAVE. WE
CAN BUY THE COFFEE COMMISSION.
WE CAN START WITH. ONE PILOT
CLIENT. WILL NOT. THE NEEDED
ABOVE THE YOUNG INCLUDING
INTEGRATION THAT ARE REQUIRE TO
MEET OUR TWENTY THIRTY GOALS.
URGED LEGISLATURE IN INDUSTRY TO
THANK A LOT WELCOME. AND THE
COURTS. COULD YOU SPELL THANK
YOU NEXT. NINE EIGHT SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FOR GO AHEAD. AFTER
HE GOT A MEDAL ON OF VALLEY AIR
NOW DELHI CLEANER NOW IS THE
FIVE WE REDUCE ERA THAN CAL BUT
BY VALLEY REGIONAL WORK AIR
QUALITY IN THE UNITED STATES WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE ESPECIALLY THE QUEEN
CALLS FOR ALL PROGRAM. YOU'RE
NOW HAS DONE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
THOUSAND VEHICLE REPLACEMENT AND
HAVE APPROXIMATELY THREE MORE
THOUSAND. THREE THOUSAND MORE
CUSTOMERS IN THEIR PIPELINE WE
ARE YOU DRUNK THE POOR OF
CONTINUED FUNDING IN ORDER TO
COURT THIS RECORD NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS THANK YOU. THANKS.
NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT
A SUNDAY AFTER CAL START IN
STRONG SUPPORT IN THE EURO
MISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. TAKING A
RETHINK THESE TYPES AND LEVELS
OF INVESTMENT ALLOW CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE TO BE A QUIET LEADER
. IT WILL ALLOW MARKET CERTAINTY
WHICH YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
TODAY. FIGURE IT WILL ALLOW THE
STATE AND THE INDUSTRIES TO
SCALE UP AND REDUCE COSTS WHICH
IS IN PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE IN
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY SECTOR
. AND FINALLY WE DO AGREE WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT- THIS IS
KATIE PERFECT PACKAGING COULD
HAVE IMPROVEMENT ONE OF THOSE
IMPROVEMENT DEFINITELY COULD BE
IMPROVING AND INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE- RT RT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS.
NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER HERE
ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE ON A COUPLE
OF ITEMS. FIRST ONE ISSUE TO THE
YOUR EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE WE
DO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN THIS SECTOR I WANT
TO CALL ATTENTION TO THE
PROPOSED PORTS FUNDING AND
REALLY ASK THAT THIS FUNDING
MUST BE USED FOR ACTUALLY
ADVANCING GENERAL MISSION USES.
BUT THE PARTICULAR FOCUS ON
CARGO HANDLING EQUIPMENT
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT AND
SHIPPING. AND NOT SIMPLY FOR
EXPANDING PORTS. BUT ALSO LIKE
TO REFLECT ON WHAT WE HEARD IN
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COUPLE
WEEKS AGO THAT COMBUSTION
ENGINES. ARE NOT PART OF OUR
FUTURE AND IT'S THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD NOT ALLOCATE ANY FUNDS
FOR SO CALLED NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. AS STATED EARLIER
ABOUT YOUR CALL. SECOND ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE AGAIN WITH
ARCHBISHOP DREAM SPECIFICALLY
THE PROPOSED GREEN HYDROGEN
PROGRAM. DIRECTOR ENERGY SHE'S
COMMENTS TO FOCUSES FUNDING ON
ELECTRIC WHAT ARE YOU DOING
POWERED BY RENEWABLES. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE THE REPOSE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION PROHIBIT FUNDING.
FOR IDEAS AND PROJECTS THAT RELY
ON OFFSET YOUR STOCKS TO CALL
THEMSELVES RENEWABLE. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT PROPOSED PROJECTS
COULD INCLUDE FUNDING FOR POWER
PLANTS TO BLEND HYDROGEN WITH
NATURAL GAS. RICHARD. ENTRY
INCREASED OXIDATION. LASTLY
BEHALF GLOBAL CLEAN ENERGY IN
REGARDS TO THE CAPITAL BUILDING
. PROGRAM PUT OUT THAT MOST NEWS
AND BE LOOKED. TO ADMINISTER THE
FUND IS LOCAL. SUCH AS TEACHING
A- THANK YOU. FIFTEEN BUILT
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
PROGRAMS CAN TAILOR THE FUNDING
TO LOCAL DESIGN PROGRAMS THAT
BEST MEET LOCAL NEEDS. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
HIS BODY MONSON CALLING ON ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THE CLEAN ENERGY
PACKAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY FEDERATION AND SUPPORTED
THE PACKAGING PARTICULARLY THE
CREW PROFITS OR INVESTMENT
PROGRAM. AT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ENSURE NOTED THIS IS A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT HAD
BEEN GREATLY OVERSUBSCRIBED WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AND AS ALWAYS WE
APPRECIATE THAT SURE STOP
RECOGNITION OF THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE AND
BUDGETARY DIGESTS YOUR PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. NEXT MY NINETY YOUR
LINE IS- OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE MAX ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION ALSO NOTED AS NOT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF LEADERS THAT THE
VALUE CHAIN OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INDUSTRY TO
ADVANCE THE GOAL OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN WHICH
THE MARKET FORCES OF INNOVATION
AND COMPETITION AND CONSUMER
CHOICE. DRIVE THE EX EXPEDITIOUS
AND EFFICIENT ADOPTION OF EVEN
DEPLOYMENT EASY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT- PREVIOUS COMMENTS MADE
AND TE GOVERNOR THE ORIGINAL
VEHICLE PACKAGE THE FUNDING
LEVEL PROPOSER CRITICAL FOR THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO
HELP HER STATE MEET MEET THEIR
CLIMATE EMISSION VEHICLE AND AN
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT
PULLED. DOLLARS AND A STRONG
MARKET THAT YOU KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMITTED TO
REVOLUTIONIZING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. THANK YOU
NEXT. MY NAME ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DONNED CAP KEY
WITH MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF AIR CONDITIONING
HEATING AND REFRIGERATION
INSTITUTE TESTIFYING TODAY ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE RELATED TO
THE EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PROPOSAL AND
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
RELATED TO REFRIGERANT. H. ARISE
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED ORIGINAL EQUIPMENT
MANUFACTURER COMPANIES IN THE
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
HEATING VENTILATION AIR
CONDITIONING COMMERCIAL
REFRIGERATION EQUIPMENT MARKET.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS H. R. I.
AND ITS MEMBERS OF THAT WORKING
HAND IN HAND WITH CARB ON THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE REGULATIONS PHASING DOWN
THE USE OF HSCS AND HVAC ARE A
QUICK MEANT. INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF CARDS OUT
AND CONTINUE TO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE AGENCY TO ENSURE
MANUFACTURERS CAN COMPLY. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE REGULATIONS SIGNIFICANT
EMISSIONS REDUCTION POTENTIAL.
TO THAT END H. R. I SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATING TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF THE NEXT
GENERATION LOW GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL REFRIGERANTS. THAT
SAID IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING CODES
DO NOT CURRENTLY ALLOW FOR THE
USE OF MANY OF THESE
ALTERNATIVE. LOW GWP
REFRIGERANTS BUILDING CODES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MUST BE
UPDATED TO ENABLE THE USE OF EPA
APPROVED SUBSTITUTE REFRIGERANTS
WITHOUT THIS CRITICAL UPDATES TO
THE CODES. MANUFACTURERS WILL BE
UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH CARBS
REGULATIONS LEAVING CONSUMERS
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO INSTALL
NEW EQUIPMENT THAT UTILIZE LOW
GWP REFRIGERANTS. ADDRESSING THE
CODES ISSUE IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THE CALIFORNIANS CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO NEW
HVACR EQUIPMENT AND WE CAN ALL
BENEFIT FROM THE SIGNIFICANT
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS THAT THE
PHASE DOWN HFC ROLLOUT. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND REQUESTED SUPPORT FOR THIS
INVESTMENT AND URGED THE STATE
TO HELP ADVANCE THE CRITICALLY
NEEDED BUILDING CODES THANK YOU
THANKS FOR THE UPDATE ON THE-
BUILDING CODE SNACKS. NINE
THIRTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLAY
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS JACK SHERMAN WITH
LOCKHEED MARTIN CORPORATION ARE
WE TO I AM HERE TODAY TO WADE
INTO COURT FOR THE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LONG DURATION STORAGE INCLUDING
GOVERNOR SINCE COMPOUNDS BUDGET.
POCKET MARTIN STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE PROVISIONS RESPOND THREE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THE CDC HAD
STAFF EXPERTISE PROGRAMMATIC
EXPERIENCE BUT WHAT YOU CAN
RESPOND PLAYING QUICKLY AND COME
UPON THEM ON THE PROGRAM'S GOALS. FOR LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE. LONG DURATION SOLUTION
CAL. TO ACHIEVE THE DAY KERR.
CLIMATE GOALS WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING THE GRAND
RELIABILITY. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION INDICATE
THAT ONE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
LONG DURATION STORAGE WILL BE
NEEDED BY TWENTY THIRTY JOIN
AGENCIES SP ONE HUNDRED
INDICATES FOUR THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS NEEDED BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SANDERS MY NAME IS KRISH OTHERS
I'M THE DEPUTY POLICY DIRECTOR
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR MY
COMMENTS ARE AN ISSUE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
ALONG WITH THE CHARGE AHEAD
CALIFORNIA AND INVEST IN CLEAN
AIR CAMPAIGNS WANT TO AGAIN
THANK THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PROPOSAL AS A REALLY SEVERE
EMISSION VEHICLES. ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCES ONE MILLION
ELECTRIC VEHICLE BEING PLACED ON
THE ROAD WHILE THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE MOMENT WE CAN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THE
BARRIERS TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
ARE HIGHEST FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I LIVE IN A
DIFFERENT BAND CENSUS TRACT IN
WEST LONG BEACH IT'S A FEW WEEKS
AGO I WAS EXCITED TO SEE ME EVEN
DRIVING OUT MY NEIGHBOR'S
GARAGE. YET IF I CROSS STREET
INTO A WEALTHIER NEIGHBORHOOD
THE DIFFERENCE IS DATE NIGHT.
THERE ARE SO MANY MORE EVEN THE
WEALTHIER NEIGHBORHOOD THAT MY
OWN. WE NEED CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE THOSE BARRIERS FOR
DISADVANTAGE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO NEED TO
MAXIMIZE THE AIR QUALITY CO
BENEFITS IN ADDITION TO
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING MYSELF. LUMINARIES
THAT FAILED TO MEET NATIONAL AND
STATE AIR QUALITY STANDARDS. IN
OTHER WORDS ARE ERIC SO DIRTY
IT'S ILLEGAL. UNDERSCORES THE
NEED TO INVEST IN CLEAN MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. THE
PARTICULAR MATTER WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF OVER FORTY
DIFFERENT CANCER CAUSING
CHEMICALS IT'S A PREDOMINANT AIR
TOXIC CONTAMINANT IN OUR STATE.
THIS IS MAGNIFIED MEANS NEAR
GOODS MOVEMENT CORRIDORS
COMEDIANS LIKE MINE. MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES ARE ALSO
MASSIVE CONTRIBUTOR TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. TO
BUILD OFF OF LAST YEAR'S
HISTORIC NVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE GO BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INVESTS ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS.
FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION FOR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS BUT FOR
THEM OFFERED EQUIPMENT INTO
BILLION FOR THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IN ZERO
EMISSIONS CHARGING SUPPORT WE
ALSO OPPOSE CHANGING EQUITY
DRIVEN PROPOSALS- PROVISIONS IN
CARBS CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PLAN THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. WHICH ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO CENTER
EQUITY INSTRUMENTS CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY. AND WE
HOPE YOU'RE UP TO THAT CHALLENGE
THANK YOU. THANKS. NINE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE ON
BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA A BUSINESS TRADE
GROUP OF OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPERS AND TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
THE RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT
OFFSHORE WIND POWER. COMMENTING
ON THE CLEAN ENERGY PACKAGE
ALTHOUGH THE C. SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DEDICATE
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR FACILITY
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES AT THE PORTS THAT
WOULD HELP SPUR OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY IN FEDERAL WATERS OFF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST. THIS IS IN
LINE WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
NATIONWIDE THIRTY GIGAWATT
OFFSHORE WIND GOAL AND WHAT
HELPS THE STATE MEET ITS CLIMATE
GOALS BY PROVIDING A RELIABLE
SOURCE OF CLEAN ENERGY AND
WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES AS NOTED
IN THE SB ONE HUNDRED. AGENCY WE
ALSO COMMEND THE CC ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE BEGINNING
IMPLEMENTATION OF LAST YEAR'S
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
REQUIRING THE STATE TO DEVELOP A
PLAN GO FASTER WHEN AND ALSO
FACILITATING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
PORTS AND SUPPLY CHAIN HOWEVER
TO FULLY RECOGNIZE THE GOALS OF
THE BILL AND THE BENEFITS OF
EMERGING FLOATING OFFSHORE WIND
TECHNOLOGY- WE STRONGLY SUGGEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE FORTY FIVE MILLION I
SUGGESTED MCGOVERN BUDGET AND
PROVIDE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
MILLION WHICH WILL HELP ME OTHER
STATES TWENTY THIRTY AND TWENTY
FORTY FIVE GOALS WE ALSO JUST
EXPEDITING VISIT FEASIBILITY
STUDIES THAT ARE NEEDED TO HELP
KICKSTART A MULTI PORT STRATEGY
WHICH WOULD HELP COMPLIMENT THE
LEADERSHIP ACTIVELY ALREADY
HAPPENING IN THE NORTH CALLS AT
HOME BOOK COUNTY. IN THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE THE STATE WILL
NEED TO IDENTIFY ANOTHER PORT OR
PORTS THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE LARGE
SCALE OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS IN THE CENTRAL COAST OF
MORAL BAY WHERE AT LEAST THREE
GIGAWATTS OR MORE OF OFFSHORE
WIND CAN BE DEVELOPED BY TWENTY
THIRTY THIS WILL BE ENOUGH
COMBINED TO SUPPLY POWER. FOR
ONE POINT SIX MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS. FINALLY I MISSED
HERE YEAH WELL NEED TO RECOGNIZE
WE HAVE TO HAVE NO REGRETS
STRATEGY. SO ANY TYPE NO REGRETS
AND- TO ENSURE THERE IS
SUFFICIENT- PORT CAPACITY. THERE
WILL BE A NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THESE BANKS PASSING NAVIGATION
ACCESS. AND MINIMUM DESIGN LOADS
AND SO THIS FUNDING. A MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE THAT IN
ADDITION TO LEVERAGING THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. WE PROVIDE A
MORE DETAILED COMMENTS IN A
LETTER. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATION. TO ENSURE THAT
THESE ARE POOR INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES ARE NEEDED. AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEAR TERM AND
LONG TERM GOALS OF MEETING THE
KIND OF CHANGE IN LIABILITY
ISSUES ARE APPARENT IN OUR QUEST
TO MEET. STATE CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
. NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS BEN
GRANDY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA THE WIDE
ADVOCACY GROUP THAT FIGHTS FOR
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER AND OPEN
SPACES CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION THE CHARGE
AHEAD CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE
ESTABLISHED BY SB TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE. HE DID STATE POLICY TO
ELECTRIFY THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IN A MANNER THAT ENSURES
ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION REALIZE
THE BENEFITS THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CAN PROVIDE LARGELY AS A
RESULT OF THAT LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA HAS A RICH PORTFOLIO
OF WELL UTILIZED EQUITY FOCUSED
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO THEIR MACHINE VEHICLE.
AND MOBILITY AND DISADVANTAGE IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ALL THESE
EFFORTS REQUIRE CHARGING AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE A REPORT
BY THE CDC FOUND THAT THE STATE
WILL MEET OVER ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PUBLIC AND SHARE PRIVATE
CHARTERS IN PINES THAT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT IS
SLOWING VEHICLE SALES. GOOD GAP
OF SLOWING PROGRESS TOWARD THE
STATE. TO HELP PUBLIC. IT'S GOT
THIS PHONE CALL TOWARD ST PAUL
HEALTH. AND GOAL. IN MY LITTLE
PROJECT BUDGET. WE URGE YOU TO
EXPAND UPON YOUR CAR COMMITMENT
FOR THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. CALIFORNIA'S THAT PACKAGE
AND TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TRULY INVEST IN CLEAN AIR.
CALIFORNIA'S INVEST ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION PER TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS LIKE CLEAN COST
ALL IN SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
BASED TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
BUT USUALLY CALCULATION BUT FOUR
POINT EIGHT BILLION PER YEAR
OMISSION TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT IN TWO BILLION
FOR THE CLEANING TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. ON BEHALF OF THE CDC'S
CLINTON'S PROTECTION PROGRAM
BUDGET SHOULD BE USED TO SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
FOR THE PRIMARY BENEFIT OR
PRIMARILY SERVING RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGE OR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY. BUT THE SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET SURPLUS FORECAST FOR THIS
YEAR CALIFORNIA HAVE A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY FUND THESE
PROGRAMS AT A LEVEL. WITH THEIR
DEMAND WHILE GUARANTEEING AND
BUILDING ON TOP OF THE FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS CONTEMPLATED
BUT NOT YET APPROPRIATED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S JUST FOR YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
THAT PACKAGE. AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FUNDING PLAN FOR THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION INITIATIVE.
MADE PROGRAM CHANGES THE COCA
COLA TRUCK INCENTIVES ON THOSE
WHO MOST NEED THEM THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD RESIST
EFFORTS TO ROLL BACK THESE
IMPROVEMENTS. CAN KEEP HAPPENING
BY MY CALIFORNIA AFTER
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING THAT PROGRAM BUT ARE
CLEARLY UNDERFUNDED. THANK YOU
AND- WE UNDERSTAND I HAVE TO GET
OUT OF THIS SO THIS ROOM IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES AND WE HAVE.
SIXTEEN PEOPLE ON THE LINE SO I
WOULD ASK PEOPLE TO. LIMIT
THEMSELVES TO ONE MINUTE SORRY
FOR THE- THE TIME LIMIT. NECKS
PRESENTER. BLINDS EIGHT. YOUR
LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU YES WAS THE DISTRICT GOOD AN
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THAT BUILDING
. PACKAGE WHILE HE'S THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING IS GOING
TO DIRECT INSTALL PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN BAC'S BENEFIT WE
NEED INVESTMENT IN CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE OUTREACH EFFORT
FOLLOWING THE EXPERTISE THE
COMMUNITY BASED ART. WE ALSO
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO DO
NOT OWN ESSENTIAL APPLIANCES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR EFFICIENT
APPLIANCES ESPECIALLY TRICKLING
WE HOPE TO COLLABORATE AND
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT
RENTERS ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN ARCHITECTURE. WE ALSO NEEDED
THAT STRATEGY THAT REDUCES GHG
AND CO POLLUTANT THEY ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE DO YOU THINK
YOU CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE
SACRIFICED THOUSANDS AND INSTEAD
YOU GET THE DIRECT BENEFITS FROM
BOTH G. H. T. AND AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTION POLICY. WE ALL DID
WHAT NEEDED BE PRIORITIZING
BACKTRACKING. ON THREE CORRIDORS
IN INDIA EIGHT. AND WHILE NOT
GAS AND- WHAT KIND OF. ON GREEN
. TO THE THAT THE STATE AND-
HIGHER AND LET THE GREEN HIGH.
PER THAT USE THE CO. GOALS ARE
LET PRODUCED BY GARY DOT AFTER.
ON UTILITY THAT NEED HELP CAN TO
FEEL THE ECONOMIC BURDEN TOLD ME
THAT AT THE ROOT OF COLD BECAUSE
JUBILEE DOLLARS UTILITY THAT
LEAD. EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY TO
THIRD THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU NECK. NINE
NINETY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO OUT
. HELLO GOOD UP MY NAME IS RICK
THE ISLAMIC COMMUNITY BECAUSE BY
ANY. AND EACH WILL BE DOWN IN.
COUNTY THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE IT'S
NOT TRANSFER AND USE OF THE
VEHICLE FAMILY VEHICLE IS UNDER
. RHETORICAL WE SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENTS REGARDING THE-
EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE WHAT WE
SEEK SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. IN THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY DESIGNED TO ENSURE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES CAN
AFFORD ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS AND ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WHICH REMAIN AFFORDABLE TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
IMPERIAL COUNTY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MIKE ROBESON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE THE MEANEST
PULL YOU TOTALLY DISSOCIATION-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE ISSUE
THREE RELATING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS- WORKS- THE COMMENTS
BY THE LA- THAT GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS AS OPPOSED TO REPAIR
FUNCHESS DOES MORE APPROPRIATE.
METHOD TO ENSURE. ELECTRICITY
RATES AND BROADER ADOPTION OF
OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS IN WE
WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE. TO
ENSURE THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BUILDING ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION FUNDING. PACKAGE
WOULD ALSO HAVE A SIMILAR
COMMENT WITH ISSUE TWO ONE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND SIMPLY-
AFTER THERE IS CLARITY THAT A
PUBLICATION SHE'S ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR GRANTS AND FUNDS FOR THEIR
FLEETS AND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE- YOUR MISSION. APARTMENT
THANKS I UNDERSTAND NEXT. NINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CLAIMING THAT I'M ABOUT
TO GET A LITTLE BIT HE WILL
COUNTER WITH THE GREEN AWNING AT
THE TUNE OF YOUR COMMENT ON THE
ISSUE TOO THAT THAT PACKAGE.
BEFORE THAT THOUGH I DO WANNA
THE COMMON YOU MAJOR ABOUT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE BEING AT THE CAT
THE CAT AND- THEN INCONSIDERATE
STATEMENT THAT THE VALUES THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO EDUCATION AND
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF POLICIES
AND ECONOMIC IMPACT THE
STATEMENT NOT BEING MENTIONED
CAN I GO ON MENTION AN ANCHOR
YOU TO REFLECT ON YOUR
STATEMENT. BUT MORE TIME
ENGAGING WITH LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSEHOLDS. I'LL
BE HAPPILY GRINNING INSTITUTE
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY SOLD BEFORE
THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS MADE BY
COLLEAGUES AT COLLISION BETWEEN. ERIN AND BARBARA CALIFORNIA.
OR TO THE POINT THAT THE
GOVERNOR THAT PACK. THANKFULLY
TO EQUITY BY PRIOR TO. FUNDING
FOR TRANSPORTATION ACT PRODUCTS
CHARGE MORE FOR SURGERY. TO
HEAVY. CALLED PROGRESS RADIC.
WILL IN HELPING REDUCE POVERTY
IMPROVE. BUT YOUR MEANINGFUL
BENEFITS LOW INCOME. YOU CAN ACT
. TO POST BEATS FILIPPO. ON
DEPLOYED MARKET. OF TRICKLE DOWN
BENEFITS. THE STATEMENT PETER
SCHIFF MUST BE INTENTIONAL IN
THEIR APPROACH AND HAD TO TALK
ABOUT EQUITABLE MAKE EQUITY REAL
BY OPERATION WRITING IT. AND
PUTTING INTO PRACTICE BY
PRIORITIZING INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE FINALIZED UNITY- THAT ARE
QUITE LIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM.
THE COMPUTER TO BUY TO BUY A
CAR- POVERTY AND POLLUTION. I
WANT TO QUICKLY ADDRESS THE
ANALYSIS AND RECOMMENDATION
PROVIDED BY THE L. I. O. WHEN
THEY MENTION THAT IT'S UNCLEAR
ON THE LAW OF THE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROGRAMS IN ACHIEVING
STATED POLICY GOALS. WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL NOT BE ANY OF OUR
GOAL- WITHOUT PROGRAMS THAT
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENT BENEFITS
OR DISADVANTAGES. COMMUNITY FINE
AFTER HE GOT THERE THAT DAY BUT
HE GOT A FEW THAT ARE COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM YET THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN FUNDED FOR OVER
TEN YEARS. AND CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED. OUR TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROGRAM FOR PROVIDING
MULTIPLE BENEFITS OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT
AND THE FACT THAT THIS IS NOT
RECOGNIZED BY MISTREATMENT
DISCONNECTING COMPLETE
DISREGARD. FOR THE LIVE
EXPERIENCE OF THEM UP ON MY
COMMUNITY. WE SHOULD NOT BE
GETTING EQUITY PROGRAMS AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND RATHER FIND
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THEM FORWARD
TO MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS AND
THEREFORE NOT CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE AND THEN OUT OF THE
PROCESS. AFTER A LONG TIME HAS
NOT PRIORITIZED UP ONLINE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
COMMENT TO SAY. ABOUT A
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND-
I. DIDN'T MEAN TO. I THINK I WAS
PROBABLY FOCUSING ON ECONOMIC
FINANCIAL SOPHISTICATION AS A
BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEY FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS BUT- HI. YOUR
COMMENTS ARE DULY NOTED NEXT.
THEY WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CLEAN ENERGY PACKAGE. AND ALONG
WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER WHO
SPOKE EARLIER WE SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF A COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCE. PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION LINE ITEM IN THE
ENERGY PACKAGE- AND WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PLANNING A
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE. IN
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND ANOTHER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCE PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU
MICHAEL GRANT AND CLEAN BACKUP
POWER- WITH PRIORITY GIVEN TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- AND
FRONTLINE COMMUNITY IS- I ALSO
WANNA KNOW WE SUPPORT THE
DECARBONISATION AND- LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE. AND
HYDROGEN INVESTMENTS ARE
PROPOSED IN THE PACKAGE. I DO
WANT TO NOTE HOWEVER IT THAT
BIOENERGY AND ORGANIC WASTE
BASED HYDROGEN CAN PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT CARBON REDUCTIONS.
AND SO LIMITING HIGH YOU'RE
GOING TO DROP OF GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN IS REALLY
LEAVING A LOT OF SIGNIFICANT GHG
REDUCTION VALUE ON THE TABLE. SO
AS YOU CONSIDER REVISION FOR THE
PACKAGE- IN MAY. I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE A BROADER-
GREEN HYDROGEN DEFINITION THAT
INCLUDES ELECTROLYTIC AND-
ORGANIC WASTE BASED HYDROGEN SO
HOW. DO YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NECKS. MIND EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE MEMBERS STAND TRIAL ON
BEHALF OF A RIVAL AUTOMOTIVE. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ARRIVAL BEEN
INNOVATIVE MANUFACTURER OF
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WITH NORTH AMERICAN
HEADQUARTERS AND MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES IN NORTH CAROLINA.
ARRIVALS CURRENTLY TESTING
PROTOTYPES OF THE TV TRANSIT BUS
THE LAST MILE DELIVERY TRUCK TEN
THOUSAND WHICH WE INITIALLY
DELIVERED TO U. P. S. WITH
ADDITIONAL ORDERS FROM OTHER
COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS AND LOOKS
FORWARD TO INTRODUCING SOME OF
THE VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA
MARKET AS EARLY AS THIS YEAR. AS
SUCH A RIVAL STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY TO INVESTMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS LIKE A
TRIP CAN PLAY IT AGAIN TO
CONVINCE CUSTOMERS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. AT THE SAME TIME
GIVEN THE OVERWHELMING POPPER
WITH POPULARITY OF EGYPT WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT CARD
TO CONSIDER REFORMS THAT WOULD
ENHANCE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THE PROGRAM TO THE CUSTOMERS AND
FLEETS CAN MORE CONFIDENTLY RELY
ON IT WHEN CONSIDERING
PROCUREMENT OPTIONS. ARE SHOULD
ALSO CONSIDER MORE TRANSPARENT
MECHANISMS TO OPTIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF INCENTIVES AWARDED
BASED ON NEED. RATHER THAN A SET
AMOUNT. I THE RIVAL SIGNET
CONCERNED ABOUT RE CAR ACTION TO
EXCLUDE LARGER FLEETS FROM A
TRIP YEAH I'LL DO BUILDING.
WHICH MAKES NO SENSE AT THIS
EARLY STAGE OF THE MARKET. WE
ARE. RECTIFY THIS ISSUE AS PART
OF ITS BUDGET- ACTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ZACKS. NINE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME'S JANET
FLYNN AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE GREEN HYDROGEN
COALITION R. G. H. T. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
WE'RE A EDUCATIONAL EITHER ONE
C. THREE NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION
AND OUR MISSION. IS TO
ACCELERATE MULTI SECTORAL
DECARBONISATION COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENABLE IT CLEAN AND
JUST ENERGY TRANSITION WE
APPLAUD CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO SCALE ELECTROLYTES THERE'S AN
ERROR IN STRONG SUPPORT. I'D
LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY OFFER
SUGGESTIONS TO BUILD ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET TO
HELP ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA AS THE
NATIONAL AND ULTIMATELY GLOBAL
LEADER IN GREEN HYDROGEN THE
GIRL FROM THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THREE INSURANCE
ADVANTAGES THAT POSITION WELL.
FIRST WE HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF
RENEWABLE FEEDSTOCKS WILL ONLY
TREAT CITY AND ORGANIC WASTE AND
MENTIONED BY SOME OF THE EARLIER
SPEAKERS SECONDLY A LARGE AND
DIVERSE. AND SCALABLE OPTIC
MARKET. AN IMPORTANT SCALING.
GLOBAL THANK. WE HAVE DEGENERES
LEADERS ALL LEVEL. GIVEN THAT.
THE CIVIC GESTURE. FIRST CALLUM
BUDGET SHOOTING. AND ALLOW GREEN
PER FOR A FORMER OF BRING
FEEDSTOCKS THANK ONE ELECTOR
RELEASE MAKE SURE YOUR FULL
COMMENTS ARE SUBMITTED TO OUR-
COMMITTEE I WERE ON A TIME.
BASIS HERE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PERSON. ONLY EIGHTY
EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN. ONE MORE
PERSON CENTRED CARE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU GETTING HERE MEMBERS
PERSONALLY GET UP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY KNOWN AS EIGHT EE EE THE
COURTS OF THE POTENTIAL CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
INVESTMENTS AND OUTLINED IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND WE WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO SELECT THE TEN
GAP CURRENTLY NOT ADDRESSED. IT
DOUBLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET IN THE IN CONSTRUCTION
THAT'S BEEN PACKAGED UP LOCATED
ON MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY INVESTMENT
IN EQUITY PROGRAM. ARE RELIABLE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL
TO PROVIDING CAN CONTINUITY AND
CERTAINTY IN THE PROGRAM. ALL
CUT CALIFORNIA CAN REAP THE
BENEFITS. THE PROPOSED ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION TO AID THE
TRANSITION TO THE EMISSION
BUSES. WE ASK THAT THE LEAD BUT
BECOMING SURE THAT THE DOLLAR
ON. AND EASY BASKETS THAT
POSSIBLE WHERE NOT WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE GROUP
STRUCTURE OF THE GRASS.
LIMITATION ON THE NUMBER ABOUT
THAT CAN BE FOUND AT DISTRICT.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
LOOK AT PROVIDING TECHNICAL BUT
THEN TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
DID NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
NAVIGATE THE CURRENT STATE GRANT
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSED THE BUDGET PROPOSED
RECOGNITION THAT OFFSHORE WIND
LONG DURATION STORAGE AND OTHER
TECHNICAL INVESTMENT CAN ALL
PLAY A MEANINGFUL ROLE IN
ACHIEVING A 100% CLEAN RIGHT. WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED HOWEVER THAT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET FALL SHORT
ON AS OF THAT DATE THE
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY AND DEMAND
SIDE RESOURCES THAT WILL KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON FOR COMMUNITIES
AND CRITICAL FACILITIES DURING
PS PS AND THEN. EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS THAT STRESSED THE
GRAND. STAND READY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU
NEED SEX AND CLEAN THE DOLLARS
TO WORK FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY WE ARE OUT OF
TIME IN THE END THIS ROOM
THIRTY. FORTY THROUGH. TWO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE MORE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY. ALAS
HE DID YOU PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS. OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY THIS WAS A- A BIG
PORTION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND THE OVERSIGHT THAT
WE HAVE ONE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR- AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE. WHO STAYED ON
THE LINE AND PROPERTY YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION TODAY-
pAND THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL. REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO IS
ADJOURNED.